[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
yo yo yo yo bonjour à tous mesdames et
messieurs salut le F salut Lucas salut à
tous alors mon Fab on y est c'est
aujourd'hui que ça va se décider ce
match de championnat du monde
qui va nous offrir son vainqueur dans un
match de départage qui va montrer monter
en tension petit à petit à mon avis ça
va cracoter sévèrement aujourd'hui ouais
alors ou pas en fait bizarrement parce
que le fait d'avoir moins de temps de
réflexion ça fait que tu te fais moins
de nez au cerveau
faut plus clique c'est plus ta main qui
peut jouer et
non bon après je sais pas ça c'est juste
une hypothèse mais
peut-être ça pourrait s'ouvrir un épaule
ce côté là quoi justement en tout cas
moi c'est mon grand favori il y a un
pour aujourd'hui Yann
si déjà sur le match quand même plutôt
dominé en tout cas pour moi pour moi bon
il a jamais été mené dans les parties
c'est lui qui a eu les deux balles de
match on va dire quand même partie 12
partie 14 il a pas réussi à les
convertir mais il les a eu il a été un
peu plus maître des ses émotions je
trouve tout de même si il a eu une
implosion totale il s'est quand même
remis et globalement
il a juste simplement été légèrement
plus fort après Ding il peut être
content d'en être là alors peut-être que
ça va le détendre d'être arrivé jusque
jusqu'au tie-break et de prendre aussi
ses 100 cas hein les fameux 100k qui qui
sont déjà tombés
non mais du radis parce que de toute
façon même si ouais peut-être n'est pas
un peu plus favoris quoi ça va pas être
grand-chose et aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
on va voir ça peut vraiment se jouer au
nerf et puis je sais pas une petite idée
dans une ouverture un truc pas encore
jouer que tu te dis bon je la gardais
vraiment sous le coude
tu vois s'il prépare un truc pour les
rapides je me lâche sur un pronom deux
et demi un demi pour ne pas trois
parties merci au revoir
1/2 un demi
un demi merci au revoir
pour moi ça va être ça va être une
défonce à la
on va voir
non mais ça peut tu penses 1 2 2 tu
penses quoi
franchement je sais pas je pense rien
en termes de score c'est dur
quoi score un but
non mais je sais pas moi ça se finissant
en trois plus deux quoi donc pour toi tu
dis 2 2 matchs nul de partout ce que je
voudrais après
presque je pense
je sais pas ce que je pense non mais qui
est plutôt né pour favori mais léger
quoi enfin donc bon
comme ça on est plus clair que ça quoi
bon allez ça part des quatre pour Ding
alors est-ce que tu penses qu'il va
envoyer une catalane parce que ça peut
ne pas être idiot de de
ces trois poisons
ok c'est 3 fois alors ça j'ai pas trop
dans mon range le C3 poison
[Musique]
inversée mais pourquoi jouer ces 5 sur
C3 fin est-ce que tu peux m'éclairer
pourquoi pas juste faire fou F5 et c'est
un système de Londres juste ok avec un
temps de plus choix intéressant de la
part de de Ding euh ouais ouais ce ce ce
jouable ce C3 du coup numéro 2 bah je
l'avais jamais vu à haut niveau ce C3
Fab la première fois que je l'ai le
coing
alors qu'est-ce que ça donne cette
position fable et blonde quand même un
pion de plus un fiancetto qui part
est-ce que les Blancs ont pris
l'avantage ici Fab non mais
c'est une position jouable parce que de
toute façon ton fout de même quand tu te
bouffer ces 5 un jour si tu te le fais
bouffer ça c'est encore une autre
histoire tu vas jouer avec ces quatre
pour essayer de taper sur la grande
diagonale en mode catalane quoi ou une
femme inversé si on veut
donc voilà et puis après les pauvre
encore regagner ce pion C5 puisque les
blancs sont quand même à deux doigts de
te faire B4 et de s'accrocher est-ce
qu'on peut dire que c'est un excellent
choix d'ouverture de la part de
dinglieren là avec les Blancs première
impression comme ça début de départage
une minute de jeu est-ce que finalement
il est bien rentré là dans l'impact
c'est un peu comme au rugby tu es là
voilà le premier pas clash et tu veux
dire qu'il est là qui montre est-ce que
tu penses qu'il vient de mettre le
premier gros tampon là quand même avec
ce choix d'ouverture surprenant et qui
lui donne une position qui lui sied
finalement
ouais bon alors intéressant dans le sens
où
inattendu donc
hyper un petit effet de surprise et
puis après toute façon pas mauvais on
voit que Yann a quand même réussi à
réagir rapidement il a enchaîné les
coups il sait pas laisser mettre à terre
par cette surprise là tout de suite
envoyé c'est ça est-ce que ça avait été
peut-être prévu par ces seconds ah mais
c'est 3 toute façon
oui enfin c'était pas peut-être pas
prévu pour ce match là mais toute façon
tu te dois de couvrir tous les ordres de
coupe aussi les toutes les toutes les
possibilités donc toute façon il avait
déjà étudié ce genre de position alors
après je sais pas à quel point en
profondeur ou pas ça c'est une autre
histoire mais
en tout cas
il va faire quoi Ding il va faire rock
aussi mais si réussi à conserver ce pion
C5 et ce qui serait pas en train de
prendre l'avantage simplement dans cette
ouverture parce que si on garde le plus
envie
de C4 ça peut faire très très mal très
très vite c'est un gros bureau après
alors pour l'instant B4 j'imagine qu'on
se faire pousser par A5 plus ou moins
il le joue il le joue quand même ok bon
bah peut-être à 5 quand même alors là on
a pas d'évaluation les gars là on
regarde pour le moment sans ordi n'a pas
on est à une nu en rapide on le mettra
un petit peu un petit peu plus tard
cavalier G4 ok touche le Food 3 donc où
est-ce qu'on le met
bon soit tu recules
soit tu vends F4 tu provoques 5 et tu
recul je vois pas la subtilité pourquoi
mais tu peux y penser parce que
peut-être que tu dis des cinq plus
vulnérables je ne sais quoi enfin bon
j'ai l'impression que les blancs sont
quand même bien en fait
bon il veut OK
et 5 il veut peut-être H3 ou qu'est-ce
qu'il veut en fait
si on prend puis on prend
puis on prend C3 puis on prend
B7 qui est français 5 et
E5 prix
on peut faire un petit vote est-ce que
vous voulez la barre d'évaluation pour
les rapides pour ceux qui peuvent pas
suivre
je lance un sondage Paul un Sean Paul je
lance pour le rapide je sais pas la
longue j'aime pas parce que voilà mais
là
j'envoie un petit vote
c'est le public qui va décider
de toute façon ça ça se joue pas à ça là
en rapide ça va pas se jouer à les Val
de l'ordi donc je sais pas exactement
ok ça avait l'air clair pour eux dame
c'est 7 et donc bon âme C7 ça vient sur
contre la case E5 pour y installer soins
cavalier soit toujours pousser le pion
je
serai friand d'une poussée au 5 mais bon
ça paraît fort et sur E5 est-ce qu'il
peut vouloir trois retours
comme ça même si je fais 5 4 je tourne
la case des cannes il est juste mort
ravi quoi oui mais bon
et je pense pas qu'il peut y voir enfin
si c'est ça il faut y aller avec les
Noirs quoi j'ai envie de dire
après les pions c'est les pions hein
en tout cas là maintenant quand tu joues
5 tu as ton pion des 5 et tout de suite
sous
tension sous tension
concret ça peut la barre d'habitude je
la mets pas parce que j'aime pas trop
mais là pour le rapide si ça peut aider
les amateurs à avoir l'évaluation
ça peut être on va dire que si un moment
dans la vie où c'est utile c'est
maintenant d'avoir la barre
mais ne vous y fiez pas trop parce que
avoir une position d'un plus facile à
jouer d'un point de vue pratique c'est
plus important ici surtout avec la
pression
et une question il dit quoi alors moi je
comprends pas en fait donc
attends c'est là-bas c'est pion prend
puis on prend cavalier
ok peut-être tu cale un B5 après genre
tu fais pion prend puis on prend enfin
puis on prend d'abord si on prend puis
on prend B5 ok alors
peut-être en B4 en B4 on prend C3
mais je vais prendre des cinq ouais mais
tant pis je te le donne
j'ai un pion de moins j'ai la paire de
fou j'attaque peut-être la Torah mais je
sais pas d'ailleurs mais je te fais
peut-être mais je peux peut-être te
faire E4 à la fin de la variante bon
désolé on va pas bouger les pièces sinon
si ça joue on aura plus rien donc
essayez de suivre j'ai peut-être 4 à la
fin
ça me bloque le fou mais ça bloque le
fou F6 et j'ai quand même mon punto de
plus
bon j'imagine nepo il a plutôt envie de
ça mais je sais pas
bon après il peut aussi reculer
cavaliers maintenant oui puisque
maintenant
D8 fois aussi enfin oui
tu peux avoir du D4 et tu évite un peu
peut-être les cavaliers j'ai 5 un jour
sans faute
ouais bon bah faut
checker les deux quoi
c'est un énorme début de match de la
part de Ding ici
très très gros début de match il joue
vite peut-être qu'il connaît même encore
il envoie les coups et il est précis il
est il est dur sur l'homme
pour moi c'est vraiment tu vois moi il a
mis l'impact là il met il met les
impacts là il met les tampons va falloir
être fort côté côté Yann pour sortir de
ses 22 ok le prix des quatre bon il va
sur le truc qui me semble logique mais
qui est 5 j'imagine c'est la variante
qu'on avait hein j'aime bien ah mais qui
est C3
les bouffées G4 bon caillot 5 et
peut-être tu bouffes je sais pas ouais
mais
plus ou moins
B4 et A3
ouais et sûrement
ou un truc comme ça
mais il connaît
c'est pas Fab je t'annonce que c'est pas
en tout cas il a déjà vu il peut pas
jouer aussi vite le 13e cavalier 3
dans un
fouillis monstre
[Musique]
pression mais j'ai peut-être parce que
judo va taper la colonne B un peu le
pion c'est 5 peut être exposant certains
cas mais là il sera plutôt bien prendre
l'espace une autre question si tu fais
foi F6 que je fais tourcer un que tu
bouffes bouffe cavalier c'est si c'est
ce que je peux me permettre de jouer
pour G5 en se disant alors attention
qu'avec un pion G5 peut-être un jour
j'ai le même endroit j'ai deux tours
et comme ça après je te fais cavalier
des caches je te fixe sur blanc je
ramène ma dame et un moment donné je te
fais G4 tourage 3 enfin en fait je te
défends juste
ouais non j'ai 500 joli coup peut-être
possible non pour essayer de jouer le
mat en fait on voyait une épine comme ça
sur le pion H7 et le bloquer
qui est en difficulté un foie F6 donc
j'ai 5 donc
c'est déjà et avec des plutôt de
positions préférable aux blancs rien de
faire mais plutôt sympathique en plus
facile à jouer attention Yann il va
falloir serrer les vis ici
et pas se faire des boulonner d'entrée
les joueurs qui doivent être exténués il
y a pas eu de jours de repos apparemment
il y avait auparavant il y avait un jour
de repos entre la dernière partie du
match et le et le départage qui
permettait aux joueurs quand même de
souffler là ils se sont envoyés une
partie de 6h30 hier ils ont dû finir
exténuer et dès le lendemain 15 heures
ça enchaîne
c'était marrant parce que Ding a dit en
conférence de presse alors en anglais
peut-être qu'il a mal c'est mal auto
traduit mais il a dit qu'il allait
essayer de se reposer pour avoir la
motivation de jouer
mais je pense juste qu'il a voulu
employer un mot un peu plus que motif je
pense que c'est juste que bah c'est
l'anglais n'est pas sa langue natale et
je pense pas que ce soit le mot
motivation réellement qu'il a voulu dire
exprimer
parce que la motivation il l'a forcément
la motivation d'un titre de champion du
monde femme un titre que nous n'aurons
jamais en tout cas pas aux échecs
[Applaudissements]
là il nous sort une partie magistrale
jusqu'à maintenant il a mangé du lion
et c'est toi qui est si c'est la si la
le G5 mais il va l'avoir un prix va la
voir il va lui envoyer dans la tronche
non madame prend des cinq en fait ça va
mais je sens que c'est plus fort
alors l'ordi d'un équivalent mais pour
moi j'ai 5 et honnêtement plus fort
parce que cette idée d'arriver un jour
pour mater c'est c'est une épine ça fait
plusieurs bonnes choses
et après il faut juste voir si on a le
temps de faire fuer 5 fois 4 mais bon tu
dois défendre ton 4 quand même bah ton
dessin et tu auras peut-être pas le
temps parce que si il prend des cinq il
faut prendre un G4 évidemment tu peux
partir là dessus c'est pas très risqué
pour les blancs et tu te dis ok je vais
retourner 3 enlever le cavalier 6 taper
sur la grande diagonale et faire
pression à long terme mais l'autre elle
a plus me plaît plus en fait on nous
parle de damaka c'est moi je serai
plutôt parti Surger 5 parce que dans ma
carte oui tu protèges le pion G4 donc
c'est un joli coup et en plus tu
peut-être un jour tu fais G5 plus tard
pourquoi pas des retours mais j'ai 5 en
fait je continue à attaquer en fait moi
je voudrais G5 on peut montrer très
rapidement j'ai 5 tours D8 cavaliers des
4 en fait ça cette position là c'est je
pense c'est la position de rêve
c'est l'objectif des blancs tu peux
mettre le fond F3 le ranger deux et
passer etc tu bloques à l'adversaire sur
sur 4 on a le même principe des deux
faiblesses donc le pion des 5 plus le
adverse un peu faible ce qu'on cherche
aux échecs donc c'est cool après oui
donc j'ai 5 c'est au noir de trouver des
bons coups et pas laisser ou sur qu'il y
a des cartes peut-être pas le prendre ou
s'activer en tout cas là ne pas laisser
l'emprise mais on va dire maintenant de
toute façon là bon ok ça y est calcule
un peu il va juger est-ce que je préfère
dans ma cave je préfère G5 parce que je
préfère dame prend des 5 et va calculer
les variantes juger ce qui lui plaît le
plus et choisir en fonction quoi il a
commencé à réfléchir attention là il est
ternu
en espérant qu'une miette n'est pas
venue se glisser dans le mécanisme
d'inglyrène
chemise bleu clair aujourd'hui pour Ding
j'ai l'impression de porter d'autres en
plus où est-ce qu'elle est blanche et la
caméra mais pas mauvaise mais est-ce que
c'est un effet d'optique ce que j'ai
l'impression sur la caméra du haut que
c'est plutôt blanc et sur la caméra du
bas plutôt bleu
mais bon après est-ce que ce ne sont pas
nos yeux qui nous jouent des tours c'est
comme le truc de la robe noir ou or non
je sais plus c'était noir
j'ai pas du tout la robe je sais pas en
fait il y avait un c'était bleu clair ou
ouais je sais pas une photo qui passait
et selon les gens ils voyaient pas de la
même manière quoi moi j'ai un bleu très
clair mais bon après
il y a le soleil qui revient dans les
yeux de l'épaule là-haut sur la photo
elle c'est un signe du destin il l'a eu
mais
il y a pas eu les photographes pendant
les 10 premières raisons ils n'ont pas
rampé devant les joueurs et c'est plutôt
logique un vull important du début de
partie c'est bonne chose que que les
joueurs n'aient pas été dérangé
par ces appareils photos finalement ne
faisait que nous gêner
magnifique scène ici Astana on voit bien
on peut montrer
les chikis en grand les deux hommes qui
se font face seul au monde sur cette
magnifique estrade la chemise blanche
ouais en réalité
pour Ding
qui a 18 sa veste sur le dossier de sa
chaise alors qu'il Yann n'a pas de veste
derrière lui ce que c'est une différence
qui pourra compter
la clim se met en route
tu peux te protéger quoi
c'est vrai et regarde pour le moment il
y a un petit peu de soleil encore on
voit dans l'angle mais quand le soleil
aura disparu la température baissera et
digne pourra peut-être
éviter une fringale
en tout cas les deux hommes qui
réfléchissent on va voir quel est le
choix de Digne qui sent que c'est un
coup important dans cette partie
évidemment il a G5 évidemment il Adam D5
peut-être qu'il regarde aussi damacat
qui a un coup candidat mais il hésite à
mon avis plutôt entre G5 dame prend des
5 de toute façon sur G5 il s'est
pertinemment que Yann répondra tour des
8 donc si il veut jouer G5 il peut déjà
être dans l'anticipation du du coup
suivant ah bah il doit enfin oui il faut
faire
ouais dans ma carte en fait je vois que
c'est la suggestion de la turbinette
mais c'est franchement pas un coup qui
me semble naturel alors peut-être le
meilleur objectif
non mais bon après tu peut-être tu peux
tu peux l'avoir tu peux dans ma cADAM F4
je veux une finale aussi
donc pourquoi ne pas commencer
ça peut aussi être un coup qui regarde
on sait pas on peut pas savoir gère ça
peut
ce que cavalier des cadres j'y crois pas
du tout
prend des cinq
j'y crois pas
ça j'y crois pas
attention digne quand même il a mis le
premier impact si c'est un il peut
réfléchir c'est un coup capital de cette
partie mais attention de ne pas repartir
dans ces travers indigne d'utiliser tout
son temps là après quand il est mal au
temps on le voit un petit peu trembler
ce serait dommage parce que c'est
probablement pas un coup déterminant
s'il hésite entre G5 et d'un A4 il y a
la différence c'est probablement minime
et il faut pas qu'il se mette trop mal
au temps la Ding et qui commence à à
vouloir tout calculer trop contrôler les
événements il faut
laisser le clic parler et envoyer
peut-être un coup et réfléchir garder
son temps pour pour un moment de la
partie où celui-ci sera vraiment
indispensable Fabien ouais ouais alors
après peut-être ça va un petit peu loin
sur il part sur de me prendre des cinq
ce qui va peut-être un peu le rassurer
on va dire c'est qu'ils ont du rajout
dès le premier coup donc il sait que
même si un moment il a 30 secondes il a
un jour c'est plus 10 secondes
contrairement donc à la cadence lente
dans le match où ils avaient un temps
sec
c'est un peu plus
en sauce et enrobé qu'on va dire et donc
ouais dans l'autre cas de figure tu as
deux minutes tu sais que deux minutes
c'est fini quoi et que tu as fini de 50
tu auras plus de 10 secondes là bon tu
chacaux que tu joues tu reprends un peu
donc tu as pas cette épée de Damoclès je
vais tomber
ça a peut-être un côté rassurant donc il
a choisi le dame prend des 5 qui est bon
qui était le coup que j'avais de base
qui est peut-être moins bon que le G5
mais qui a l'air sympathique simplement
pour mettre une pression donc sur B7
avec le fou G2 sur la grande diagonale
et la colonne B ouverte pour les tours
donc évidemment
l'option C5 peut être une farce ou une
faiblesse là je le vois plutôt comme une
force perso puisque il nous aide à
prendre de l'espace énorme du mal à
l'attaquer mais bien sûr si les éléments
tournent à un moment c'est un pion un
peu isolé comme ça donc faudra regarder
mais pour l'instant c'est plutôt cool
alors il y a une question qui me qui me
taraude il vient de passer plus de 5
minutes en rapide pour jouer dame prend
des 5 faut ranger 4 était l'unique coup
pour Yann pourquoi il réfléchit quoi je
sais pas c'est dommage parce que Yann à
ce moment de la partie après cavalier si
il est dans l'expectative il ne sait pas
si Ding va jouer j'ai 5 ou dame prend
des 5 quelque part en lui donnant le
dame prend des seins qui donne la
direction de jeux à ayan et il permet à
Yann de se familiariser avec la position
qui arrive sur le temps de ingirène
c'est quand même dommage Fabien là dans
la gestion du temps ouais ouais surtout
que a priori il sait ce qui va jouer
donc je sais pas si vérifie tu vois s'il
veut repartir sur un truc offensif à
base de Kelly G5 etc ou bon alors moi je
regarderai je sais pas tour B1 par
exemple ça me semble un coup naturel
hyper logique
tu peux je sais pas peut-être d'autres
coups voilà il y a plein de conjoie
il essaye un petit peu à l'image d'hier
d'aller titiller loin titiller le roi et
essayer de mettre Yann ko c'est très
intéressant parce qu'il menace dame 4
Fabien attention
F5 pour se défendre mais on n'aime pas
ce genre de coup parce qu'on a fumé la
case de 6 et les cases blanches et voilà
mais sur dame 4 bon on perd pas encore
le fou mais on va sûrement tâcher de
l'éviter à côté Yann donc qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire [__] de ne va pas à
cause de damoc 4
[Musique]
donc est-ce que il va faire H6 peut-être
rachis c'est ce qu'on peut être tenté de
jouer
cinq dames rangées 4 et on aura affaibli
quand même ces cases blanches avec ce
fou qui pourrait revenir rayonner
attention quand même c'est une des
premières fois dans ce match qu'on voit
le foot de Digne un des plus grand si ce
n'est le meilleur spécialiste actuel des
ouvertures catalanes donc de se fout G2
on se rappelle que c'était qualifié
d'ailleurs contre Nakamura grâce à ce
fou G2 dans une belle catalane dans une
belle catalane où il avait gagné la
dernière partie des candidats pour aller
arracher cette deuxième place finalement
qualificative même si elle était censée
être éliminatoire Fabien comme quoi ça
ne se joue parfois
Lucky looser quelque part donc ce fou
j'ai deux qui brille sur cette diagonale
et je suis pas étonné finalement il
retourne sur les fondamentaux dans les
moments difficiles il faut c'est bien tu
te rattaches à tes plus grandes forces
alors donc tu disais H6
dame prend G4 et peut-être dame 5 à ce
moment là touche la Torse étroite
défoncer 5 tâche touche de toucher FC 5
donc belle dame au milieu
pourrait aussi décider d'aller se
replacer en 6 pour venir
s'appuyer sur le pion c'est ça qui
finalement faire d'une pierre deux coups
regarde tac tac là c'est de l'autre côté
sur H6 qui est le 4 si on a le temps de
prendre E2 avec les Noirs puisque quand
même ce pion est en prise ça c'est du
calcul de votre faut regarder après même
des fois tu as des combines à base de
KFC je te le donne je vous la colonne g
moi j'en sais rien enfin faut calculer
juste tiens je te file le pion je te
mets le courant B1 je te mets le
cailloux
et on y va donc qui avait lieu enfin H6
qui avait le 4 ça se regarde très
clairement et l'autre option c'est
peut-être
tour F8 pour essayer de contrôler cette
case 4 et à toucher le pion au deux
ouais ouais pourquoi pas toi fait vite
mais
pourquoi pas je sais pas c'est l'autre
option c'est pas on ne peut pas lâcher
là-dessus après peut-être même pour 8 un
simple coup comme
3 j'aime pas trop de 3 quand même ça
fait bien peu cette case blanche que
j'ai pas envie d'affaiblir
bref je sais pas on a l'impression qu'il
peut y avoir un truc qui te mette une
tournure parce qu'en fait tu peux même
avoir des fois des gens C4 on revient
vers le cadre on touche j'en sais rien
alors moi je partirai probablement pour
toi à 8
je sais pas tu auras 8 bon en fait
faut regarder qu'il y avait le 4 vous
prenez deux et il va lui ce truc un peu
plus avec les nains le cahier débarque
en D6 est-ce que ton foot tu vas le
mettre en assise tout blindé il mettra
quand même bien hors-jeu et un moment tu
vas te prendre un peu des vagues vers
ton roi
intéressant ok j'ai 5 goding
courageux aussi puisqu'il a fait un
cavalier G5 hier complètement raté
il retourne sur cette cage G5 et c'est
assez bien joué mais aujourd'hui il est
mieux que celui derrière mais celui
d'hier est assez catastrophique celui
d'aujourd'hui et plutôt fort parce qu'il
il a un rebond c'est-à-dire que hier
quand on s'est fait toucher par H6 on se
retrouve un peu bête et le meilleur
solution c'était même de repartir en F3
voilà finalement alors qu'aujourd'hui
ben il vient Angers 5 pour taper H7 mais
aussi pour revenir vers des six qui va
taper B7 donc il a il c'est du 2 ans
d'un quoi
ok donc on s'attend à qui avait le cas
mais dame 4 c'était la prévention qu'on
avait qui est sûrement jouable dans le 4
on disait sûrement H3 G5 dame project
qui devrait aller pour les Noirs si on
rate rien évidemment
[Musique]
qui avait le 4 là intéressant c'est de
pions pour l'initiative un peu Carl
sanasque
en rapide ça peut donner en plus des
positions avec initiative qui sont un
peu plus faciles à jouer
ouais c'est une finale de championnat du
monde Fabien c'est le départage la
pression est à son paroxysme il faut
aussi les avoir bien accrochés pour
envoyer un cavalier 4 rameding enfin je
veux dire des fois juste il fait pas
toujours les meilleurs coups mais le
côté intention de jeu et d'envoyer il a
été là depuis le début du tournoi du
championnat quoi ah là j'ai envie de te
dire il a jamais reculé devant dans
l'adversité 5 m devant la ligne dans but
tu prends pénalité ou tu prends mêlés là
tu as les entraîneurs ils te font les
trois quoi les trois points les joueurs
ils se regroupent et digne non
[Musique]
tu as les entraîneurs non ils ont pris
mêlés
[Musique]
il hésite à le jouer
en fait le truc c'est que sûrement c'est
deux options intéressantes pour lui donc
c'est un coup de butoir là pour pour
Yann et les joueurs n'ont pas à noter
les parties il a pas pris il a pas pris
en E2 il a fait tour 8 donc c'était
sûrement dangereux un sous-prant de
turbo j'ai été avant des 6
il fait ça pour anticiper qu'il y ait
des sites j'imagine et prendre avec la
tour en deux je dirais enfin ça doit
être ça son idée c'est très bien joué de
la part de Yann qui refuse la mêler
et relevez-vous
l'écroule
la mêlé regarde je te redonne pénalité
tu prends les trois ponts tu fais quoi
maintenant donc tu auras 8 très bien
joué il veut peut-être aussi ramener
cette tour sur E5 et peut-être après
l'autre tour sur 8 et contre-attaqué en
E2 c'est très très bien joué de la part
de Yann là les deux joueurs font une
bonne excellente partie quasiment mieux
mais c'est ce que je vais te dire
c'est honnêtement c'est peut-être une de
leurs meilleures parties jusqu'à
maintenant les deux joueurs s'envoient
coup pour coup
ils sont pas en train de se faire ce
dont tu parlais les autres jours les
noeuds dans la tête à hésiter à plus
savoir quoi jouer finalement agafé là
les joueurs
tu as plus de temps pour objectivement
chercher les coups mais tu es aussi
beaucoup plus de temps pour psychoter et
voir des fantômes et des choses qu'il
faut pas voir en fait et là juste il
joue sur leur qualité intrinsèque et
les coûts qui leur reviennent
naturellement quoi c'est de super
joueurs donc forcément c'est c'est bien
et
donc tout recins qui chasse cette dame
qui repart en D2 ok très bien enfin
peut-être tu pouvais partir ailleurs
mais des deux pourquoi pas je veux dire
[Musique]
tu souffles un peu quoi il remarqué
aussi une autre chose regardez tous les
pions sont sur case noir donc contrôle
les cases noires et le fouet sur cases
blanches donc il y a une harmonie dans
la position blanche qui est criante donc
c'est vrai qui échanger ce fou est
casser cette harmonie et peut-être
souligné quelques cases blanches faibles
pour un cavalier c'est c'est dans
l'intérêt de Yann faut acheter un coup
logique après ça force à jouer fou
contre cavalier et deuxième truc c'est
que tu peux aussi tolérer qui relief 6
qui te pète un peu les pions mais bon
Yann il a pas peur j'ai pris F6 mais
ça pourrait quoi faut quand même évaluer
je vais le montrer parce que c'est un
joli coup comme dit Fabien on peut
prendre et échanger donc c'est possible
pour gagner du temps mais on se peut
aussi donner un temps au noir pour
disloquer leur structure de pions allez
le roi et ça peut être un problème non
seulement en milieu de jeu mais aussi en
finale cependant le petit point positif
pour Yann c'est que c'est dans un 3
contre 3 donc il semble si jamais on
échange beaucoup de pièces ils puissent
tenir la nul dans une finale malgré une
structure de pions légèrement délabrée
c'est pas ce qu'il a joué il a joué tour
des 8 alors ouais bah du coup qui est
ici
ça appelle cavalier des 6 et qui
l'envoie tempo oh la Dink qui met une
pression de malade ouh oh la grimace de
Yann oh la grimace de Yann Fab oh il a
pas l'air bien
ah salut ça lui fait pas oh regarde oh
il est pas bien oh il est pas bien
Yannick
peut-être sa position le même mal il a
peut-être raté quelque chose dans une
variante Yann qui n'a jamais été mené au
score encore dans ce match c'est
peut-être la première fois que Ding est
devant finalement en quelque sorte c'est
la première fois qu'il a l'avantage dans
une partie alors qu'il y a égalité au
score on l'a eu à la rentrée
ouais
ça a été très sporak exactement
c'est la première fois qu'il a vraiment
une occasion là de prendre l'avantage
regardez la jauge qui vole il sort sa
meilleure game du championnat en au
moment au moment clé et et là où il a le
moins de temps finalement j'ai
l'impression qu'il ne joue que les
meilleurs coups en fin détendu Ding oh
si il continue sur ce rythme là il sera
champion du monde
bon après faut voir la réaction en face
quand on est pour aller blanc et puis
c'est là il a pas encore perdu mais oui
effectivement c'est Ding joue que ce
niveau de jeu
qu'il allait vitesse d'exécution et
force des coûts c'est pas mal alors toi
5 rares qui part rappelez-vous quand
même que c'était celui qui avait mis fin
à la série d'inviens civilités de Magnus
Carlson en départage Magnus Carlson qui
pendant 10 ans avait tenu contre tout le
monde et gagner tous ces départages et
dingly arène était venu le chercher à la
syncopie Cup et il avait soulevé sans le
toucher il avait mis à terre
il avait massacré il avait fait un match
de départage d'anthologie d'ingly Rennes
et là il est encore en train de de
sortir le grand jeu le joueur chinois
bon après écoute on va voir parce que
c'est pas fini toi H5 Yann qui veut
aller te faire peur faire cavaluer au
sein qui est le F3 te dis ah j'ai une
colonne vert vers ton roi j'arrive alors
bon normalement les blancs le temps de
réagir sur quel lieu 5 même 300 j'ai un
coup comme F4 pour chasser ce cavalier
bien recontrôler F3 etc mais
bon c'est pas fait encore mais pour
l'instant ça joue bien
en tout cas Fabien Yann qui prend le bon
choix pratique de dire ading ok était
mieux ok tu vas peut-être la gagner mais
tu vas peut-être la perdre aussi oui qui
veut il veut retourner la pression là il
prend il prend tous les impacts il subit
pour le moment Yann en ce début de
partie mais il veut il veut renverser la
pression avec cette tourage 5 et même si
objectivement il est moins bien comme le
dit Fabien imaginez ce cavaler qui
arrive en F3 fou prend F3 fou prend F3
tout rache un match serait imparable
exactement donc débile mais kb5 qui a
value 5 kg prend C7 bah on va pouvoir
commencer à il y a la tour en prise s'il
y avait pas la tour en prise c'est juste
pour illustrer là il y a malheureusement
dame prend des huit qui sauve mais c'est
juste pour dire que si on réussit à
installer cette ce fouet 3 et cette
tourage 5 le mat pourrait facilement
devenir imparable donc ça peut tourner
très très vite aussi en faveur de Yann
il faut que Ding trouve les coups
exactement donc ça force
à réfléchir trouver des trucs alors
Mathieu il nous donne une belle
suggestion dans le chat dieudames c'est
de un beaucoup profilactique qui quelque
part s'enlève du vis-à-vis de la tour D8
sur un coup comme fois je crois ça va
pas du tout tu te fais fermer la tour
le fameux F4 toujours qui empêche qu'il
f-3 et qui vient recontrôler les cases
blanches finalement donc c'est un
beaucoup de contrôle qui empêche le
contre-jader
alors qu'est-ce qu'il veut sur cavalier
5 il y a plus F4 attention
Ding sur cavalier 5 quel est son idée
sur cavaliers
ne vous embêtez pas avec la jauge parce
que
l'ordinateur réussie pas à calculer en
fait c'est pour ça que je vous dis la
jauge il faut pas la prendre au pied de
la lettre mais ouais tant bien c'est que
c'est dangereux parce que ça enlève une
tour qui contrôlait F3 avec F4 il a
décidé de la contrôler avec la tour C3
donc je comprends ce qu'il fait
attention
à même un coup comme dame français 5
peut
fonctionner là ça fonctionne pas parce
qu'on touche la tour évidemment et qu'on
réussit à s'en sortir mais attention si
cette tour C3 venait à quitter la
troisième rangée ça peut faire maths en
deux coups c'est quand même sacrément
dangereux ce qui est en train de faire
digne
c'est très compliqué faut réfléchir
enfin parce qu'en fait genre les dings
et pas loin de te dire je vais gagner
entre quelques coups parce que tu as
baissé ton l'air bon il y a le vis-à-vis
mais si tu fais la F4 en couple comme ça
et bien joué il enlève l'option et ça
mêle qui est des 6 à mal maintenant
parce que sur ses propres cavaliers
c'est pas fini la variante parce que
dame prend des 6 dame prend des 6
peut-être B prend à 7 tours D8 et tour
B8 et on va Adam et on va Adam mais pas
le temps de tourner on est cloué oh là
là Fabien mais alors est-ce qu'il veut
pas c'est promis à prendre et faire ta
varier
il doit souffler qu'est-ce qui vient lui
et là regarde le requin regarde il joue
la gagne regarde regarde-le regarde-le
si balaye les chiquer des yeux oh il est
là oh il est là oh il est
oh c'est trop oh c'est trop la petite
pause l'élève le maître qui parle à son
élève ici oui bon tu t'es amusé 15-20
minutes en championnat du monde mais bon
alors qu'est-ce qui peut nous faire le
Ding
UE
[Musique]
le café
oh non mais bientôt il y a des mecs qui
vont lui apporter un croissant quoi non
mais bon regarde non mais c'est trop
regarde-le non mais regarde c'est un
spectacle
qui tient vaguement mais qui tient
peut-être
attaque le cavalier
ouais
OK
peut-être des prises en B6
intermédiaires
et je me disais j'ai changé avec la tour
H5 un peu muret mais tu peux reprendre
la tour en 6 et tu gagnes un tempo sur
la dame elle veut pas rester sur mur
donc ok faire autre chose la c'est
toujours la même histoire on se reprend
le truc qui va dame
super compliqué
super compliqué c'est quoi c'est B7 ou
bien B7
[Musique]
et nulle peut-être ou plus pour les
blancs non même pas de plus en plus
dame
boum ouais faible ça va pas du tout
ouais ça peut rentrer là-dedans enfin
cela dit
ok dur mais fin d'un coup Ding doit
vraiment défendre et comme on dit les
mouches ont changé d'âne
super
il a senti évidemment le cavalier F3
tout le monde
et nous on y arrivait pas on a eu les
dames prends ces cinq les machins AB A B
tempo regarde le regarde le marlou
regarde oh le petit regard dans les yeux
oh le petit oh il fait mal hein celui-là
oh il fait mal oh il fait mal il est
content
il est content là tu as vu il a cherché
du regard et viens prendre madame si tu
as le courage
viens la prendre il peut pas vous avez
compris il y a cavalier F3 avec le mat à
venir et sur Roy F1 qui évite l'échec et
qui prend des deux échecs et bouffe la
tour B1 donc
regarde-le il s'étire il s'étire je
crois que c'est un soulagement pour lui
[Musique]
regarde comme il est fort
oh la détermination dans le regard de
Yann c'est
incroyable ce qu'il est en train de lui
faire oh il est en train de lui marcher
dessus psychologiquement là aussi il a
gagné c'est c'est un KO là il va prendre
du miel mais
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que digne a pu rater AB
tu penses pas il a cherché du regard
pour le voir il a pas raté parce que
sinon il aurait pensé qu'il était
gagnant
mais ce qui est sur la c'est qu'il a
pris un coup de massue et se tourbé hein
quelle erreur mais bon c'était tellement
bien vu de la part de gamme après c'est
un coup logique ouais il se trouve qu'il
va pas et que il arrive il fait la garde
dans les fins pour avoir des F4 mais
bon après vouloir faire tourner un et au
4 pour défendre latéralement ça avait sa
propre logique et c'est sûr on va tout
voir mais oui
et on peut pas tout voir on peut pas
tout voir mais oui
disons qu'il a pas voulu jouer à la peur
au ventre et il a tout à fait raison
digne il a voulu ah mais il faut
l'initiative et mettre des coups à des
aquarium le finir Yann qui te sort une
défense et ouais donc là le seul coup a
priori c'est B5 s'en aller laisser notre
Dame en prises pour apprendre la dame
noire mais donc tout reprend les deux ou
d'un seul après faut calculer mais on
peut faire 32 qui semble le coup le plus
logique place la tour sur la seconde
rangée et c'est les noirs qui sont
actifs après de là à gagner on va voir
parce que c'est une histoire en fait le
truc qui se passe c'est que dès qu'on
joue à F4 et qu'on chasse le cavalier on
on renverse toute la pression en tout
cas on l'assumait peut-être que le roi
va être faible ou enfin ça devient moins
agréable parce qu'il y a eu avant
chasser le fou puis G4 puis enfin je
sais pas comment disons c'est pas gagné
pour rien mais il passe dans le dans la
position du chasseur quoi
incroyable dingly Rennes une nouvelle
fois sous une pression monstre qui
trouve les seul s coups en défense ça
aurait été sa grande force pendant tout
le match à Digne même en glissade à deux
doigts de craquer il vient il trouve la
seule défense on a une vraie finale de
championnat du monde ici Mesdames et
Messieurs les deux hommes ce livre et
jouent bien en même temps enfin on a on
a deux hommes au meilleur de leur forme
meilleur de leur force
il y en a qui a un petit peu déçu quand
même allez on voit que
il pensait peut-être l'avoir emporté
avoir enfin enterréding Irène mais une
nouvelle fois
attraper et qui essaye de filer comme ça
défend en face il faut
faire des bancs sont installés par Ding
alors Yann à mon avis va garder les
dames tu penses ah ouais parce qu'il a
déjà réussi une fois
l'embrouiller dans le roi l'embrouiller
ouais donc un coup comme d'hab ça tu
penses je pense qu'il va décaler la dame
et qui va essayer de tout garder après
ça double tranchant parce que si son
attaque se fait refouler ses pièces sont
très mal placées finalement ce marche un
peu dessus tu reprends des deux c'est le
choix de la sécurité mais bon en même
temps tu reprends les deux c'est super
B6 c'était une finale
mais tu reprends des deux il y a active
après faut avoir une suite dans dans la
variante mais peut-être tu reprends les
deux qui prend ses sept quelle Détroit
on se replace en attaque F2 avoir
mesdameset est logique aussi je pense
c'est deux choix légitimes qui qui
s'entendent et ça lui de voir ce qu'il
préfère le monde quelque chose de très
joli sur tout reprend des deux cavaliers
français 7 dans le chat on nous propose
pour C2 mais cette fois en fait ça
marche pas parce que tu reprends tour
cavalier F3 en fait on n'est pas tenu de
le prendre alors bien sûr si elle [__]
F3 on matte mais il peut faire bref tout
à l'heure il y avait une dame en des
deux comprenez qu'on revait des
fourchettes c'était donc c'était
[Musique]
un bon c'est pour ça que c'était aussi
dur à faire marcher c'est aussi pour ça
qu'Anna était très fort parce que il a
il a multiplié les thèmes tactiques
c'est pas c'était pas que cavalier F3
c'était cavalier F3 avec elle prend des
œufs
into fourchette une tour fourchette
une en fait
donc 5 jouets Yann qui réfléchit
digne qui a subi la pression mais la
pression il aboie aujourd'hui Ding il
est très très bien en défense très très
fort une nouvelle fois quand il s'agit
de de sauver les demi points de
s'accrocher aux branches
mais bon je suis content de ce qu'on
voit parce que c'est une bonne partie on
voit des jolies coups c'est serré et
donc c'est cool et les joueurs sont
expressifs c'est c'est un beau combat
auquel auquel on assiste peut faire un
petit tour sur la grande caméra pour
essayer de ressentir peut-être un peu
mieux l'atmosphère encore que je trouve
qu'on qu'on ressent pas grand chose avec
cette caméra on va rester peut-être sur
les gros plans des joueurs trop éloignés
un peu vu drone enfin drone vite fait
il fallait mettre des drones qui qui
surplombe qui vole mais silencieux
des drones feutrésil cherche l'âne qui
cherche un gros avantage alors attention
ça ça peut parfois jouer des tours dans
les parties on recherche un énorme
avantage il n'y est pas et on croit
confortable on va chercher un truc qui
n'existe pas ça arrive plus vite te dire
pas tellement logique de de chercher
dans une telle position mais oui parce
qu'il doit penser qu'il un gain et nous
on le sait avec la jauge on est Josette
quelque part on sait qu'il y a pas de
gains et là on voit Yann qui cherche qui
cherche qui cherche regardez ces petits
mouvements de tête c'est c'est la
vitesse de calcul là c'est des variantes
qui passent
et je me dis qu'ils vont enchaîner alors
est-ce que c'est qu'il y ait des 300
coups que j'aime bien parce que ça
attaque F2 ça libère la Torah 5 pour
repartir je sais pas de l'autre côté
vers à 5 verset 5 vers quelque part
mais c'est sûrement pas le seul coup
qu'il y a eu des trains c'est un joli
coup ça tape un pion surtout que si
spion disparaît c'est sympa ça nous
donne des cases
et on dit ok 3 dans le chat on propose
un coup comme Tour Eiffel tu mets des
barbares tu mets les barbeles mais
passif mais oui enfin je veux dire je
suis pas sûr je vais gagner surtout
enfin mais je peux regarder fouet de ce
qui se passe je peux penser à Tours
c'est 5 et me redéployer je peux faire
des
après attention parce que le cavalier il
a une case de dessin elle est jolie la
case des 5 elle tape B6 et 3 bam je
défends et je reviens tout de suite
peut-être avec un rebond autre part
parce que ça touche le roi donc
attention les blancs en fait ils sont un
deux un coup et demi enfin un coup même
d'avoir un de multiples possibilités de
de renforcement de leur position ah non
mais sans rien faire ce cavalier c'est 7
qui semble complètement hors jeu là
actuellement et pas il a une place
[__] ils bondit il jaillit
d'ailleurs c'est assez marrant alors là
c'était pour les plus débutants mais que
de se dire que c'est plus compliqué
parce que oui elle est en B7
ça lui prend les trois coups quoi enfin
qui est juste à côté que de venir un F4
en E3 qui sont deux très beaucoup plus
loin mais il vient il
aille genre d'Antoine Dupont
il est bien il est pas si mal placé et
cette tour H5 comme tu disais cavalier
des trois là où j'apprécie énormément
ton coup c'est que ça va permettre
peut-être de repartir cette attaque sur
le roi qui a été très utile à un moment
donné il faut je crois donc il part sur
autre chose
pourquoi pas mais la tourne elle m'a
l'air un petit peu mal placé
de vouloir enchaîner avec cavalier j'ai
quatre tourages 2 essayez de faire des
tours sont tout pour ranger par le
cavalier c'est un schéma qu'on voit très
rarement quasi jamais son habitude de
voir les tours du même côté alors
attends
[Musique]
de ranger tu vas te faire un sandwich
ouais mais couper par un pion voilà donc
est-ce que le pion est prêt en sandwich
ou justement évite alors
j'aurais peur avec les Blancs parce
qu'il a dû en route on prend aussi si
votre mater plus ou moins il veut te
faire tourner un tour à champ et tu es
enfermé en jet d'eau non ça je suppose
aussi ouais
mais déjà bon faut la voir ok donc pas
tant qu'on B6 si on fait
quatre pardon attaque le pion tout
récemment la variante que j'avais en
tête c'était ça tu auras 2 et Tour
Eiffel
mais j'ai plutôt l'impression que je
vais pouvoir te menacer ton FK touche
ton cavalier H5 tu reprends G43
[Musique]
je suis content moi aussi je repars bah
peut-être nul peut-être nul mais c'est
comme ça enfin je veux dire
[Musique]
et au lieu de 3G 2 aussi
et au pire bon déjà j'ai un tu peux plus
ou moins répéter ce qui se passe enfin
elle va parvenir à achetera toute seule
ça c'est mais
moi j'ai deux je ferai sûrement en fait
si je le ferai
entourage de échec donc tu dois
réfléchir moi le premier truc que j'ai
que j'ai vu sans sans regarder quoi que
ce soit c'est que sur cavalier G4 tour
F3 tout rage le Tour Eiffel c'était mon
idée de base
et j'aime pas mon cavalier qui est loin
donc je me serais dit j'ai pas m'attaque
pas directement donc je vais utiliser
mon coup pour revenir en défense logique
assez logique aussi les deux sont
logiques c'est une question de goût mais
des cinq
c'est pas mal cette attaque bêtises tu
remplaces ton cabin mal placé tu veux
recoulisser tu vois que tu tiens avec ta
Torah ta tour Eiffel
parce qu'on a vu une vente de nulle
quand il y avait toutes les tours là et
donc
attention quand même on en a pas encore
parlé on en a pas reparlé depuis un
moment mais plus que 3 minutes 20 pour
Ding ça commence on commence à rentrer
dans la zone que j'aurais appelé
dangereuse de monnaie le monite arrive
parce que la 320 on l'a déjà vu il avait
craqué dans une dans une partie avec les
Noirs où il avait envoyé un H4 on
l'avait vu un closer attention
je crois que tu as pas trop le choix
c'est la salle case
disponible pour pour cette tour et
peut-être qu'il veut jouer un tour B5 en
réalité venir clouer un peu jouer un peu
cavalier et et se débarrasser des pièces
offensives adverses est-ce que ce serait
pas ça l'idée de de Ding dyrène possible
et en plus il est protégé par le
cavalier donc il retrouve une une
harmonie dans la position complètement
différente et il joue de manière très
offensive Ding en fait il joue pas la
nuit il joue le gars pour ça je voulais
dire peut-être que il a vu les tours
francophone
parce que regarde maintenant imaginons
une tour qui débarquera en dessin un
échange et regarde-moi il sera à 3 cases
de dames bah ouais ou cavalier Franck et
prend B6 tu as le pion a passé et toutes
les pièces noires allez le voir qui sont
plus du bon côté de l'échiquier et qui
sont quand même un peu bizarre
regarde-moi ces deux tours une tour à
deux une tour en H5 est-ce que tu fais
mon grand alors bon la bonne nouvelle
pour nepo c'est que cette histoire des
deux elle est importante elle coule plus
F2 donc il y a pas F4 pour l'instant qui
enfin serait une menace en temps normal
donc genre de situation donc pour
l'instant il tient plus ou moins de
manière tactique artificielle mais
palmarès de la tour je cours un pied ou
quoi enfin oui mais palmarès de l'autre
tour
ouais c'est ça
mais peut-être ouvert tourger 5 du coup
tu vois pour enlever ce cahier de 5 et
retrouver
quelque chose
mais tu es quand même ouais c'est c'est
un peu bizarre quoi les tours on
croirait des fous qui se touchent je
sais pas comment dire mais une tour en
G5 une tour en D2 c'est c'est très
artificiel
j'ai pas du tout pensé mais alors
attends est-ce qu'il le menace vraiment
admettons que je fasse un coup comme
tour des cinq tours
E5
et ça a l'air complètement forcé
par un match nul vous allez le voir
arriver je pense que c'est le seul coup
parce que si fait si je pense des
cavaliers F4 vont arriver il va il vient
blinder son il va te gagner B6 et puis
ben après tu vas pas passer le roi avec
si peu de pièces mais tourner à chat ça
menace maths pour H5 en H2
et ça a l'air imparable sauf que il y a
cavalio 7 échec font ça enlève ce roi de
bon le roi de bouger tout reprend le 5
et là la tour H5 elle peut pas à la fois
prendre 5 et défendre sa copine à H1
du coup
après c'est vrai que peut-être on
s'entend pas très bien je sais pas ça va
faire nul
répétition tourage de échec et match nul
les deux hommes se serrent la main belle
partie quelle partie
quelle échange entre les deux hommes
partie de très haut niveau franchement
et l'un et l'autre ont bien défendu
quand ils ont été un peu en danger vers
le
tourage 5 et compagnie de bien alors le
B6 fantastique et Helling quand il se
prend ça il a pas tremblé et le cavalier
il a toute la défense et là il a tout vu
qu'il y ait des cinq cavaliers 5 une
partie mesdames et messieurs qui a
touché les sommets on est content de on
est vraiment heureux là du niveau de jeu
c'est pas du tout la même chose que ce
qu'on a vu en longueur non beaucoup
mieux
ça a joué l'acier et la pause ne va pas
être longue mesdames et messieurs ne
partez pas puisque ça relou dans 10
minutes donc tu as trouvé en profiter
pour mettre les petites pages de pub
habituelle soufflez-nous même et revenir
en forme pour la deuxième partie de ce
match alors on va mettre à jour le score
le score on va mettre les hommes du bon
côté puisque ça va changer de couleur
on va changer le nom de la partie on va
tout mettre en place comme ça au retour
on est on est tranquille partie 2 sur 4
machin 4 le
pour que si nous avions
des nouveaux
ils soient pas perdus
donc on a partie de sur quatre le
premier à deux points et demi gagne
demi-1/2 et les chiquets de la première
partie donc pour les blancs
effectivement donc c'est tout bon
allez mesdames et messieurs à tout de
suite et on revient tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs nous sommes de
retour pour pour vous jouer un mauvais
tour on va voir lequel des deux entre
Ding et nepo va réussir à jouer un
mauvais tour à son adversaire on va déjà
aller se placer Fabien sur sur la
nouvelle partie qui devrait rapidement
commencer alors est-ce que on est en
capacité d'avoir notre premier bug avec
une partie qui ne s'ouvre pas attendre
on va attendre en tout cas quelle
première partie on a vécu enfin
incroyable très bonne niveau de jeu
l'intensité ça jouait vite et bien
c'est tout ce qu'on veut tout ce qu'on
demande et nickel très belle pub pour
pour déjà rapide pour l'instant
sardache qui nous demande est-ce que ça
peut finir à cette partie ou alors ça
joue tous les départages alors ça joue
là c'est un bo4 pour le moment il va y
avoir quatre parties donc là un demi un
demi il faut marquer 2,5 points pour
remporter ce match de départage donc
quoi qu'il en soit à la fin de cette
partie ça jouera un minimum encore deux
parties même ah ouais enfin encore deux
parties
qui reviennent alors là de nuit champion
mais
voilà donc par contre s'il y a deux deux
il continue avec un autre match en blitz
parti plus rapide
du radis c'est très serré quoi
mais bien sûr tout peut tourner très
vite
un mauvais coup et hop ça glisse il peut
y avoir un chaos en fait donc là la
prochaine partie admettons que j'en sais
rien moi il y a une gagne avec les
blancs sur une gaffe de dingue et
complètement explosé c'est pour ceux qui
ont regardé le Tour de Romandie hier
c'est un petit peu le mano à mano entre
entre yetz et Thibault Pinot et Thibault
on pensait qu'il allait revenir sur yetz
petit coup d'accélération et un peu trop
tard ouais mais après et puis tu
exploses tu fais plus les efforts quoi
oui bah si tu vois que tu reviens pas tu
reviens pas
donc ça peut ça peut très bien terminer
sur chaos ce match donc là pour le
moment je n'ai pas la partie donc ça ça
va être compliqué
elle devrait arriver après on peut
commenter à l’œil mais bon on est un peu
loin on peut commenter au visage c'est
le faire Fabien
Ding qui a double ses pièces avant avant
la partie à double aux échecs ça veut
dire remettre une pièce bien au centre
de sa case tu la repasse bien comme il
faut et d'ailleurs je crois que les
Anglais disent j'adoube oui aussi
le mot international tout à double
finalement épice a trouvé une pièce on
peut on peut le dire Fabien
en passant c'est en passant quoi en
passant
il est là Ding il revient en premier sur
l'échiquier est-ce que ça veut dire quoi
que ce soit ou pas non pardon est-ce que
ça veut dire quelque chose de venir en
premier comme ça s'installer est-ce que
ça dénote d'une sérénité ou au contraire
de stress ou on n'en sait rien en fait
en tout cas les deux hommes qui serrent
la main il y a du respect entre ces deux
hommes il se vivent un combat intense
depuis trois semaines évidemment au-delà
du combat il y a aussi du respect entre
eux oui oui bon ça a l'air même chaque
fin de partie
il se il se parle un peu il débrief
rapidement
[Musique]
il est vert mais il part pas dégoûté en
renversant tout quoi enfin voilà donc il
se comporte tous très bien et
après je connais pas leur relation je
sais pas s'ils en ont à côté mais en
tout cas oui on sent qu'il y a une qui
parle là c'est haut il part il revient
il fait un aller-retour il a le sourire
digne non tu as pas le droit d'aller
attention et ce qu'il a voulu aller
faire un tour rapide aux toilettes qui
lui a été refusé il peut faire ce qu'il
veut en fait enfin si il y va excellente
commencer au pire l'arbitre appuie sur
la pendule et les pojou et ça envoie ça
joue E4 5 cavaliers F3 cavaliers C6
Fabien on va avoir une énième espagnole
alors berlinoise non espagnol et joueur
qui joue sur leur point fort et c'est
logique alors est-ce qu'on va voir
finalement aujourd'hui un Marshall dans
ces championnats du monde ça fait
longtemps qu'on en a plus vu et non il y
a un qui refuse de nouveau le Gambie
Marchal que vous avez fait c'est force
mars
Carlsen Yann qui fait une petite grimace
qui essaie de se rappeler on va voir ce
qu'il a prévu aujourd'hui 3 à 4 c'est 3
à 4 OK
et je trouve alors pourquoi faut des 7
le bon coup de toute façon à 4 ça
attaqué le pion B5 donc fallait bien
défendre cette tour où la bouger ils
font des sept mieux que B7 parce que les
longs déjà joué D3 et donc tu t'ennuures
un peu alors que là on décède tu
contrôle plus de cases notamment la case
F5 aussi peut-être qu'un cavalier saute
dessus un jour
et il repart avec son concept de fouet 3
alors c'était pas dans cette position là
mais c'est un coup qu'on avait vu
l'autre jour qui est pas fait grande
impression mais qui est peut-être un peu
plus logique ici puisqu'on avait vu Ding
qui avait rapidement réussi à
contre-attaquer au centre finalement
et cette fois-ci avec le fond en D7
c'est peut-être plus difficile de jouer
ses plans avec C5 et 5 ouais alors c'est
toi le spécialiste de l'espagnol Fabien
je parle sous ton sous ton contrôle
mais après il peut aussi partir sur du
H6 story 8 Wi-Fi restez un peu comme ça
après toujours pareil un de jouer avec
ce C5
ça fait bien qu'à ce dessin qu'on a vu
que c'était un thème dans ce match
et là t'as pas donné l'adresse du Kib
bien tu as pas encore joué C3 donc
est-ce que tu as envie de si vite lui
donner le trajet
le trajet vers la case D5 la dernière
fois le pion était déjà en croit
lorsqu'il avait mis le fond en E3 et
c'était peut-être un peu moins
harmonieux ici c'est vrai qu'il peut
encore jouer pour cavalier C3 cavaliers
D5
mais bon digne je sais pas je sens qu'il
va rester fidèle sa manière je sais
position
alors là il y a peut-être aussi une part
de bluff parce que on sait qu'il aime
jouer cavalier à 5 et c'est 5 ding ding
le C Ding c'est que ne possède et n'est
possible
mais ça je vais me demander est-ce qu'il
y a pas Béa parce que tu as le fond des
sacre quand même tu tu le défends bien
non alors ça c'est intéressant c'est
rare qu'on voit ce cette idée dans les
Espagnols Fabien de cavaler à 5b prend à
4 ouais ça peut arriver bien derrière ce
qui joue vite donc il attaque le
cavalier à 5
alors quoi c'est 5 ou qu'elle est
B7 alors là on est en train de
s'enferrer côté digne dans une
préparation maison de l'équipe de l'Épau
attention danger
attention danger pour pour Ding il va
falloir être très solide dans la tête et
regarde Yann de nouveau le langage
corporel du chasseur ça il remet la
pression digne qui subit beaucoup qui
subit beaucoup là il a subi la fin de de
la première partie il subit d'entrer une
préparation adverse mais qui n'était pas
réellement évitable puisque
Yann évidemment et celui des deux le
mieux préparé et là c'est l'équivalent
de d'une bonne première balle de service
pour pour faire une analogie pour ceux
qui suivent un peu moins les échecs il a
servi fort et euh
qui va qui va renvoyer la balle
évidemment mais qui va être qui va être
sous pression dans les champs
pour un deuxième bon coup de raquettes
etc donc là que la cinquième attaquer il
est reparti en C6 alors pourquoi pas moi
je pensais être rabaissaad pour mourir
verset 5 mais c'est si tu veux dire
c'est quand même une case possible
est-ce que les Blancs veulent toucher au
X2 et faire genre
menaçant entre guillemets de récréation
A4 et si ça se passe comme ça tu es
mieux avec les Blancs structure ou
est-ce qu'il va faire qui va lisser C3
pourquoi pas qui menace quand même le
pion à 4 passages j'imagine que dans les
deux cas de figure Ding son prochain
coup que ce soit fousset 4 ou cavalier
C3 ses cavaliers des cartes à mon avis
peut-être qu'il y a eu B4
d'accord parce que tu aurais bouché la
vie du Fou et cavalier BK tu viens taper
une fois en a deux et surtout c'est 5
après je sais pas trop bah tu couvres un
peu la case des 5 mais bon c'est un
choix après je peux pas te dire que
c'est mieux ou moins bien c'est juste on
peut l'envisager quoi alors on va on va
voir comment ça se passe cavaler ses 6
il a joué cavalier C3 justement le coup
que tu proposais Fabien et donc
maintenant cavalier D4 ou cavaliers B4
semble les les deux options pour
pour Ding ça c'est les deux coups qui
permettent de protéger le pion à 4
simplement
parce qu'en fait le problème pour les
Noirs c'est que si les blancs prennent
ce pion A4 ils ont une structure de 7
pions bien groupés les noirs sont 6
groupés et puis on assiste tout seul
donc ça sera toujours une faiblesse
parce qu'il est sur une colonne ouverte
pour les blancs qui pour mettre la
pression avec la tour un fond C4 double
et les tours triplé peut-être avec la
dame ou se mettre à jour en E2 faire ces
trois D4 attaquer là-bas donc c'est une
faiblesse chronique et pour toute la
partie on n'aime pas en fait c'est pas
terrible de faire ça donc Ding va
essayer de pas le laisser faire ou si ça
arrive qu'il y a des compensations à
côté
pour justement pas laisser les blancs
avoir les mains libres de faire tout ce
que je disais quoi alors est-ce qu'on a
une option celle de jouer à 3
vu tout ce que tu viens de dire alors
peut-être peut-être peut-être sa
réaction fait Brand a au moins chacun
son isolé et sera plus dur d'attaquer à
6 et si tu fais B3 et que tu récupères
le pion dans un deuxième temps mais tu
vas quand même tempêtrer les pièces et
il faudra un certain temps va être très
moche alors après si on imagine que dans
un futur lointain on repasse par bien on
fait ces trois D4 ou B4 peut-être mais
c'est dur sur la 3 de faire B3 quand
même surtout que le fou 7 le si on
réussit à jouer dessin parce que quand
tu mets quand vous mettez un pion en B3
vous Bouchez la vue du Fou sur des 5
donc si on fait A3 B3 et qu'on réussit
dans un deuxième temps à jouer D5 ce
pion à 3 il est pas encore perdu pour
les Noirs donc ça peut être une option
de jeu à trois pour le prendre enfin B3
j'y crois pas trop quoi ouais mais du
coup ce qu'il faut le prendre non mais
tu le prends et tu joues pour cahier des
cinq et puis voilà mais c'est vrai que
tu as plus histoire de pion à 6 mais
mais avoir ça en fait bon quand même les
blancs pour les prendre à 4 il faut
sûrement qu'ils perdent du temps donc ce
que tu le rends si facile
mais voilà préparation de Yann pour pour
cette partie là c'est encore très bien
joué il arrive avec une nouvelle idée
fraîche c'est pas mal hein et qui met
immédiatement la pression sur Ding
difficile à jouer d'un point de vue
pratique et les Blancs n'ont pas
réellement de risque donc c'est très
très bien joué de la part de Yann qui a
l'air content d'être rentré dans cette
variante et qui peut et qui doit une
fière chandelle assez secondaire
qui lui offrent sur un plateau d'argent
une partie un petit peu plus simple avec
les Blancs maintenant ce sont les deux
joueurs qui sont les pilotes dans de
cette équipe et qui vont devoir réussir
à concrétiser les avantages ou des
avantages de de leur équipe respective
Ding là qui est un peu laissé à lui-même
mais on sait qu'il est capable d'aller
très vite avec son engin ouais non mais
il peut trouver
[Musique]
c'est assez subtil c'est pas mal tu vois
je sais pas si il a pris la bonne
décision de faire bipron à 4 mais ça
coupe envie de regarder tu as mis le
fond des 7 tu te dis ok et
tu vas pas investir 20 minutes dans une
partie de 25 minutes dès le coup numéro
10 pour
être sûr de conséquence et digne qui
décide pour la première fois de cette
partie de prendre du temps dans un
rapide on a deux trois moments comme ça
on peut vraiment se plonger dans la
position et Ding a décidé c'était au 13e
coup après cavalier C3 qu'il se devait
de de serrer la vis et de prendre de se
précieux temps de le laisser s'égrainer
pour trouver les coups peut-être avoir
dans un peu plus tard dans la partie une
proposition plus facile à jouer qui lui
permettra d'enchaîner ses coups
justement
on va voir en tout cas pression mise par
Yann d'entrée de j'ai même envie de dire
par l'équipe de Yann parce que là Yann
pour le moment il n'a pas encore joué un
seul coup dans cette partie
pour le moment il sait il sait ce qu'il
a à faire d'ailleurs regardez là ça
pendule elle est au-dessus de 25 minutes
donc c'est à dire qu'il a repris du
temps avec en s'ajoutant 10 secondes
puis j'ai 10 secondes plus 10 secondes à
chaque fois donc il a il se paye le luxe
de partir il y a oh là là
il se paye le luxe d'aller en salle de
repos incroyable en rapide c'est rare
ici de voir ça mais la pression que ça
met sur Ding oh le le roi le roi Yann
nepomiaci qui décide de laisser son
valet seul sur l'échiquier même je
dirais même son écuyer
non mais le truc c'est que ouais
normalement rapide tu as pas trop le
temps et puis qu'on a vu la partie
d'avant et pris dans le rythme tu dois
prendre des décisions à chaque coup et
tombez vite jouer attaque le pion B2
donc shading qui n'a pas joué nickelby4
nickel ni à 3 mais un autre coup
relativement logique évidemment il s'est
ouvert une colonne et il l'utilise pour
la tour donc on s'attend à cavalier
prend à 4 quelque part qui va à la fois
récupérer le pion de moins et des fentes
B2 une pierre deux coups
et qu'est-ce qu'il veut sur quel bras
cadre après je sais pas mais
c'est le coup qui semble mille fois
logique qui prend à 4 comme tu le dis
hein ce pion on a besoin de le récupérer
un jour ou l'autre on a besoin de
défendre le pion B2 on fait d'une pierre
deux coups c'est un coup facile alors
après est-ce que l'idée de Ding c'est de
se dire ton cavalier il est en A4 il va
être vissé à la protection bonale bouger
parce que c'est le coup va jouer Yann il
est vissé à la protection de spion B2 si
tu joues B3 pour libérer ton cavalier tu
enferme ton fou si tu le laisses ton
Cavaillon à 4 pour protéger le pion il
est mal placé et au-delà de ça j'ai
peut-être un jour un coup comme cavalier
Descartes qui peut créer une découverte
sur sur ce cavalier donc tour B8 il veut
peut-être provoquer justement cette
prison A4 te dire fais-le maintenant ton
pion B2 il va être sous pression et puis
moi je vais aller m'occuper un petit peu
après de la loi qui sait peut-être
replacé mon fou vers G7 essayez de
pousser des seins et puis toi je te
laisse un peu te débrouiller là avec
avec ton petit
[Musique]
je sais pas à quel point va être
inconfortable avec les Blancs parce
qu'une fois qu'on a appris ce pion A4 on
pourra toujours jouer fou B3 pour qu'il
soit bien défendu et repartir verset 3
dans la foulée et qu'on s'est attaqué à
6 alors ce fou en B3 peut est-ce que
j'aurai le temps quand tu reviens en C3
de joint cavalier à 5 peut-être pas la
course sera ouverte sur le pion
étonnant quand même l'attitude de Yann
là il donne deux minutes il laisse
peut-être respirer sa proie bon il
revient serein voilà alors là c'est plus
que c'est plus que ça là il revient tel
un pacha alors là regarde-le il va
s'asseoir c'est ah ouais il a vraiment
l'attitude
du joueur qui domine après attention pas
en faire trop quand même ah bah il y a
rien fait il est peut-être mieux
moi je préfère sa position mais je veux
dire s'il fait le malin tombe dans le
ravin attention quand même le ravin
n'est jamais si loin surtout sur cet
estrade une petite chute en revenant et
ça pourrait en être fini des espoirs de
Yann
attention de pas perdre sur une entorse
à la cheville alors qu'on voit qu'il y a
quand même un photographe qui vient
s'asseoir Fabien dans le coin
donc ça y est il a pris l'option et donc
on va voir ce que ce que digne en tête
comme set up avec les noirs
pour lutter contre ce cavaler à 4 parce
que donc ouais si il fait rien je
m'attends à fou B3 et retour c'est trois
puis on organisera petit à petit c'est
et on aura un pion plus on gagnera la
partie Ding qui a pu utiliser ses
précieuses minutes offertes par Yann
pour continuer à calculer il est très
concentré le joueur chinois regarde la
tête prise entre les mains il est comme
vissé ce visage de Ding dans les mains
le penseur
dingly Rennes qu'il a est en train de
produire un effort de calcul pour fermer
la porte à Yann Yann qui a l'air serein
comme jamais
il a l'air sûr de sa force Yann
il repart bah écoute a priori il connaît
bien sa position parce que je veux dire
ils ont décidé hier de jouer ça
il avait pu la réviser il a peut-être
fait des parties d'entraînement dessus
et donc il a ses dettes et là toute
façon ça dépend pas de lui c'est Ding
qui va choisir le setup donc il a
peut-être raison de pas s'épuiser à
réfléchir comme un fou et dire vas-y
joue ton truc j'aviserai en fonction
puis finalement il fait circuler le sang
avec des petits pas les talons qui
renvoie le flux sanguin avec le stress
c'est peut-être une très bonne décision
et il se prend pas la tête à réfléchir à
rien il se détend il a il a réussi à
avoir la position qu'il espérait après
l'ouverture et il laisse pour le moment
Ding s'épuiser physiquement mais aussi
nerveusement parce que là c'est un
moment difficile à passer pour Ding très
concentré qui calcule mais la position
est simplement difficile et pour le
moment il ne joue pas contre Yann on le
répète il joue contre l'équipe de Y qui
a travaillé avec des ordinateurs d'un
niveau supérieur à 3600 et lots donc il
peut il va pas pouvoir inventer l'eau
chaude ici digne il peut pas non non
mais faut qu'il
a été trouvé un genre position qui lui
plaise à peu près et pareil pas qu'il
soit trop des nœuds dans la tête
alors qu'est-ce qui peut vouloir faire
est-ce qu'un moment tu peux penser à
dams C8 pour défendre un peu assis ce
que mon salaire toutes de foutrant H3 tu
vois enfin on sait pas il part sur
cahier des quatre ok un coup
relativement logique alors moi je m'y
serais attendu le coup d'avant ouais
pareil pas d'abord donné à 4 mais bon
peut-être que c'est bien donc ça attaque
à 4 il faut faire quelque chose en
fonction donc est-ce que on prend des
cartes d'abord et on défend le cavalier
mais le pion en D4 il sera pénible parce
que il prend la caisse C3 cavalier donc
on reviendra pas si facilement on
s'emprisonne donc ça faut bien réfléchir
ou alors est-ce qu'on fait genre fou C4
C4 qui est cool plus logique tu défends
le cavalier avec la tour tu replaces ton
fou qui maintenant en C4 est bien placé
qui a plus le problème du B5 qui venait
le toucher et par la même occasion tu
menaces peut-être tu prends assis ça
alors après avoir un fou prend assis sur
et peut-être tour à 8 pour enfiler mais
tu commences à l'oreiller sur le
pioniste voilà est-ce que l'idée sur
fousser 4 ne serait pas fou et 5
propose l'échange avec l'idée sur fou
prendre de remettre ce pion dans la
structure et donc d'avoir des des chiens
de faïence qui se regardent en C4 et B5
il peut faire les chiens de faïence hein
[Musique]
est-ce que on veut genre C3
provoque qu'elle prend F3 dame prend F3
et surful prend C4 des Français ok on se
double un pion on a une belle masse
depuis on compact et surtout on reste
avec ce petit case noir un peu
dégueulasse parce que faut que ça qu'on
a mieux après avoir on peut aussi songer
un coup comme B3 en fait s'en fout les 5
parce que ce B3 qu'on ne met pas avec le
fond à deux maintenant bon quand même on
souffle et on consolide tout mais
peut-être je peux essayer de faire C6
après essayer de jouer
tellement que je te prenne en V5 moi
j'aimerais que tu prennes C4 et moi
j'essaye après du coup de pousser ma
masse de pions donc fou B5 ça doit se
regarder
je vous prends à 4 tu reprends à deux
vaguement enfin j'ai on se prend des
deux quand même mais j'ai peur que ce
soit mauvaise son affaire à 6 on a donné
la paire de fou on laisse te fous ces
quatre incontesté j'aime pas tellement
pour les Noirs je pense pas que ce soit
une grande décision de faire ça
qui prend le bouillon oh la préparation
de Yann
elle est bien cadrée elle est très très
bien cadrée et ce qui se lasserait pas
garder celle-là il aurait pas dévoilé à
la 13e il se passerait garder dans la
poche pour cette partie Yann peut-être
mais en fait si ça se trouve enfin c'est
fort et c'est pas si fort j'en sais rien
après toi je l'ai pas analysé mais il
s'est dit ouais bon en lente il va
prendre le temps et puis il y a setup
qui est possible machin qui ça va aller
mais que en rapide tu as moins le temps
de réfléchir et que c'est plus compliqué
c'est possible qu'ils décidait que
c'était plus une arme de rapide que pour
j'aurais envie de dire non de but en
blanc mais je vois pas pourquoi
peut-être qu'il est comestible mais
simplement on n'a pas envie de [__]
sur mon C4 on fait des 5 à ce moment-là
et on te repousse bien quoi mais on
gagne quand même quelques quelques temps
quelques tempos et tu vois faut ado tu
peux pas [__] au pire je te bouffe
j'aurais besoin mais je te sache la
structure j'attaque 4 tu fais prendre ça
remet le fou des sept qui donc je crois
priori il est pas comestible le sera
sûrement un jour mais là pour l'instant
pas tellement
[Musique]
et donc il veut il veut des 5 ok soit
intéressant de Link je trouve ça c'est
ici ça pose un problème pratique et sur
cavalier C3 il y a tout reprend B2 voilà
alors après peut-être qu'on se venge sur
un 6 avoir quand on commence
d'échanger de troquer B2 contre raciste
peut-être que ces trois tours mais de
quel point les quatre
Eddy E2 attaque des quatre attaque à 6
et menace faites-vous B3 on ferme la
tour
bon après tu peux enfermer la tour qui
te sacrifier une qualité je sais pas
faut regarder c'est compliqué mais bon a
priori je pense c'est pas bête pour les
blancs de faire peut-être ce truc là
ça réfléchit côté Yann Ding qui a
réussi à peut-être pas à trouver la
meilleure réponse à ce à ce fouet 3D
d'eux très malins de la part de Yann
mais qui en tout cas réussi à poser de
réels problèmes à son adversaire et qui
se sort pas si mal de de ce pas
difficile il a retourné le service comme
il pouvait et il oublie pas de boire de
l'eau ça aussi c'est important et
continue à s'hydrater à s'alimenter
pendant les parties ça peut éviter une
fringale et là il réfléchit calcule Yann
qui pèse les variantes là regarde il
calcule lui aussi fort les yeux rivés
sur cette aile dame c'est vraiment de ce
côté de l'échiquier que les choses se
passent oui oui voilà en gros des cinq
c'est une menace donc il faut trouver
une parade alors tu peux aussi vouloir
faire caler prendre quatre prendre tu te
prémunies un peu des dessins quoi si tu
te dis maintenant j'aurais fou B3 enfin
ou EDC des fou B3 donc ça tu peux
échanger le calice et toi qui proposait
il a l'air pas mal aussi est-ce que quoi
d'autre Yann Ding qui qui vient de
quitter la table mais je crois qu'il
avait une envie pressante déjà juste au
début de la partie on a vu faire un
aller-retour qui va peut-être été refusé
quand il dit que la partie allait
commencer et là ça y est il est sorti
l'ouverture il en profite pour comme on
lit dans le jargon faire la vidange
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut avoir envie de
réfléchir il réfléchit
faire un coup même comme si 3 fais
attention ça peut être des coups
difficiles quand c'est la première
décision importante d'une partie on peut
parfois faire des fautes il a raison de
prendre son temps il prend des quatre
donc ça va forcer puis on prend des cas
et ok c'était une option dont on parlait
à l'idée c'est que maintenant sur les
dessins qu'on pourra prendre et on aura
la case B3 pour le fou donc on est moins
sujet avoir des problèmes sur des cinq
moins sensible et peut-être qu'il
pourrait diriger son fou vers F4
d'ailleurs pour venir donner un petit
toucher une petite fois cette tour
replacer son fou
un système de Londres et après on voyait
la marche avant F4 G4 G5 il faut F4
jouer logique très bien joué de la part
de Yann quelle partie
elle se fout qui est fort en C4 les
pièces blanches bien placées il y a que
ce cavalier A4 qui est un peu loin mais
il est mieux il est mieux avec les
Blancs ça s'est bien passé son ouverture
il a
il a une position sympa qui peut
travailler je crois qu'il n'a ce 5 aussi
ici avec les Blancs
parce que on prend fou prends on attaque
à la fois la torduite et l'option des 4
donc il y a des problèmes à résoudre
pour Ding il y a beaucoup de choses qui
se passent là dans la position beaucoup
de problèmes à régler et comme tu dis
qui en réalité ce qui va aller à 4 c'est
la seule pièce mal placée mais qui
pourra revenir après soin un coup comme
C3 provoquer un échange un jour on n'est
pas pressé il est pas sur le point
d'être perdu ou peut-être B3 KB2 et on
verra alors les trois temps qui a les
dessins qui rodent qui rôdent c'est pas
le moment mais si les noirs sont
provoqués à faire comme C5 à un moment
tu peux très bien vis-à-vis de faire B3
sans souci le problème de C5 et c'est le
cours recommandé par l'ordinateur c'est
que tu tipotec le coup des cinq à vitam
eternam et stratégiquement j'aime pas le
coup
mais des fois si tu as pas le choix tu
as pas le choix enfin
mais du coup ouais sur ces cinq tu
pourras toujours je B3 repartir en B2
avec le cavalier et trouver un trajet
revenir en jeu soit à la place du
français 4 ce serait magnifique
n'auront plus de de ressort dans leur
position
est-ce que un ressort ça pourrait être
de faire du roi H8 de déplacer le
cavalier de faire F5 mais alors comment
le faire j'ai peur qu'on est simplement
pas le pas le temps matériel de réaliser
ce plan c'est dur ouais c'est
extrêmement difficile pour
ici
quelle prépa de Yann quelle prépa gardez
bien au chaud pour cette partie
regarde il est tranquille il est heureux
Yann mais maintenant il ne faut
absolument pas gâcher les munitions
ça permet dans les variantes avec E5
puis on prend fou prendre que le pion de
D4 soit protégé par la dame donc c'est
un coup un bon coup et ça vient manger
du temps c'est à dire que là comme tu as
pas fait B3 si tu avais le plus en B3 tu
pourrais faire cavalier B2 et venir
comme ça pour remplacer le fou mais là
tu n'as pas le temps
exactement
ça a l'air d'être un coup
intéressant ce fou aussi est-ce que tu
me prépares aussi à des seins qui
prépare pas encore il y aurait [__]
tu prépares un jour et après souvent la
réaction Mika va pas bien marcher c'est
de te faire [__] aussi ce5
sauf que je pense qu'il y ait des cinq
qui va arriver alors est-ce que c'est si
grave on recule le fou mais je veux dire
au moins il s'active avec les Noirs
mais là tout d'un coup on en fait c'est
génial pour les blancs ce qui était en
deux parce que tu sautes en E4 en C4
était loin loin et je sais pas là le
temps il compte c'est OK stratégiquement
c'est nickel pour les blancs mais
qu'est-ce qui va se passer les noms
tellement il a mangé ça
bon ça peut tu veux même faire un tour
B5 tu t'en vas là-bas je sais pas ça
c'est pas clair c'est le truc que tu as
envie de faire marcher avec les blancs
mais s'il marche pas il marche pas c'est
comme ça et
si je joue un simple B3 ouais alors faut
regarder des cinq en D5 j'ai encore la
Tour Eiffel
ok alors B3 s'il y a pas des 5 pour
l'instant ça va donc avec l'idée simple
de faire cavalier dehors et peut-être
prendre à 6 aussi un moment quoi disons
une fois qu'on a fait cavalier B2 oui on
sera là pour on va essayer de le manger
de la tour au moins on s'active la tour
au passage pour le ce pion là a quand
même partir du principe que si tu veux
t'y accrocher même en faisant des A5 ben
un jour on peut faire cavalier de quand
même puis Dame des deux enfin ou même
dame un fout des deux tu vois des plans
comme ça alors il a joué quelque chose
de complètement différent Fabien il a
joué tout E1
ok alors il se laisse doubler les pions
ouais je suis pas contre j'aime bien
l'idée parce que tu veux faire B3 KB2
qui est Détroit et il y a toujours mal
se replace donc comme ça sur Full
français 4 dépenser on perd pas au 4 ça
le défend donc on a protégé le pion E4
en prévision de foot français 4 donc
c'est un coup pas mal je veux dire et
donc pourquoi pas on profite de ce fou
F4 qui tape la tour B8 Fabien j'aime
bien le coup j'aime bien le coup
pourquoi pas
très bien joué de la part de Yann
il va falloir être fort à côté Ding
très franchement c'est
il faut être très solide je trouve que
le coup proposé par la turbinette et
intéressant c'est de faire à 5 alors
c'est triste c'est très triste comme
coup mais se dire finalement je laisse
un temps de plus au blanc voire un peu
quelle direction ils prennent mais au
moins je blinde mon pion pour le moment
je le rends un petit peu plus difficile
à manger peut-être plus tard dans la
partie
ça t'évite de devoir regarder faux
principes à chaque coup parce que le
jour où il marche tu te prends un pion
et puis voilà lorsque le cavalier se
décale d'avoir tout reprend à 6 là c'est
vrai que tu sécurises ton pion pour le
moment et tu passes un peu ton tour
donc pourquoi pas
très très bien jouer de la part de Ding
il prend les il prend la bonne décision
ici
ça joue vraiment très bien aujourd'hui
Fabien là depuis le début les deux
joueurs nous offrent un spectacle
extraordinaire à la hauteur finalement
de l'événement exactement ça joue très
bien
bonne prépa de nez pour dinksay il
souffre mais il trouve quand même des
coups qui te qui lâchent pas l'affaire
et
c'est pas fait enfin voilà et la partie
d'avance c'était c'était un peu
l'inverse en fait donc là les deux
joueurs qui sont de coups pour coup qui
jouent bien c'est en même temps du beau
spectacle qui qui nous offre et
franchement ça fait quand même plaisir
un match
qui a parfois souffert des des nerfs des
deux joueurs qui qui n'ont pas réussi à
bien jouer en même temps et finalement
on était un petit peu inquiet ce matin
avant le match je veux dire attention
est-ce que ça va pas être encore le
festival des fautes avec une pression
encore plus forte moins de temps à la
pendule et c'est tout l'inverse qui se
passe actuellement les deux joueurs qui
réussissent dans dans le money time à
envoyer des paniers à trois points tel
un duel entre Michael Jordan et
peut-être Shaquille O'Neal j'avais des
rêves basket un petit peu anciennes Fab
je suis sûr que le chat qui met des
trois points quoi ouais enfin il prend
la faute il te met les deux points et il
te met le lancer franc quand même il est
là quand même Brian plutôt
mais physiquement tu vois tu as
l'impression que tu as le tu as
check-ile quoi le
Cosmo contre Jordan plus plus aérien
dans le style
et
ils sont là mais non non mais là ça joue
bien et finalement justement qu'ils
aient moins de temps peut-être pour
cogiter ça ça fait que je puisse sur la
réflexe naturelle qui sont très bons et
puis en 25 minutes tu as quand même le
temps de ne pas faire n'importe quoi
quoi qu'il en soit les deux joueurs qui
s'accrochent Yann qui sent que la proie
est entre ses mains mais d'inglieren on
l'a dit un petit peu plus tôt c'est une
anguille tu l'as éteint
[Musique]
il te file entre les doigts
il met la dame en F3 ok bon bah pourquoi
pas ça active la dame en jeu celle il
est tour ça remet rien en question sur
la position en général c'est très bien
ça laisse tous les problèmes dans la
position pour pour les noirs
tu peux avoir envie de faire 5 à un
moment un scorpion prend faut prends tu
touches un peu plus C6 je sais pas enfin
ça t'ouvre des options et elle est pas
mal sodomie tu laisses les noces se
débrouiller avec leur position c'est dur
de trouver des coups un thé noir alors
est-ce que décaler le cavalier
en 17 en D7 par exemple pour sur 5 avoir
des cinq
je sais pas peut-être quelle est cette
paraître un coup logique quand même
après je me questionnais
[Musique]
si on pouvait prendre aussi se faire des
trucs en dessin et tu fais 5 je partais
en D2 et j'en sais rien et on voit mais
tomber 7 et un joli coup tu t'enlèves tu
t'enlèves de ce problème là qui qui est
l'attend dans la position il s'en allait
enlever des problèmes comme il avait
rien à faire digne il vient de se faire
A5 je m'enlève d'un problème ton set je
m'enlève d'un deuxième et ça permet de
la tour en baisser ça en plus sinon
ben c'est pas mal il joue des coups qui
tu parles bien tenir d'enlever les
thèmes au passage je surprotage mon fou
on sait jamais Fabien il y a quand même
une tour en face ça peut être utile et
dans un monde où il y a un échange en E6
ben ma tour peut-être qu'un jour elle va
passer directement à F7 et venir te
taper sur ton sur ta colonne F donc
c'est un coup comme ça qui a l'air de
rien
il fait énormément de choses ce petit
coup de tour
très bien joué Ding qui qui défend là il
est 50 centimètres 1 m derrière la ligne
de fond mais on voit profond
et puis il se donne des dessins tiens du
coup maintenant
le 5 et ce qui force pas la main de Yann
mais ça ce serait plutôt dans en faveur
de Ding en tout cas il rentrerait dans
une position il va se passer des choses
il va plus être dans à subir là pendant
10 20 30 coups à être comme ça derrière
à défendre et finalement un jour à
craquer en jouant E5 c'est le coup que
qui a joué Yann il permet de rentrer
dans le vif du sujet alors maintenant il
est toujours dominé bien évidemment et
peut-être même qui va perdre cette
partie mais ça va se décider sur les
coups qui viennent si Yann se trompe
maintenant hop le l'avantage va
disparaître
la mauvaise nouvelle pour Ding parce
qu'on en a donné quelques bonnes c'est
que le seul coup d'après l'ordinateur
pour rester dans la partie en tout cas
flow c'est fou des cinq et Yann a l'air
de s'en rendre compte qu'il y a pas
énormément il y a pas pléthore d'options
pour Ding puisqu'il se lève une nouvelle
fois et j'ai l'impression qu'il veut
montrer pas son adversaire de par cette
attitude sa domination sur l'échiquier
attention quand même un digne qui se
laisse pas impressionner depuis le début
du match par cette attitude un petit peu
désinvolte ouais
parce que quand même après 5 tu attaques
quand même C6 enfin pas que hein mais et
donc il faut descendre tu résous un
problème s'il faut prendre du cavalier
et tu te remets au centre et voilà et
puis eux prend des six vous prend vous
prendre
mais ok c'est logique aussi puisque ça
défend ça défend ces 6 alors est-ce que
c'est si grave on n'en sait rien encore
je suis pas sûr ça c'est grave je suis
pas sûr c'est pas le coup optimale de
l'ordi mais ok il est
c'était un coup qui s'entend très bien
qui était qui était dans le dans la
liste des coupes possibles bon c'était
il y avait deux coups c'était cahier des
cinq ou foutait 5 de toute façon les
deux s'entendaient après fou dessin qui
était au dessus on sait pas trop
pourquoi mais le fait de voir Yann se
lever comme ça en mettre des lieux c'est
un petit peu inquiétant pour Dinga et
Ding il faut s'accrocher ne pas se
laisser impressionner par cette attitude
de Yann il bluff il bluff
non mais après soyez se lèvent parce
qu'il est très confiant ou aussi parce
qu'il a besoin de se calmer les nerfs tu
peux le voir dans les deux sens donc tu
sais pas enfin de toute façon aux échecs
souvent tu essaies de concentrer à jouer
des bons coups si tu peux après il fait
ce qu'il veut en tout cas digne il a une
attitude de champion il bouge pas
après j'aime pas trop quand il fait ça
j'ai un c'est qu'il a du mal à trouver
Céline je me rappelle
avec ses mains lorsqu'il avait
complètement explosé prise des 6 prises
D6 d'accord il y a eu un échange
il va y avoir prise des 6 prises des 600
corps et vous voyez la jauge finalement
qui ne s'affole pas non non mais moi je
vois rien
dramatique pour les Noirs après bah il y
aura toujours ce pion assez faible mais
il y a ce Cavalia 4 un peu mal placé en
fait tu vas rêver que le cahier à 4
revient dans ses 5 un jour
et tu as peut-être du jeu avec du tout 8
tout recettes cette tour là qui va
pouvoir tout d'un coup tac venir jouer
la colonne ouverte digne qui s'accroche
bon je m'attends il faut prendre des six
quand même maintenant
sur les caméras ça me prend des six
joueurs rapidement
et tout recad peut-être
cavaliers F6 je défends j'attaque
si tu as envie mais alors
ma tour ensemble elle sera cool elle
t'attaquera à 5 etc oui il veut dame
5 parce que en fait la dame noire c'est
celle qui nous empêche de ramener le
cavalier à 4 en C5 et c'est les plus là
du coup bah ça sera plus sympa pour
lequel quand on arrive en C5 on touche
B7 on touche 6 on touche à 5 on touche
tout on touche tout
c'est très bien joué de la part de Yann
il veut il veut supprimer le dernier
défenseur des cases noires
alors peut-être qu'on peut ne pas partir
en F6 mais aller de manière plus
offensive vers B4 finalement de toute
façon la dame veut bouger donc pourquoi
je viendrai attaquer quelqu'un qui veut
se déplacer je te laisse je te laisse
venir en E5 mais je te je ne te provoque
pas je viens en B4 je contre-attaque
monsieur
j'attaque ces deux donc sur québec4 vous
prend 6 il faut compter sur les cahiers
français 2 un jour enfin je sais pas
quand mais alors j'ai peut-être une idée
mais je sais pas si elle marche une
journée sur KBK faut prendre ici j'ai
peut-être des tours recettes
pas facile mais si ça marche ça marche
voilà c'est pas l'ordi c'est bon donc ça
peut ne pas marcher mais tu vois j'ai
envie de justifier ma tour là qui
revient un peu bizarre ce tour recette
mais intéressant
ça va c'est cool pour les Noirs parce
que c'était de défoncer les pions tu
reprends la colonne tu m'as taxé deux
[Musique]
bah disons
parce que finalement s'il le fait pas il
sait qu'après dame 5 il souffre et KBK
c'est peut-être un moyen concret de
résoudre les problèmes alors ou pas ça
se trouve c'est un futé mais ok pourquoi
pas tout de même aussi regarder cavalier
F6 dame 5 dame prend tout reprendre fou
français 4 alors oui je vais peut-être
perdre un pion mais je t'ai quand même
défoncé la structure mais bon si je fais
B3 qui est B2 je suis hyper content quoi
tu pourrais avoir du mal à jouer
il va de l'autre côté bon mais il avait
peut-être pas enfin faut pas aussi cette
recette je sais pas si ça marche en gros
c'était tout recettes c'était tout
recette
c'était dur donc
[Musique]
dame 5 qui est le coup logique qu'est-ce
qu'il a en tête contre
ça mais alors il peut échanger
il a un genre de cavalier 2 qui est un
genre de cheat c'est pas exactement mais
après maintenant on peut aussi songe à
B3 côté blanc un coup que j'aimais pas
tant que lequel était en dessin que bon
il peut aller en B4 fait lancer 3 là il
est quand même repoussé de l'autre côté
et B3 peut-être
que sur B3 on peut échanger on va voir
une fois je sais pas de quoi tu
reprendras
bon je préfère des mais faut voir si des
trois ça me saoule ou pas
mais des trois peut-être je te fais un
intermédiaire quoi la position est
complexe je pense qu'il va jouer dame 5
personnages voilà il faut calculer
exactement d'un membre français 4 décès
des trois on arrive à jouer il va jouer
on le voit il joue dame 5
parce que c'est plus sécurisant faut
prendre ces quatre prises C4 c'est la
variante dont on parlait
alors des trois ou pas des trois je sais
pas moi mais c'est en gros je me dis il
a fait qu'il y a F4 pour quelque chose
comme ça
ça marche ça marche pas mais en tout cas
le dame 5 de dépôt il est logique
sur D3 si les Blancs jouent G3 cavalier
prend H3 il y a 3 G2 et le trick c'est
que la tour contrôle la case G5 de
sortie du cheval donc on devrait jouer
F6 mais bon on va gagner un pion puis
deux pions maintenant il prendra pas si
ça se passe comme ça il ira souvent pour
gagner un temps sur la tour et prendre
ces deux
est fort ou je ne sais quoi
et ben ça marche quoi enfin
bon après je sais pas si ils comptent
faire des trois mais ça me donnait cette
impression si il est venu F4 c'était
pour faire fonctionner ça alors juste
pour dire une nouvelle fois juste un
petit point sur l'ordi pour dire le le
coup à trouver là on vous a dit ce qui
nous paraissait logique le coup à
trouver pour tenir cette jauge proche de
l'égalité c'est tour B4 attaque le pion
C4 avec l'idée sur B3 de maintenant
jouer D3 et de déstabiliser
la défense blanche ok jolie c'est pas
simple c'est très ingénieux c'est en
fait si on a l'idée elle est dure à
avoir si on a l'idée qu'on va tomber 4
B3 avec l'idéal tiens juste avant son
pion et je te fais des trois après c'est
un truc quand même classique il y a des
fois de ses idées
parfois quand vous avez une structure BC
contre a vous faites un genre de tout
rêve B8 l'adversaire fait B3 et on fait
à 5 à 4 pour pour casser la structure ça
peut ça peut arriver ou inversement un
contrat et B de provoquer un B3 pour se
débarrasser du pion donc là c'est un peu
cette même idée de de de venir le le
faire se protéger par le socle pour
casser le socle après et que c'est tout
le monde et cassé tout le monde c'est
difficile
voilà c'est pas la variante est facile
c'est juste l'idée qui est difficile à
avoir donc c'est dur de savoir s'il va
la trouver parce qu'on a quand même plus
envie de calculer des trois directs
cavalier 6 des coûts plus forçants et
peut-être qu'on arrive juste pas à
tomber 4 ouais ouais déjà bon a priori
alors dit il gueule pas après B3 d'après
Détroit il te dit bon ça va aussi c'est
peut-être un peu moins bon que B4 mais
et à noter que l'autre avantage de tour
B4 c'est qu'on s'enlève des cavaliers 5
aussi donc c'est c'est un coup qui fait
beaucoup de choses pour B4 mais
difficile de l'avoir après on va tomber
4 donc Mathieu demande ton BK
est-ce que c'est des trois maintenant
on sait pas c'est possible
[Musique]
qui est B2 j'imagine
même pas qui est B25
alors Détroit G3 ça ça va être lavande
principale
[Musique]
bon on souffre un peu mais même quand on
perdra C2 ça va pas être si simple
d'avancer avec les Blancs le pion B
restera
[Musique]
du couloir un jour H6 probablement
on souffle on souffre
c'est pas foutu moi-même
[Musique]
le niveau de jeu mesdames et messieurs
impressionnant d'ingly Rennes mesdames
et messieurs on vit on est en train de
vivre les meilleures parties de ces
championnats du monde en termes de
niveau de jeu c'est en rapide qui l'ont
décidé de s'envoyer des parpaings et là
il y a plus une balle dehors incroyable
tour B4 un coup qui aurait été difficile
même extrêmement difficile à trouver en
partie longue et digne il y aura une qui
envoie ça en rapide bravo mesdames et
messieurs
[Musique]
incroyable incroyable niveau de jeu
alors c'est
c'est quelque chose
pendant que Magnus est en train de
s'amuser à monter Carlo à jouer un
tournoi de poker c'est deux hommes sont
en train de montrer qui méritaient cette
place finalement championnat du monde
parce que là ils ont rien à envier à
Magnus dans ces rapides
ça joue un niveau stratosphérique
incroyable
incroyable tour B4 un coup extrêmement
difficile les options numéro 3 dans les
coups logiques qui est la meilleure et
tour c'est 5 des trois mesdames et
messieurs on est sur un niveau
stratosphérique aujourd'hui et je crois
que sur C3 mais tu as des deux tu
reprends à 4 tu reprends à 4 D2
et cavalier E2 roi F1 cavalier C1
qui sont-ils
incroyable incroyable tourbéca tour C5
D3 C3 tour à 4 D2
Fabien tu peux te le prendre en fait
enfin
reprend un cadre des deux je reviens
quand même perdre
attention attention
Yannick
les maths du couloir tu fais h euh
il va faire nul il veut pas se tromper
et plus un truc cahier prend tu me
prends ceci je te reviens E5 je te
bouffe C4 franchement c'est
stratosphérique alors là c'est ah je te
dis même en longue hein c'est il n'avait
pas ce niveau en long il y a deux jours
de ça non non il joue mieux rapide qu'en
longue hein c'est incroyable là ce
qu'ils font
non on a vu beaucoup d'erreurs
ils n'ont pas réussi à défendre en
langue et là il y a plus de fautes en
fait il y a plus de fautes
incroyable c'est un match de tennis tu
as un pendant tout le 5e 7 il y a que
des doubles fautes c'est n'importe quoi
et là ils arrivent au tie-break et les
mecs ne sortent plus
une balle ils sont toutes dedans
première balle de service retour
ça sort plus une balle c'est incroyable
incroyable Détroit
hallucinant et là attention il y a un
parce que tu peux avoir C3 et te le
prendre ah mais je crois qu'en fait tu
vas pas te le prendre parce que tu peux
oublier
aussi non
je vois pas de défense en fait ouais
maintenant et le truc c'est quoi ton
français 6 ça va pas suffire parce que
tu fais tourner et tu évites le match du
couloir et en fait c'est ça que tu
regardes en premier et si ça s'appelle
bah tu es une la variante et du coup
basta si ça ça tenait pour les blancs tu
peux dire ah c'est cool
et peut-être
je peux pas faire ces trois
et donc voilà
donc ça va faire ça va sûrement faire
nul quelle défense de Digne il va
complètement remettre la pression sur
Yann attention la partie n'est pas
terminée encore il peut se passer des
choses mais vous voyez cette jauge à
gauche maintenant qui nous annonce une
égalité parfaite après
5 plus tôt je sais pas pourquoi tu
laisses C4 enfin oui non mais ça va
en réalité il va rester des tours et
trois pions de ce côté et merci merci
mesdames et messieurs au revoir Mathieu
nul là c'est sûr
si tu prends là on te prend là si tu
prends là on prend là on dirait d'abord
on sait pas trop se comprendre quel
monde il y a pas des échanges massifs
mais ce tourbékin impressionne surtout
prends à 500 tu prends ces quatre si tu
prends B2 il peut peut-être échanger de
faire ton racisme tu as pas torse 8 moi
je prendrai donc tu prends ces quatre en
fait
je pense que ça va liquider plus que 7
minutes pour les deux hommes alors mais
c'est pas plus que 7 minutes 7 minutes
avec 10 secondes par coup de rajout
c'est plus que c'est amplement suffisant
pour faire nul sans aucun problème donc
il prend ok donc on s'attend à cavalier
5 petite fourchette
[Musique]
et normalement ça va se liquider parce
qu'en fait le cahier en C4 il a tout
RAV4 vont attaquer B2 à fond les jours
les Noirs vont prendre B2 qui allait
prendre les blancs reprendra 5 il y aura
le scénario indiqué précédent par keV
avec plus que des pions est loin déjà
trois comptes 2 ce serait nul mais alors
trois contre trois n'en parlons plus
ouais
il y a plus rien à trouver évidemment ce
serait bête de faire une erreur à ce
moment de la partie de la compétition
donc ils prennent quand même leur tente
on sait sept après tu as une question je
me demande est-ce que les joueurs mais
je sais pas si tu le sais toi on a non
non mais ah oui bon ça je sais pas mais
on le droit de parler avec leur
secondaire entre les rondes alors j'en
sais rien parce qu'en fait ça change pas
mal si en fait tu as ton équipe là qui
fait tourner les modules sur feu 3 fous
des deux et qui te dit un site refait ça
par en B7 ou Fessy ou fait ça et que tu
aurais pas la ligne de deux
et vice-versa Yann tiens tu te refait
ses trois je pense qu'ils ont
généralement ils ont le droit donc ça si
quelqu'un l'information
voilà ça devrait faire ça devrait faire
nul tranquillement encore une grande
partie de la part de la part des deux
hommes
et donc là
grosse félicitations indigne
ça c'est pas le problème mais c'était
normal ce qu'il a fait une époque il a
sorti une très bonne prépa après la
jouer l'écologie qui aurait suffi pour
battre tellement de joueurs sur la
planète et digne par contre il était
dans une station délicate et il a trouvé
le Caval F4 et surtout le tour B4 D3
enfin super enchaînement et puis d'arper
à se mettre en place comme ça faire le
cahier des quatre le fou aussi le a5 le
temps B7 beaucoup de coups difficiles en
fait après la préparation fait aussi
partie du jeu donc non non mais bon
les deux les deux oui mais j'ai envie de
te dire que là sur ce qui était fait sur
l'échiquier c'est Ding qui était très
impressionnant en retour de service
à travailler l'équipe a des idées et ils
ont peut-être encore une pour la pour la
quatrième ronde
qui avait pris un billet de donc on
s'attend à tout reprend à 5
00 il va garder les cavaliers sur les
chic et malgré tout
alors qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui cherche ce qu'il veut
aller en 5 attaquer F-7 un peu qu'il ait
des idées des vérités comme ça ou c'est
rien ou c'est juste qu'il y a eu des
sept tu bouges ta tour je vais au 5 tu
vas vérifier je regardais ça et qu'il y
a aucune vérité de rien je pense qu'il y
a toujours des velléités je pense que là
il y a des vélos qui peut y avoir un
millimètre de vérité il y a de la
velléitaire bah c'est vrai que si tu
prends une victoire
c'est pour ça que je dis la position
égale va sûrement se diriger vers une
nulle mais attention quand même il y a
de la velléité là ils sont tous les deux
velléitaires
regarde Yann il a pas encore abdiqué
il y a une microscopique pression le
cavalier un peu loin du jeu
il va tenter quand même le va tout
il a déjà joué H3 son adversaire la page
web encore un tempo à perdre
il y a de la petite vérité
c'est pas violent mais c'est là regarde
il s'accroche là il lâche il lâche pas
il y a pas de nul facile pas de demi
point donné ici
du couloir et de pas laisser cavalier 5
plus les deux tours sur la 7ème rangée
donc il y a eu des trois pas mal prends
la case de 5 au cavalier 7 donc là en
fait les deux cases contrôlent l'un
l'autre mais du coup c'est bien ce qui a
été trop petit qui va aller au 5 ok
j'imagine tu peux le jouer quand même
mais je veux dire ça fera pas trop mal
et puis tu veux aussi pourquoi pas
torber un échec et aller prendre F2
c'est bien joué ça défend bien plus de
fautes
je pense que Ding est sorti d'affaires
la cave à les détroit est bien placé il
était déjà avant mais il a il a continué
sur le bon chemin
Yann qui réfléchit
c'est position là on peut un peu les
forces après faut pas trop les forcer
non plus ça peut arriver que ça se
retourne oui bah tu t'en vas c'est super
ça non mais là tu vois je vois bien un
coup comme tout rêve ça comment tu
blindes de oui toi
c'est peut-être pas le coup le plus
agressif de la position mais bon tu
non mais là de toute façon tu as plus
grand chose à graisser quand même
pas de risque tu continues à mettre une
microscopique pression
mais tu vas pas t'enférer dans les tours
J5 là pour aller faire cavalier FC dans
ce genre de choses ou tu sens que tu es
en train de
bon bah tu peux le faire il le fait il
est vraiment
il veut vraiment pousser la pression
jusque jusqu'à son comble
pourquoi pas ah non c'est peut-être bien
joué
c'est peut-être bien joué
F6
qui faisait semi-per parce que tu dis je
me fais attaquer des trois et Machin
mais t'as toujours bien qu'il est prévu
tu auras jamais tu t'auto black avec les
Blancs donc si toi j'ai trop et pas un
souci pourquoi pas faire ça
c'est bien joué de la part de Yann quand
même il force encore quand même trouvé
un petit truc bon après je mets une H6
c'est pas obligé
ce truc que j'avais
il part en courant
logique si tu enlèves du vis-à-vis mais
tu défends moins bien
par contre bon
ok bon moi je vais acheter sur H6 bon vu
qu'il marche mais en fait c'est enfin
c'est truc de défense attaque et là au
prochain tu fais H6 et tu es tranquille
je pense ça va être ton F4 toi F4 solide
sûrement F3 et tu fais H6
bon ça doit se terminer un moment quoi
mais bon s'ils ont pas proposé nul ça
peut tourner encore un peu
tu peux faire même G6 peut-être
pour essayer de monter le ranger 7 et
aller contrer avec du tour 1
c'est les positions
en fait il y en a un qui veut faire nul
bon ça va faire nuit mais si les deux
ont décidé de se mettre sur la gueule il
y en a un des deux qui peut gagner et
Yann
qui s'absenter en courant il revient le
nom il revient il revient il a couru il
a couru il va faire F3
si tu veux continuer tu fais du G6 et tu
t'arrêtes pas quoi
on en parle plus mais
il veut des vérités
dans des seins qui est B4 ce cavalier
quand même un peu hors-jeu un petit peu
mais tu vas quand même l'idée de revenir
en Décathlon peut-être
mais voilà retour des deux sûrement
des deux je veux dire tu blindes ton G2
tu évites les mauvaises blagues ils vont
des 6 OK
là je pense ouais
de cases en diagonale d'un cavalier tu
le coupe généralement ça tu coupes lui
et tu reviens avec lui et tu reviens
vers F4
tu remets des velléités de ton côté quoi
c'est pas qui joue pour le gars en fait
peut-être
qu'il y aille C2 alors après
c'est lui qui peut se retrouver bloqué
l'autre qui ressort
qui veut la femme il voudrait faire
nulle
ça suffit on en a assez fait
en tout cas c'est beau aucun des deux ne
veut ne veut lâcher c'est la guerre des
nerfs
je pense pas le droit de proposer nul
avant le 40e coup en fait
sûrement c'était la règle pendant les
parties lentes
pourquoi ça changerait là après mais
comment ils savent le numéro du coup
aussi beaucoup de questions non mais
qu'on n'est pas le numéro de coup sur la
pendule
alors peut-être il y a des options où tu
peux l'avoir peut-être mais bon c'est
écrit un petit de toute façon
j'en ai marre je veux pas me faire à
manger mon cavalier ou me prendre un
truc c'est bon on a assez vu tu en as
marre là
je prends je vérifie je double
[Rires]
on est cinq c'est le coup pour faire nul
tout de suite
on va voir si siding le jour voilà enfin
un fameux
8 et changer avoir cavalier fuite je
crois pas que tu es découverte fatal
mais oui il y en a marre des vérité quoi
c'est pas loin il est très belle 8
allez on échange tout donc on aura
quatre parties aujourd'hui au minimum a
priori un partout
ouais ils ont ils s'en envoient à
tronche là
Yann qui essaye encore d'envoyer de la
vérité il cherche un dernier truc un
dernier truc mais ça a pas l'air
3 minutes
parti qui dure un peu plus d'une heure
il est déjà très heureuse de 10 minutes
mais cette partie là on atteint leur jeu
elle est longue enfin je veux dire ils
prennent leur temps ils avaient 25
chacun au début ils ont plus que 3
minutes on fait déjà 44 minutes juste
comme ça plus toutes les 10 secondes par
coupé donc ça fait 20 secondes par coup
il y en a 40 800 secondes bon je vous
laisse convertir mais oui on est à leur
jeu
allez hop ça prend un petit orage
aisselles
torbet 3 ou torbet de même
il y a une déçu
bon là il peut plus rien faire même si
c'est pas le pion F6 ce serait nul mais
bon on est bien content qu'il soit là et
que et qui est pas d'histoire ça permet
de
ne pas réfléchir
mais en fait je comprends pas parce que
là ils vont juste répéter
ok bravo messieurs encore pour ce
spectacle et cette bonne partie très
très belle partie il y en a un peu déçu
mais
il peut pas s'en vouloir il a fait sa
partie mais ça jouait la scie en face
quoi c'est comme ça
elle est partie une nouvelle fois d'un
niveau
extraordinaire Fab
très très belle partie les deux hommes
qui se sont envoyés et qui ne font plus
de fautes en fait c'est ça le c'est ça
le problème c'est qu'il y a plus
d'erreurs et donc il y a plus de il y a
plus de victoire ça défend extrêmement
bien
rapide
bon peut-être on va avoir une victoire
et me stwin après ou encore des nuls
mais ça joue ça joue super bien
donc on se retrouve dans 10 minutes on
va remettre une petite pub peut-être
bientôt on prépare tout le setup et on
se retrouve à part le setup
se relancer dans dans le combat de nous
meublé en nous parlant de ton lit
d'exercices Fab ou pas ah oui je peux
donc je fais ça donc c'est un autre
livre d'exercice c'est un livre qui va
sortir le 25 mai prochain qui est déjà
dispo en précommande et donc c'est un
livre d'exercice avec plus de 250
exercices 286 exactement me semble-t-il
avec des quiz culture générale un livre
en couleur qui sera sympathique à lire
et plein de petits exercices qui
aideront donc pour essayer de progresser
et faire des échecs de manière un peu
fun quoi
donc voilà pour le lire qui qui sera pas
vendu cher il coûte moins de 10 € 9,90
voilà donc
pour l'auto promo et
voilà enfin on est on est pile au bon
moment donc on se retrouve dans un peu
moins de 10 minutes pour la suite du
match merci de suivre ce match en notre
compagnie et on vous dit à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes de retour mesdames et
messieurs pour la troisième partie de
ces départages entre Ying et Rennes et
Yann nepomyachi arbitres qui sont en
train d'installer l'échiquier de
remettre les pièces pour cette partie
17 du match 7e partie finalement
troisième des départages il y en a eu 14
en longue
qu'est-ce qui se passe pourquoi les
caméras marchent plus
sont déjà mises en place sur la grande
canne c'est reparti
indienne qui avait [__] mais qui est
l'utilise là et donc il va se faire du
détroit qu'il est de 4 etc et une époque
doit être prêt contre ça
non pas de ta question
il sort finalement sa botte pas secret
mais qu'il est pas utilisé c'est marrant
parce que c'est c'est l'ouverture ce
qu'il a rendu connu sur laquelle il est
le plus à l'aise alors bon il a pas joué
des quatre mais c'est dans dans l'esprit
catalan et il utilise pour peut-être sa
dernière partie avec avec les Blancs
pour le but en or allez reste plus que
de partir donc
super avec les Blancs le match sera
quasiment plié encore que avec la
pression d'un titre de champion du monde
pour encore renverser la vapeur mais
s'il gagne il prendrait une option sur
le titre donc là c'est des parties qui
valent très très cher qui peuvent valoir
Fabien un titre de champion du monde
d'échec et une page dans l'histoire du
jeu tout à fait c'est parti hyper
importante donc
il a raison de jouer le genre de
pression dans lequel il est à l'aise
donc position qui est très symétrique
mais comme toujours il y a se fout de la
Catalane c'est un petit plus qui tape sa
grande diagonale c'est un fou qui est
sorti et le fou B2 pareil contrairement
au C8 donc voilà les Noirs ont un petit
truc à résoudre le jour où ça va sortir
fou si il se passe rien bon ils sont
égalisés mais encore faut-il encore
faut-il y arriver alors là est-ce qu'il
veut prendre de la dame ou du four alors
dame prend on s'attend il faut F6 dames
des deux et
peut-être un échange un jour en B2
maintenant plus tard je sais pas il peut
aussi voir prendre du fond des 4 et pas
perdre de temps dessus ça va vite voir
un choix cornélien
choix difficile ici mais la mauvaise
nouvelle à mon avis pour Ding c'est que
Yann il est prêt il est très très près
on l'a vu dans ce match et bah service
de ligne direen et très très bon retour
Yann il a réussi à lire le service le
petit coup de langue
alors j'ai pas envie d'y en difficulté
dans l'ouverture parce qu'avec les
blancs c'est pas c'est pas le mot mais
peut-être qu'il connaît un ou deux coups
ou trois coups de moins que son
adversaire cependant on a déjà vu dans
ce match qu'il avait une ressource une
capacité à se remettre des coups durs
d'ingly Rennes hors du commun c'est
peut-être finalement son point le plus
fort il réussit à accepter les défaites
accepter les mauvais moments et à
continuer à jouer à son meilleur niveau
et donc il joue d’âme prend des quatre
alors là attention sur B6 Fabien ce
serait une faute il y aurait dame prend
G7 et chaque et mat en un coup donc ça
va pas être joué là le coup ça va être
fou F6 c'est évident qui embroche la
dame et le fou la dame qui va retourner
sur ses pas en D2 pour garder le contact
avec le fou B2 et on verra si les Noirs
échangent en B2 ou si ils jouent un
autre coup à noter aussi qu'on a du mal
à faire vivre le fou pour le moment sur
la diagonale puisqu'on peut chasser ce
cavalier par le coup E4 simplement
lorsqu'on chasse le cavalier avec le
coup E4 et bien ça va boucher la vue du
Fou et donc finalement ce cavalier est
un excellent antidote au poison au venin
G2 exactement le fou qui a le seum on
peut dire pour le moment
mais bon peut-être justement il a craché
son sel à un moment sur l'homme donc à
voir
est-ce que cavalier F6 est un coup
visuellement pas du fin non c'est pas
moche le cavalier est bien placé en
dessin que le fou a envie de venir en F6
non mais la non mais c'est sûr c'est
évident hein c'est forcément le coup
Yann qui part alors attention Yann qui
dans son de pas trop en faire avec ses
allers-retours attention de pas perdre
trop de temps donc faut F6 qu'il est en
train de jouer regardez la dame qui
repart en des deux c'était prévu
il a le coup d'après alors
est-ce que c'est pas cavalier F4
joli coup alors l'idée c'est que sur
dame prend cavalier il veut fou prendre
les deux gagné une qualité sur pion
prend cavalier qui est peut-être le
meilleur coup d'ailleurs dame prend
dames cavalier prend B2 du coup on
enlèvera la tour et bon ben il aura la
paire de fou mais le cahier des deux va
se sauter en C4 D6 alors je sais pas
faudra peut-être résoudre encore deux
trois soucis
a priori ça va être à la partie mais
parce que en fait sur quel F4 tu as pas
mis le choix problème c'est qu'il veut
te faire dame prend si tu fais faut
prendre un M6 il va te faire dame prend
les deux il va te prendre deux par échec
il va te faire de plus alors est-ce que
tu as le temps d'activer de la 7e j'en
sais rien mais tu as pas l'air de jouer
par la montage avec les Blancs c'est au
mieux tu fais les compensations du coup
KF4 bon mais il a il connaît en fait il
veut sécher complètement
donc ce qui semble logique c'est le truc
regardez c'est GF Dame des deux qui est
les deux fous B2 tour B1 ou D1 ou je
sais pas je pense sur D1 parce que de
toute façon tu vas vouloir faire
cavalier C4 pour attaquer le fou donc ça
sert à rien de le chasser en amont et tu
veux sauter vers des 6
[Musique]
ça va pas l'air d'être sans intérêt pour
les blancs tout ça
je veux dire ok enfin si c'est tout et
qui sait te sécher complètement et qu'il
a toute la ligne jusqu'au bout pourquoi
pas mais il a peut-être jusqu'au bout
bon bah au pire nul nul c'est la vie
quoi mais c'est ce dont on parlait hier
pendant les parties et en début de
retransmission ici que cet avantage de
préparation de Yann sur quatre parties
ça peut payer et si là il réussit lui à
effacer une partie qu'il a avec les
Noirs c'est évidemment un immense
avantage
mais il a aussi voilà beaucoup travaillé
pour avoir cet avantage il a les moyens
qui lui sont mis à disposition et puis
il a déjà travaillé pour un match
précédent donc ça ça se trouve il l'a
pas préparé pour ce match mais c'est un
truc qui a déjà
vu et revu depuis depuis 2 ans on va
dire après on savait qu'il y a Yann
avait l'avantage de la préparation donc
on n'est pas surpris de du scénario de
cette partie jusqu'à maintenant
c'est-à-dire de trouver les coûts
maintenant
pour réussir quand même à exercer une
petite pression mais ouais il a l'air il
a l'air déçu et c'est vrai que ça ça
devient ça ça devient compliqué pour
pour dingyrène parce qu'il prend il
subit une préparation à la partie
précédente et là il resubit quelque part
un petit peu mais au moins là il se
retrouve pas en danger c'est lui qui va
quand même essayer de presser ce qui
peut s'il y a un apprécié quoi c'est pas
grave ça fera
il faut pas qu'il faut pas qu'il fasse
n'importe quoi qui force le gain pour
rien parce que nul bah ça continue de
jouer et puis finalement la dernière
partie oui il aura les Noirs certes mais
s'il gagne il est champion du monde donc
la pression si commence à y avoir un
combat de rue dans dans la partie entre
pour tout le monde
est-ce que Yann aura envie de de tout
risquer de façon un jour il faudra bien
se découvrir et risquer pour gagner et
c'est sûr mais ouais c'est difficile de
jouer avec la pression sur une partie
d'un titre de champion du monde Fabien
ah ouais non là ça sera ça sera lourd à
porter mais là déjà tu vois Yann genre
il savait jusque là mais là je suis pas
sûr qu'il sache le prochain coup ou s'il
en connaît un il ne connaîtra pas 50
donc ça va quand même jouer et il faut
qu'il trouve le bon setup pour nier tous
les problèmes parce que comme on l'a dit
il est blanc en fait le carré va sauter
en C4 et en B6 et en B6 voire en A5
W c'est rien tu peux le soutenir comme
tu veux comme souvent dans la Catane le
roi blanc peut fonder plus facilement
ton foot tu montes par G2 F3 etc donc tu
peux faire des trucs enfin c'est pas
d'être drôle et il se passe rien et tu
dois prendre un perpète ou je sais pas
quoi et au-delà de ça Ding on l'a dit on
le répète c'est un des meilleurs
spécialistes mondiaux de ce type de
position avec une toute petite
initiative mais alors il est capable de
te la tenir pendant un nombre de coups
hallucinant on rappelle hein qui il est
arrivé à ce niveau de la compétition
Ding en gagnant la dernière partie des
candidats avec les pièces blanches
contre Nakamura une partie que vous
pourrez retrouver qu'on analyser sur la
chaîne Youtube et vous verrez que
c'était un massage stratégique
au tactique de très très hautes volets
donc digne dans ces positions il peut il
peut être quasiment injouable il est
très bon enfin de toute façon il est
très bon mais
oui quand la pollution du quoi sont bien
bien ses qualités etc c'est une qualité
de calcul
précis il est précis et il trouve les
coûts qui posent le plus de problèmes il
a pas peur en fait c'est aussi quelque
chose ça d'important c'est des fois tu
peux rejeter certaines positions même si
ton cerveau voit pas exactement pourquoi
tu ouais je la sens pas
pourquoi
il a pas peur
Eliane allez pour moi là il commence à
un peu trop se lever
la tension est en train de rattraper un
peu Yann là ça devient un petit peu
exagéré
c'est quand même du rapide digne qui
réussit mieux à maîtriser ses émotions
j'ai l'impression qu'il réussit à être
plus sérieuse sur les chéquier attention
Yann cette attitude pourrait mener à un
moment donné à une gaffe on sait que
c'est le défaut de Yann il est fort il
défend très bien il est très bien
préparé il est précis il a toutes les
qualités du Mondial mais il a quand même
historiquement
ce défaut de pouvoir faire des gaffes
oui et voilà que des fois les nerfs
lâche un peu parce qu'on peut comprendre
en fait c'est pas le problème mais ça
reste un défaut en tant que compétiteur
oui alors il a il a masqué demi masqué
ce défaut puisque c'est ce qui lui a
coûté la partie 12 cette cette gaffe
étonnante ce B4 qui est parti puis le F5
il a déjà connu ce problème dans le dans
le match attention là de pas de pas
subir l'événement je veux dire deux fois
parce que les D4 qui laisse le service
de qualité tu es dans une position
difficile tout de même mais
bon c'était pas voilà
donc à voir
bon mais là ça va je veux dire sa
position elle pose pas de problème mais
il va falloir quand même un petit peu
précis et trouver quelques coups j'étais
pas en train de de mettre des doutes sur
sa position mais plutôt sur sur son
attitude Fabien mais comme tu l'as dit
la position va attention à ce cavalier
qui a un rebond on décide on en a parlé
mais attention de ne pas négliger non
plus le rebond à 5 qui peut mentionner
avoir avoir son intérêt donc il y a deux
rebonds possibles bien qui vient un peu
vite sur l'échiquier tourbé 8 j'ai
l'impression qu'il fait des petites
limites quand même comme quelqu'un qui
connaît c'est des petites petits regards
là vers le haut comme ça en mode Mémoire
très bien j'ai envie de dire parce que
tu blindes-besses tu peux toucher espion
pour ne plus être dans le viseur du Fou
G2 donc voilà puis on est plus cloué tu
aurais pu bouger le foot et 8 sans
perdre B7 et donc a priori ton idée
c'est de faire baisser c'est un moment
donc avaler 5 il me sur B6 jouer
cavalier C6
qui tient tout mais on n'aime pas
laisser ça mais en fait si ça va ça va
tu te renoncer 7 tu évites les vis-à-vis
et mets un psychédy c'était bien placé
tu peux avoir B4 B5 pour le blindé il va
il va il va t'embêter celui-là tu as pas
envie de te faire baisses en fait
mais si t'as pas mieux tu as pas mieux
après si on fait pas B6 admettons quid
du Fou C8 Fabien
alors est-ce que on veut enchaîner fou
prends E5 puis on prend le 5 et de ses
parents
et on va tolérer quand même une tour sur
la 7e qui va forcément arriver un tour
des 6
faut B7 peut-être tour d'essai alors un
tempo change les fous est-ce que cette
que vaut cette Finale 5
mieux pour les blancs mais ce que c'est
vraiment mieux ou c'est juste avec ce
roi qui va venir chasser les pions moi
j'aimerais pas trop que les Noirs quoi
mais en plus tu as le problème que
potentiellement les blancs ils ont une
menace c'est tours C7 torber 7 en 1 7
une paire de Tours mettre la tour la
tour en B8 faire G5 croiser 7 3G6 il
faut bien juger
avec H5 Royal 7 mais du coup bon allez
je me fais plaisir on peut on peut
peut-être vivre un blocus bon j'ai
laissé un pions mais attention parce que
cette structure elle est bizarre mais
elle peut créer un blocus du roman
mettre le pion F4 après
cette position qui peut partir
apparaître un peu bizarre on a
emmuré le roi et on va vouloir
maintenant faire un décalage bon alors
après c'est compliqué ouais si j'ai cinq
on a le contre jeu mais c'est juste pour
c'était juste pour montrer quelque chose
d'un peu long pour dire il faut bien
juger moi je rentrerai pas dedans
parce que même si je juge bien faudra
bien le jouer encore parce qu'il va y
avoir des coups précis chiant tout le
long non oui mais si on fait pas ça donc
on part sur B6 alors ouais donc il y
avait 6 qui est ici son a dit après
est-ce qu'on peut faire tourner vite
et tu vois je veux voir les filtres 8
serpents les deux serpents qui tiennent
les cases peut-être un mot F6 enlever ce
cavalier alors E3 du coup coûte constant
de solidation
tu te ramènes
oui mais bon
là faut arriver
échangerait pas il sait que
fondamentalement c'est
égalé il a peut-être toute la variante
qu'on vient de vous montrer un tour de
8h30 ou c'est 7 3 rois qui est 17 bouffe
bouffe B6 fubé 7 tour D8 nul
c'est complètement
on a joué les coups les plus logiques
mais attention alors Ding on va avoir vu
jouer pas mal de fois tu te dis bon et
tourner un machin c'est nul et puis tu
vois si c'est toi qui est devant
l'échiquier enfin dis toi globalement du
bon je le fais et puis tant pis j'ai
rien mais alors digne il peut te sortir
des coups qui qui sont un peu pas
bizarres mais qui te maintiennent
l'impression qu'il te donne pas la nul
tout de suite il peut il peut non mais
c'est une belle qualité ça de te laisser
galérer l'adversaire à trouver encore
des coups encore des coups encore des
coups j'ai une bêtise mais si un tour
c'est un qui est bon ou un coup comme ça
un peu de côté qui laisse la colonne
comme tu le disais ah tiens Forget tour
des deux tours c'est 7 calculer et lui
il va regarder alors lui il en a
absolument rien à faire si calcul que tu
sors pas facilement et que tu trouves
pas la nul de manière directe qui te l'a
fait jouer un peu à l'image d'un Carl
scène quelque part il est un peu cette
qualité
de te faire jouer et Yann qui repart une
nouvelle fois il parle beaucoup je
trouve que ça commence à être un peu
beaucoup est-ce qu'il le paiera cher et
ce qui paiera l'addition de de ces
allers-retours
mais je crois qu'il a pas le choix il
tient pas il peut pas c'est pas un choix
là ça part c'est
il subit il subit il subit un peu les
vêtements après il se repose à l'image
on en a déjà parlé mais d'un joueur de
tennis sur sa première balle et on sait
l'importance dans les tailles break
aussi au tennis les gros serveurs sont
souvent forts
même si tu l'as subis quelque part tu tu
te reposes sur une arme très puissante
un geste que tu sais faire tu maîtrises
qui dépend que de toi et peut-être plus
facile à maîtriser donc j'ai envie de
dire pour ce match là heureusement pour
Yann quelque part qui qu'il est qu'il
est cette préparation
titanesque bah qui est mais qui est son
point fort évidemment mais qui lui
permet quelque part de d'égaliser ce
problème de pression
alors pour jouer ok bon bah faut prendre
ça il y aura pas trop le choix donc on
va revenir le jouer quand il le sent
alors j'ai une idée bizarre Fabien vous
prend des 8 tours C1 et sur roi F8 en B7
on se calcule aussi un petit peu ici
Fabien Johnny ce qui peut être
intéressant sur tout reprend B7 tours
français 8 sur fond B7 cavaliers
mais ça peut être solide
c'est bien
donc cavalier
tour D8 mais là
ouais si je change pas les tours comme
ça
je peux espérer là je voulais en tout
cas
oui
F3 tout reprend à deux donc important
donc c'est 7 et peut-être tour c'est un
maintenant
fout des 6
et il y a pas droit fuite à cause de
fous promet ça toujours le même machin
[Musique]
F6 on voit un peu
tu repars je sais pas et tu
ouais bon sortir de là après clairement
c'est pas impossible de sortir de là
il se passe rien de grave mais pour le
moment tu sors pas donc tu vas devoir ne
pas sortir pendant 4 5 10 15 coups
de 7 il y a une opportunité il sera
peut-être là alors sur cavalier de 17
bon déjà on peut peut-être faire tour à
8 aussi
et on revient à la maison on revient à
la maison
mais bon après on fait quoi avec la tour
à 8 à 5 je sais pas F6 mais bon qui a
été 7 franchement tu as envie de sauter
sur les foutres que le reposer si tu
peux et mais bon voilà tenir c'est pas
nul direct donc il y a les tours et
qu'elle est toujours reposer loin de là
d'ailleurs non non c'est pas c'est pas
nul direct ici Fabien mais Yann qui joue
là c'est lui aussi quand même on a dit
qu'il se levait un peu trop peut-être
mais dans les coups jouets pour
l'instant il y a pas une seule erreur
une nouvelle fois dans cette partie on
est en train de vivre un match quasiment
sans faute
je me demandais ce que alors je pense
pas que ça marche mais tu vois je me
disais un F5 e prends F5
vous aussi prise aussi prise ici tour
des 7 ouais non ça va pas suffire
et pour essayer de passer la tour sur la
7e or les blancs serait pas perdant mais
on joue plutôt nul maintenant ouais
ouais non mais oui enfin le problème
de compensation on a juste fini
mais ça peut être une idée
intéressante
le petit module il propose fou et
c'était
logique il va sûrement prendre et jouer
le footer avec un point de plus pour les
blancs mais les tours qui restent en vie
qui laissent donc un
espoir au blanc de l'emporter sur le
long court
je pense que tu es plutôt content
surtout quand tu vois qu'il Yann
connaissait assez loin pour Ding je
pense que tu es assez content d'avoir
cette position finalement
enfin un truc un petit truc que tu vas
pouvoir jouer à un moment et voilà ça y
est il se lève il a validé quelque part
j'ai pas envie de dire en avantage mais
une position nettement plus agréable à
jouer c'est validé donc il va il va
aller un petit peu lui aussi
faire un tour mais
c'est beaucoup plus cohérent là gestion
de Ding qui ne se lève à bon escient il
veut pas rester assis pendant une heure
d'affilée sur une partie ça se comprend
il a besoin de décompresser de temps en
temps voilà il décompresse une deux fois
sur l'heure
pas de souci
parce que c'est dans l'autre coup c'est
tout à 8 qui perd pas sur le champ mais
on sait pas qu'on se dépatouiller après
Clément donc c'est l'herbe bizarre c'est
bizarre c'est pas bon donc il faut
prendre pour prendre on a dit roi et
fuite a priori défend le fou fou prend
B7 vous pouvez mettre la position elle
va arriver sur les surtout pas tout
reprendre pour ceux qui savent pas parce
que bon il faut vous le signaler ça
gagne aussi un pion mais les fous de
toujours poser permettent de faire des
nuls assez facilement et blanc aurait
beau avoir un pion passé les dames
potentiel ça va être il va être bloqué
un moment trop facilement et on peut pas
gagner alors qu'après faut prendre on a
le même problème de prononcer les pions
passées mais on garde la tour en vie
donc on peut créer des problèmes en plus
elle est bien placé sur cette septième
rangée
surtout D6 attaque la tour F4 elle
perdue en C4 défend tout le monde et
puis on va tenter que les blancs de
ramener le roi de faire un pion passé de
bon on va jouer un petit coup à droite à
gauche et avec les Noirs va falloir
bien défendre longtemps et globalement
c'est un truc que network faisait tout
le match alors après il y a quand même
un point positif pour les Noirs un point
très positif dans cette finale Fabien
c'est que les pions sont fixés pour le
moment sur casse blanche sur la case du
Fou et on peut avoir d'énormes
difficultés
avec les noirs et c'est là-dessus qui va
probablement jouer avec le concert de ce
fou E7 et de ce pion A5 qui peuvent
visser à vitam eternam les pions B3 et
A2 on serait beaucoup plus content avec
les Blancs d'avoir échangé les pions
quand même ce pion passé sur l'aile donc
ça c'est le c'est la prochaine étape
baume au coeur a essayé d'obtenir mais
on peut essayer de voir des cas de
figure ou la torera vera 4 le roi se
ramènera enfin on peut travailler la
position juste en fait puis voilà on va
on va essayer de le faire en tout cas ça
se dirige vitesse grand V vers cette
position tu reprends des 7 tu reprends
des 7 3 et 8 maintenant on va voir fou
prend B7 oui sinon il va y avoir une
semaine
et décalé
8 donc c'est 7 sont les coûts les plus
logiques
on arrive à cette fameuse position qui
était tant attendu et ça va jouer
longtemps
jusqu'à ce que les tours restent en vie
exactement s'il y a plus de tour ça sera
nul mais bon tu es pas comme ça quoi
vrais chances de gain pour Ding parce
que
tu sais pas ce que tu fais juste tu
tournes les pièces en rond et tu changes
pas la tour c'est ton seul travail
et tu vois ce que tu peux faire à un
moment ou un autre et puis on voit quoi
à 5 donc le fameux coup pour bloquer
les pions
et on va voir peut-être torse deux
pour pas avoir la tour des deux
s'activer et puis tu fais 3 tu ramènes
un peu le roi tu j'en sais rien dire
c'est trop dur de donner un vrai plan
parce que de toute façon vous voyez bien
la jauge qui est quasiment en milieu
donc objectivement nul mais en pratique
c'est une autre histoire quoi
shuffle de piscine mélanger les pièces
juste bouger bouger bouger puis espérer
un moment donné faire quelque chose et
puis danseur peut ouvrir une porte enfin
faut voir
parce que les Noirs devront défendre
sans rien faire ici
tu reprends le 7 peut être une idée
alors le problème de ton SS c'est que tu
c'est un peu tôt
en fait je comprends vous voulez faire à
3 B4 et avoir un pion passé mais la tour
va être beaucoup trop forte elle va vous
arrêter les pions et elle voulait manger
vous allez perdre la finale
il y a quatre c'est pas un coup qu'on
veut voir parce que ça donnerait la case
B4 là par exemple après à 4 je pense que
ce serait vraiment facile de faire nul
sans aucun problème c'est effectivement
B4 on y arrive jamais le footer il se
défendent l'un l'autre avec le pion A5
le fouet ancré et tu fais rien avec les
mains enfin tant pis en béton en plus
mais
à part servir à mettre un fond C4 et te
servira à rien quoi
bon c'est toujours ça c'est mieux que
rien mais
non mais ça va aller pour aller voir ça
donc oui non ça on veut pas et faut pas
se laisser bloquer c'est pour ça que les
foutres que le reposer peuvent justement
entendre vers la nul à cause de ce genre
de blocus qui fait qu'avec un pion de
plus des fois deux tu peux pas
qui prend son temps là il essaye de
trouver un plan non pas pour avancer
déjà mais pour stabiliser
alors là il a pris il s'est caché les
yeux
après tu sais le coup facile comme tu
disais mais bon tu peux trouver mieux tu
fais mieux
tu peux aussi jouer un truc comme fois 6
pour mettre le four en trois
la tour en C4 Laurent F3 et après voir
non mais bien sûr de toute façon faut
améliorer petit à petit et mais sérieux
c'est pas simple enfin on a vu tellement
des parties comme ça de gagner
ok un qui était très fort c'était GIRAF
dans le genre de truc
hyper bon pour foot
parce que bon tactiquement
c'est un magicien du genre de position
et
[Musique]
si on supprime les fous ce serait
probablement gagnant pour les blancs
mais bon supprimer les fous c'est pas
c'est pas chose
tu es déjà très très bien quoi
tu lui coupes la tour
comme G6
[Musique]
c'est peut-être moins grave dans le sens
où tu veux lui couper la lui laisser la
tour là et le et ce que j'arrive à te
faire calme tour B2 je te force tous ces
quatre entre guillemets je reviens
avec la tour je vais foudre
[Musique]
de me démener quoi
ouais mais ça va être fin le truc c'est
cool mais ça va être hyper dur
concrètement c'est pas facile non je
pense faut déjà stabiliser
bon il prend son temps toute façon il
est encore un quart d'heure
et il aura deux minutes ce serait pas
trop dur à jouer non plus donc là il
charge vraiment peut-être un setup à
mettre en place
si tu as même une seconde avec les
blancs avec le rajout de coup et que tu
ferais tout C8 et tu ne le dire
directement
un peu de temps si il a besoin de
calculer pour terminer la partie mais je
veux dire par là qu'il prend pas de
risque Fabien ici non aucun risque après
ouais c'est bien aussi si tu peux
cumuler un peu de tourner en rond dans
la position plus pression à la pendule
sur l'adversaire
qui a un moment peut faire la diff
ça c'est le c'est dans l'idéal après il
y a aussi un plan si on installe le four
en C4 pour faire F5 pour jouer pour F5
non mais sûrement que peut-être les Nike
va essayer de te mettre un mur avec G6
ou quoi mais bon peut-être on verra bien
mais oui le français 4 il sera pas mal
de toute façon en fait les fous dans ce
genre de trucs ils adorent être sur des
cases stables en quoi paf le français 4
il est là tu le touche plus et noir il a
la case B4 pour ça c'est tout mais je
regarde s'il ailleurs chaque fois il
faut regarder les coups de Tours qui
attaque le fou qui derrière un tempo qui
est trop fort autre chose après et c'est
chiant enfin c'est ouais faut regarder
chaque coup donc on voit la différence
c'est même pas le pion de plus pour le
fin la différence du pion de plus pour
le moment c'est pas qu'il peut avancer
c'est qu'il donne la case C4 non dit tu
te plantes là peut-être tu joues pour
avancer tu as tu joues pour F5 enfin tu
fais des petits trucs ici ou là après
évidemment sur un jeu parfait ça suffira
pas mais bon
ok on va pas toujours voir des discours
parfait c'est très dur en fait en
pratique les échecs en C4 tu réussis à
bien l'installer sur ton point à deux tu
pourras avoir des B4 qui réattent la
tour
après je comprends pour ces deux
peut-être qu'il a pas envie de le faire
si vite parce que c'est dommage voilà tu
es sur la 7e adverse tu as déjà accompli
quelque chose
elle est tellement belle
donc à voir mais
en tout cas il prend il prend
allègrement son temps d'un coup qui a
mon avis est important il prend le il
prend son temps au bon moment
parce que c'est vrai que tu peux aussi
te faire rapidement sécher par
l'adversaire et prendre le temps à ce
moment-là ça peut lui garantir une
dizaine ou une quinzaine de coups de
pression après sans forcément avoir à
énormément réfléchir
il joue tout sur ces quatre alors tour
C4 c'est une idée dont on n'a pas trop
parlé on l'a évoqué au tout début c'est
qu'on peut essayer de mettre la tour en
A4 pour jouer pour A3 B4 ça c'est un
autre plan
et lorsque la tour arrive en D2 on
pourrait se permettre de mettre la tour
en A4 pour défendre et attaquer et donc
Yann réagit immédiatement par fou B4 ce
plan coup pour le moment la tour
immédiatement
faudra aussi regarder des coups comme
fou 4 qui peuvent menacer tour C8 échec
et fou prend H7 dans certains mondes
attention de pas se faire fishoriser
fermer le fou comme illustre champion du
monde Bobby Fischer mais lui c'était pas
en dernière partie de champion du monde
c'était la première c'était direct
c'était instantané
alors
pour cela il faut que même sur tous ces
deux c'est un coup pour forcer tourner
deux et
donc
en fait c'est vrai que c'est peut-être
juste tu peux même pas arriver à faire
ce qu'on disait à écrire
j'adorais sauter en Détroit avec le
foulard je fais rien mais je t'empêche
pas des deux et après je commence à
faire mon travail mais là tu montes
je vais rien faire
8 recette faut prendre H7 ouais mais lui
il est moins grave que les autres
ici je vais fouiller 8 déjà
mais bon
je peux faire ouais
mais je vais te faire 4 j'ai réussi à
obtenir un truc comme ça c'est chaud
quoi
j'ai 7 tu prends ça tu prends J8
[Musique]
mais ouais enfin je sais pas mais je
veux dire en fait c'est ça le problème
parce que j'ai peut-être que on a
sous-estimé c'est qu'en fait si on se
fait liquider les tours en force et ben
il y a rien enfin il y a juste même pas
de loin
mais alors il faut quand même par
principe faire à 4 tant pis il fait
tourner deux tu fais quoi assis sur ton
fondateur C8 tu fais un petit trick et
tu vas quand même un peu jouer ça il
fait ça tu fais foudre tu vas essayer de
faire tourcer cette fois 8 toi tu peux
couvrir par E3 bon
oui c'est très léger c'est très peu mais
de toute façon tu donnes pas nul comme
ça
après oui si on est bloqué
on est bloqué quoi
déblo cadeau mais tu es pas obligé de
signer nul tout de suite tout de suite
quand même non mais c'est quand même
un truc mais
ça va pas être amen en fait on aurait
voulu faire ça en dernier recours et
avoir avant travaillé fait autre chose à
remis un peu la dire ça mal à la pendule
et
c'est vrai que c'est chiant va te [__]
t'as pas de torse
pour foudre c'était pas si bête et
l'ordi lui proposer un truc comme fou et
4 alors il est sorti de deux
en fait on aurait voulu ça avec la Tour
Noire enfin pion à deux et la Tour Noire
là haut chez elle
et bon
et essayer et là je suis pas sûr qu'on
va pouvoir essayer grand chose
donc on a fait torse les deux
donc tour des deux il veut te sourcilite
ou il veut juste faire nul direct
bon après ce qui fait nul ce qui serait
bon qu'est-ce qu'on fait on se fait
attaquer tous les pions il va échanger
les tours et il veut monter le roi sans
se faire bloquer sans le pion à 4 il se
garde un espoir d'un pion passager le
dame bon ça normalement ça devrait pas
enfin c'est trop dur de gagner mais Rose
B4 ça c'est pas très
5 vies
il va te reprendre par derrière
non ça c'est nul tout de suite il est
parti en B4 direct pourquoi pas ça évite
directement les A3
et j'imagine qu'il va monter le roi très
grosse prépa de Yann encore mais
peut-être qu'il connaissait jusqu'au
bout
on a tout foot que le reposer et je t'ai
changé toi en face il a pu connaître
très très loin c'est pour ça peut-être
qu'il se lever autant
ainsi un piège là-dedans un truc qui
nous ferait suer je vois pas mais
pas tellement
je dirais un roi c'est simple
bon c'est vraiment pas obligé mais si tu
es ce blanc
à 4 et A3 il va quand même parce que
c'est grave ça c'est c'est notre
histoire mais pourquoi laisser ça quoi
l'option la plus simple
je voulais te proposer
[Musique]
les deux joueurs qui répètent et la
nulle qui est signée bon bah écoute
très bien défendu de la part de niveau
qui
a pas suivi par défendre en tout cas
très bien joué très bien préparé et donc
on va arriver peut-être à l'ultime
partie de ce match alors ou pas mais
l'ultime partie en 25 minutes pour sûr
ça c'est sûr ça c'est sûr
c'est
[Musique]
très très serré ben à l'image du match
trois parties trois parties nul mais
trois parties de très très bonne facture
grosse qualité de jeu là la prochaine
ça peut un petit peu su au niveau nerf
tu as plus de fièvre
super c'est fini même quand tu es
gagnant tu vas quand même trembloter
parce que tu joues
pour un truc énorme quand le titre de
champion du monde aux échecs tu joues
pour l'histoire tu joues pour sur une
partie donc voilà et si jamais il annule
ça peut arriver il se retrouveront après
pour des Blitz
la précision de la partie
99,2 pour DIN
99,7 pour Yann parti parfaite plus de
fautes plus de fautes plus de fautes non
mais c'est écoute c'est très bien
ça suit un peu quand même
[Musique]
le studio tout ça remettre les bonnes
couleurs Fabien donc digne qui aura les
Noirs les Blancs on risque de revoir une
nouvelle espagnole ça va être ça va être
intéressant c'est vraiment difficile à
passer dans l'ouverture une nouvelle
fois pour
pour Ding pour
ça va de nouveau être compliqué
l'ouverture en espérant qu'il ait réussi
à trouver la solution l'antidote contre
ce fouet 3 fous des deux ouais donc
c'est là où ça peut être très utile de
pouvoir parler avec ton second nom qui
qui a pu checker un peu et te dire même
sans donnerant de précise ça fait aussi
je joue ça et hop et ça ça va ça tient
donc ouais et donc je sais pas s'ils ont
accès ou pas justement après sinon il va
y penser tout seul dans sa tête mais
tu peux te tromper là ça redevient comme
les échecs d'avant ou tu avais pas
l'ordi pour te dire quoi ce qui était
plus amusant c'était plus amusant
mesdames et messieurs on prend une
petite respiration avant peut-être la
dernière partie de ce match de
championnat du monde qui oppose Yann
nepomashi dinglieren qui couronnera un
nouveau champion du monde d'échecs on se
retrouve dans cinq petites minutes à
tout de suite les amis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour Fabien pour
cette peut-être
ultime partie du match de championnat du
monde la 18e
18e partie et une balle de match mutuel
puisque si un des deux joueurs l'emporte
sur cette partie il sera sacré champion
du monde
la tension doit être à son comble et ce
qu'ils vont être capable Fabien sous une
telle pression de nous proposer un
niveau de jeu équivalent à ce qu'on a vu
dans les trois premières parties rien
n'est moins sûr là c'est
un niveau de pression
maximum tu peux pas avoir plus en fait
là tu peux pas c'est une partie
où tu joues tout
un titre de champion du monde et
peut-être à la clé de cette partie et en
cas de nul on repart pour deux parties
je crois en 10 plus quelque chose ou
peut-être des blistes direct je sais
même pas il faut mettre point
d'exclamation format c'est écrit dans le
chat j'ai oublié j'ai su ce matin mais
avec la pression nous aussi on craque
Fabien et c'est une nouvelle espagnole
et 5 + 3 directement allez on enchaîne
avec 5 + 3 puis 5 + 3 puis 3 + 2 donc on
passera en blitz ce qui favorise
peut-être Yann mais bon avec
la pression de l'événement je pense que
ça Nivelle quand même tout ça alors cet
Espagnol est-ce qu'on va revoir cette
idée avec vous trois ou pas
les coûts qui sont joués rapidement dans
l'ouverture évidemment les deux hommes
c'est ce qu'ils ont à faire
ça repart pour le A4 fou D7 petit rock
et est-ce que on va revoir le fouet 3 je
crois qu'il n'avait pas le droit de
discuter avec leur second dans à Fabien
d'après ce que j'ai lu dans le chat et
donc il repart Yann pour la même
position dans laquelle il avait obtenu
un avantage cavalier à 5b prend à 4
c'est rejouer
cavalier C3 et on n'a pas eu le temps de
fixer les problèmes de la position avec
des on n'a pas eu le droit simplement
pour Ding et donc quand on n'a pas
d'ordinateur et ben on peut pas
mais ça c'est pas facile
donc il change un petit truc c'est dit
tiens tu as dû réfléchir à ça à fond
je modifie quelque chose est-ce que
c'est parce que finalement on nous avait
des informations
mais je sais pas moi c'est le droit de
parler ou pas
tout à l'heure on n'avait pas
l'information
et il se lève
c'est hyper inattendu quoi
c'est mais il y a inattendu
bon déjà tout reprend B2 il se passe
quoi
probablement qu'il prend à 4 enfin je
sais pas je vois pas on va on va on va
bouger un petit peu les pièces tour s'en
va et on revient en C3 non et on va
bouffer à 6
carrément
et tu prends la paire de fou ou tu
saccages les pions et tu en attaque de à
la fois que ça va pas être à son tac E5
aussi donc un attaque 3 paramètre un fou
des 6 pour colmater mais ça forcément
c'est avantage blanc on voit la
structure il y a pas besoin d'expliquer
plus longtemps que de mettre les pions
en rouge Fabien
donc faut bien
ok donc prolon pas te reprendre les deux
mais il veut juste qu'elle prend un 4
juste faire
ça
le pion A4
[Musique]
dans la même structure tout à l'heure
cette fois-ci
mais
tu peux le travailler peut-être 10 pour
sortir et toi tu en avantage de
structure intéressant il y a une
nouvelle fois qui sort une prépa de son
chapeau essaie de nouveau Ding sous
pression Yann qui joue peu de coup
aujourd'hui
préparation excellentissime
[Musique]
pour l'ex challenger au titre mondial
contre manus Carlsen dit quelque part à
la position du maître des lieux j'ai
envie de dire puisque par lui a déjà
joué le match il y a pas le titre mais
tu sais c'est un peu comme c'est lui qui
défendait quelque chose quoi puisque
puisque DIN qui est ici pour la première
fois et donc ce fou B1 qui qui arrive un
peu comme un cheveu sur la soupe on s'y
attendait pas
il flotte
c'est un coup auquel je n'aurais pas pu
penser ouais alors je voyais un peu dans
le chat trois vieilles parties de
grand-mère dessus donc en gros ça existe
pas de la nouveauté mais c'est rare quoi
et
non mais en fait on peut y penser enfin
faut connaître quoi spontanément ça
devient pas au cerveau mais après après
je comprends c'est tout reprend mes deux
va pas bah du coup c'est cool quoi et
donc oui tu peux avoir des moments où tu
auras plus en B3 il faut bien mal placer
mais on sait que les pions pourront
rebouger un jour puis on met trois pour
elle en B4 rien le four je reviendrai en
à deux où on peut songer à faire ces
trois repasser le fond en C2 soit B4
soit B4 soit je ne sais pas enfin et
petit à petit le fou ça m'énerve mais ça
prendra du temps bien sûr en tout cas il
est venu avec des très bonnes idées avec
les pièces blanches Yann ouais des
petites lignes pas très connues où il y
a du venin
et qui sont intéressants donc dans c'est
bien
ça tank de nouveau côté Ding
et on va voir est-ce qu'il peut essayer
de jouer avec C5 son idée fétiches
de la partie précédente là le C4 qui
vient un peu miner il peut faire
il peut faire il peut faire plein de
choses c'est un peu dans son style non
c'est ça c'est 4
le nom pourquoi c'est si fort je sais
pas à quel point c'est fort mais c'est
intéressant parce que si on revient un
coup avant juste pour vous dire les
noirs attaquent B2 donc soit en défense
pion avec Dame C1 tour B un dame vous
pouvez faire ce que vous voulez mais
vous mettez mal vos pièces dans tous les
cas et faut bien en fait ça permet
d'ouvrir la tour qui attaque à 4 et de
se prévenir de te reprendre les deux
puis c'est pas si grave il en reprenne
le pion mais on prend à 4 vous voyez les
pièces sur la colonel sont pas défendues
donc le cahier la carte va rebouger ça
serait ce qu'on appelle une découverte
et on rate le cavalier et ou le pion à 6
et dans ce sens là c'est un joli coup
parce que il a fait dans ma vie c'est un
joli coup parce que c'est une défense
active on va dire donc c'est une défense
directe voilà une dame on protège le
pion et donc on avait parlé du coup B3
ici
alors le coup B3 est peut-être même
forcé puisqu'il fait deux choses le pion
B2 maintenant et attaquer on a renouvelé
la menace avec les Noirs donc B3 on
défend le pion et on attaque à 4 voilà
et on veut le reprendre avec le cavalier
si possible pour se garder cette colonne
à ouverte comme on avait expliqué lors
de la seconde partie c'est des partages
donc sur B3 qui allait l'idée de Ding on
va on va on va sûrement le voir
rapidement parce que
je pense pas que Yann prenne énormément
de temps pour jouer B3 après faut quand
même rappeler que cette partie
vaut un titre de champion du monde c'est
pas peu valoir elle le vaut simplement
en cas de nul ça continue mais elle vaut
un titre de champion du monde celle-là
donc B3 tap
on va voir comment comment ça va
continuer cette histoire
donc il peut pas prendre si il prend B3
il va y avoir 5
non mais faut qu'il je sais pas faut
qu'il joue un coup il est un peu emmêlé
avec ses pièces avec la dame 8 le fou
des sept tout ça ça bouge pas trop
[Musique]
le Cavalaire 5 un peu hors-jeu il peut
songer déjà le ramener si l'envie
pourquoi pas
oui qui ici c'est sûrement un coup hein
mais bon
est-ce que t'as pas pu tout envie
d'attendre de faire un coup utile de
laisser prendre avec le cavalier ou le
pion et repartir on est content toujours
il prendra du cavalier mais ce qui est
ici mal ce qui peut l'embête de C4 aussi
ce qui valait je veux dire est-ce que
c'est grave est-ce que tu préfères avoir
une tour en 4 un cavalier il y a des
bars j'en sais rien moi mais ça me
semble pas clair de
de ce que je dois accomplir
et tu peux partir aussi sur
sur rooi8 qui est j'évite F5 tu joues de
l'autre côté
ouais ça ça peut être intéressant
est-ce que ça vient justifier aussi la
dame 8 qui a des passages vers H5
je trouve que c'est très harmonieux
comme plan pour pour les noirs et dans
le même genre de cas de figure tu peux
faire H6 qui achète peut-être pareil
pour libérer faire F5 ouais mais bon
enfin c'est des trucs
qu'on voit dans l'italienne donc
peut-être ici s'envisageable donc on a
notre défaut de structure à l'aide d'âme
mais on mise sur le fait d'être bien
placé à l'aile droite que le fou bien il
est quand même loin du jeu tu vois dans
l'Italie il peut revenir dans d'habitude
il est plus versé de ou quoi donc là il
est un peu loin et
pourquoi pas alors j'en sais rien
[Musique]
j'ai pas de dire j'aime bien le plan en
tout cas je le trouve harmonieux il a
fait c'est 5 donc il veut un truc
très bien enfin je veux dire mais avoir
passé le pion devant ce qu'il aime bien
faire
donc qu'elle est pour un 4 j'imagine
et cavaliers C6 et on se redirige
peut-être même vers des quatre et on
joue contre ce fou regarde ce pion c'est
5 son autre point positif c'est qu'il
bloque le pion le pion B et le pion d
oui oui
de la part de Ding donc est-ce qu'il
prend un 4 qui est ici sont faits B2 ou
on fait ces trois d'abord pour pas avoir
le cayon des 4 qui nous gêne et on
mettra le foncé de alors attendez est-ce
que je peux me permettre de jouer avec
Béa remettre le fond à de le réactiver
et rejouer avec fouger 5 avec des 5 bah
écoute peut-être enfin tellement logique
de prendre du cavalier mais si jamais
c'est pas probant et que les Noirs se
mettent en place c'est vrai que Béa pour
faire tout ça peut-être peut-être
finalement pourquoi pas avec l'idée de
jouer Béa non pas pour jouer pour sur ce
cavalier miser sur le cavalier et la
faiblesse sont à 6 mais remisez sur le X
à deux et la case des 5
les deux options sont sur la table en
réalité mais bon bah je sais pas s'il
fait H6 qui te laisse pas faire les
échanges que tu veux car elles font
aussi je pense que c'est dur d'avoir
l'avantage
mais on peut essayer enfin il y a rien
de trop mal il n'y a rien qui l'interdit
en tout cas pas bien cavalier prend je
trouve que c'est dans la logique de ce
qu'on veut obtenir
en tout cas quoi qu'il en soit on peut
dire que Yann fait la politique de la
chaise vive dans ce match il est pas là
il arrive mais alors il arrive pas non
je crois que c'est un arbitre ah si il
arrive enfin
il revient
la politique de la chaise pleine de
nouveau
et il joue qu'elle va aller prendre un 4
comme tu nous le suggéré Fabien et le
cavalier qui revient immédiatement en C6
pour dingyrène le cavalier qui était
hors-jeu en A5 qui était vulnérable et
qui revient vers le centre en C6 il a
laissé passer le pion c'est 5 il a fait
son boulot et il se replace sur sa case
de prédilection cette case C6 Yann qui
en fait de même en replaçant son
cavalier en C3 et on a vu sur la gauche
de votre écran petit mouvement de jauge
Fabien qui
descendre et une chose mécontente du
coup je voulais pas Ryan bon en fait il
va je vais fouger 5 j'imagine
connaissant la dynamique du match mais
ouais j'imagine plus le Callian en B2
perso parce que en C3 bon ok on veut des
5 mais ils gêne le pion C2 du coup
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ce fou bien
pas grand chose et alors est-ce que ce
serait pas Yann qui sera en train de
craquer Fabien dernière partie du match
un peu peut-être digne Irène qui a un
avantage qui a peut-être lui la balle de
match avec les Noirs en retour la balle
qui est peut-être giclée de la raquette
du joueur du joueur chinois Fabien et ce
fou Béa un petit peu
orphelin de case j'ai envie de dire
puisqu'il en a plus que deux
complètement bloqué le pion B3 qui est
pris par la 5 et c'est 5 le pion des
trois qui est pris par E5 et ce fou qui
n'a peut-être plus de cases cavalier des
deux attention attention Fabien le
cavalier qui qui se retrouve en D2 qui
va verser 4 mais est-ce que les pièces
sont pas en train de s'agglutiner là il
veut pas être F4 aussi mais oui il a
gluten enfin ça fait ça fait quand même
un gros pâté hein là j'ai envie de te
dire amène-moi une tartine une bonne
tartine de pain qu'on étale un petit peu
tout ça
bah c'est vrai que côté blanc tu serais
quand même plus content de monter d'une
case ton pion c'est deux donc
[Musique]
c'est bien
attention attention
cavalier des deux
il va revenir peut-être verser 4 vous
aussi 6 places et regarde s'il y a une
ouverture du centre avec avec des 5
Fabien toutes les pièces noires qui vont
s'activer c'est ça me fait penser à un
genre de ressort tu sais quand tu te
mets mal au dos tu arrives dessus bon
qui s'est mis en danger tout seul il
s'est mis le feu
c'est chaud
regarde-les un spectateur de l'échiquier
spectateur de cette finale de
championnats du monde de cette dernière
partie comme dirait certains gamers ils
sont peut-être de int je crois qu'il dit
ça intola game ils sont là mais ils sont
là mais ils sont plus trop là
ils sont enfermés
tu vois c'est ce qu'ils disent intola
game complètement
ils sont peut-être en train de coûter la
victoire à Yann qui pourra les engueuler
après c'est mate envers en B1 et un bon
la torrent
sur pattes quoi elle peut sauter un
cadre elle peut te bouffer à ça qu'un
jour mais bon le fout bien lui il fait
peine avoir quoi il fait peine à voir oh
là là mais on a même du mal si on avait
pas vu la partie à ça comment il s'est
retrouvé là à lui regarder il est venu
en C4 puis il est venu en a deux puis il
allait s'enterrer en B1 on lui a mis un
pion B3 devant la vue devant la visière
et des cinq regardez une qui accélère
oh mais Ding qui accélère qui a l'air de
bien jouer mais attention bah disons là
on a pas en train de perdre le pion à 5
là
au fout des deux Fabien s'ajoutent
tellement vite c'est tellement compliqué
je crois je crois qu'on rentre dans
l'irrationnels ici
la partie avec trop d'enjeux donc il y a
trop d'enjeux on rentre dans
l'irrationnel
[Musique]
qui doit lui l'attaquer trouver les bons
coups c'est le Pione amener la dame
j'en sais rien mais si tu commences à
bouffer à 5 que tu défends tu auras
besoin de plus tu auras ces cinq faibles
tu es un mauvais fou 7 donc tu as des
arguments à faire valoir avec les Blancs
donc à priori si je me réfère à la jauge
c'est noir sont mieux et de je le jeu
concret doit être bien mais en gros il y
a il tu vois il joue pour ça quoi
joue pour défendre et contre attaqué
mais ouais bon là les nerfs sont soumis
à rue des preuves et est-ce que tu la
sens là cette pression cette tension qui
est en train de qui est en train de
monter
oh là là le prix des coûts il prend ses
trois il faut prendre ces trois il prend
ses quatre i il veut complètement
[Musique]
passer et je sais pas idée ça me semble
plus naturel mais tu donnes la majorité
de l'autre côté
j'aurais pris deux
je vois que la jauge préfère prendre de
B mais j'aurais pas osé
voilà la position est complexe mais bon
mieux noir mais ils ont joué vite hein
[Musique]
il peut il peut plus il peut plus garder
ses nerfs maisding a du mal aussi parce
que regarde dans toutes les autres
parties là quand même toujours pris son
temps et là dans des positions d'une
complexité
inégalée inégalable il a il a envoyé les
coups à la vitesse de l'éclair et
regarder il est prêt à recliquer oh ils
peuvent plus ils en peuvent plus là ils
en peuvent plus les amis
non il a pas cliqué il a fait sa fin
de corps
c'est chaud je sais pas tout peut se
passer là cette partie ça peut encore
une fois faire nul bien sûr en plus mais
donc mieux noir quand même est moche
mais si tu arrives à ressortir bouffer
le pion à 5 ou quoi on verra faut des
vitres relativement logique défend le
pion on peut se remettre en C7 si un
jour tu fais le 4 tu regardes le roi
adverse donc tu défends tout c'est bien
joué c'est le coup normal mais les coups
sont durs à trouver je trouve avec les
blancs les noirs là oui c'est vrai que
tu fais pousser ça tu as du cahier des
cartes à F5 4 je pense que tu t'es le
prix de tes coups et beaucoup moins cher
que pour les blancs non mais comme
jeunes Ding c'est normal genre c'est pas
c'est à priori peut-être pas oh regarde
le Ding ouh là là il s'approche regarde
il s'est approchait là il prend il prend
possession de l'échiquier un fou de il
va où oh il les voit partir là les F5 il
les voit partir les E4 il voit le roi de
Yann il l'a dans le viseur là Ding
regarde le
oh c'est dans le viseur regarde les yeux
rivés sur le centre et sur cet endroit
on n'est pas alors emballer de sa
position physiquement tu sens que tu
suces
mais ça va il réussit quand même à
garder son sang-froid pour le moment
donc j'imagine qu'il veut ces trois
enfin
au moins ces trois poussées
pas mais au moins il regarde des choses
mais
quatre pour ces trois cavaliers B3 il
lui enlever ce fou peut-être
qui est venu des quatre je peux pas
prendre à 5
tu peux peut-être prendre à 5
j'avais pas vu Fabien
bon après si ça se trouve tu me fais un
quiz de pions tu échanges des fous de
cases noires tu remettes qui Allianz ou
je sais pas quoi et après j'ai peut-être
aussi des tourbé 6 tours tourisme poussé
cette C3 tempo Yann qui tient plus ses
nerf bon après il joue les coups qu'il
veut mais ouais là il est dans le mode
népot je clique tout tempo qu'on l'a
déjà vu des fois alors c'est pas méga
mon signe mais il a pas toujours perdu
en faisant ça genre la partie Euro 5
voilà en réalité j'ai envie de dire ils
jette une pièce c'est à dire on est de
nouveau comme on aime bien les les
comparaisons tennistiques il tape il
tape à plat il tape fort à plat si ça
rentre dans le cours c'est pleine lignes
et ça va faire le point si c'est dehors
c'est dehors
ça va jouer ça joue une finale de
championnat du monde
sur un Hokage
alors mais ça peut d'autant plus mettre
la pression à l'adversaire parce que si
tu es digne tu vois qui fait ça il faut
qu'il y a un truc qui marche ou qu'il y
a un truc qui marche c'est pas possible
et puis s'il y a rien tu vas te taper la
tête contre un mur mais là c'est plus du
tout en contrôle il y a plus de livres
de Fabien bref
Ding ça joue complètement normal Yann ça
clique si ça passe ça passe si ça casse
ça casse en fait on
sait plus Fabien non c'est pas trop donc
5 jouets mais qui voilà logique mille
fois logique ça permet d'avoir du E4 ça
permet de monter la tour de passer la
dame ça fait plein de choses ça peut
permettre même de jouer pour du F4 un
jour et de pas ok on s'enterre le fou
c'est 7 mais on enterre aussi le fou des
deux voire même peut-être après du F3
pour venir jouer les cases blanches
on peut aussi peut-être jouer pour dame
des 7 quoi que non ça j'allais dire en
plus des trois mais lui non il est
blindé au moins il faut bien il date ce
rôle là de défendre des trois alors
attention il peut rejaillir on sait
dehors à 4 non mais le rêve des blancs
c'est genre fou ces deux virer la dame
fou des trois quoi
et tu vas en dessin qui est ok bon mais
bien sûr tu auras pas 12 coups d'affilée
pour le faire mais si un moment tu
arrives à ça
c'est quelque chose quoi il y a plus de
favoris dans ce match de champion du
monde c'est du 50/50 on jette une pièce
la phase d'ouverture qui s'est bien
passée pour Ding
qui a réussi à se sortir de la
préparation de son adversaire avec une
position correcte plus que correcte mais
Yann n'a pas dit son dernier mot le fou
comme tu le disais il a un rêve d'aller
en dessin qui finalement il a quand même
cet avantage de la paire de fou cet
avantage structurel quand même avec ce
pion à 5 un petit peu fait pour le
moment le fou c'est sec ne réussit pas à
s'activer il est bloqué par les pions
jouer au 4 pour l'activer ça va être dur
ça réveille le fou B1 qui va pouvoir
rayonner sur ce pion les deux joueurs
ont quand même des arguments à faire
valoir et surtout et surtout un titre de
champion du monde à aller chercher au
bout de cette partie peut-être ou un peu
plus loin dans des départages en 5 + 3
en tout cas Ding semble être déterminé à
aller mettre la pression à Yann dans
cette partie
on risque de voir de belles passes
d'armes encore une fois Fabien
probablement probablement
non mais bon moi j'aime pas bien la
position avec les blancs mais je veux
dire ça va à peu près mais les Noirs ça
sent quand même que tu tu vas l'attaquer
loin
ce soit avec 4 et dame fou sur la grande
démonade ou même F4 qui est pas si mal
tu veux planter une épine en F3 c'est
les blancs font F3 même ça enlève tous
les plans avec le fou derrière et
compagnie et tu peux songer à qui a eu
cette cave 5 tu reviens par là plus des
G5 H5 G4 ok on y va quoi et ne pas
oublier que la tour peut venir via B6 G6
pour garder la tour sur la colonnette en
fait une fois qu'on joue F4 on peut
avoir tourbé 6 en G6 un jour tout F5
tourgers 5 on peut vraiment très très
vite ramener les deux tours sur le sur
le racadverses ça ça peut ça peut faire
ça peut faire mal ça peut faire
extrêmement mal Yann qui réussit à
reprendre le contrôle de ses émotions de
ces nerfs prendre le temps de réfléchir
dans une position où chaque coup peut
coûter un titre de champion du monde une
nouvelle défaite de laquelle il serait
difficile de se relever pour Yann qui
avait déjà perdu il y a deux ans contre
Magnus Carlsen dans un match EPIC
vraiment
parce que la partie qui lui hier il te
fait pas E5
et puis la douce fameuse 12e partie oui
oui il a acheté à la poubelle mais on va
dire que que même si tu avais fait nul à
la douche c'est pas ce qui se passait la
13 et 14 dans la 14 c'est la dernière tu
es gagnant et tu gagnes pas
après là aujourd'hui ce qui se passe
c'est qu'il joue bien et c'est bien
remis Ding joue bien tout le monde joue
bien c'est c'est cool malgré la fatigue
on pouvait plus penser qu'après les 7
heures de jeu hier les deux hommes
arriveraient exténuer 14 parties 7
heures de jeu hier et il n'en est rien
les deux hommes ont réussi peut-être
aussi grâce à l'adrénaline d'un titre de
champion du monde et la motivation qui
doit être qui ne peut pas être plus plus
grande à élever leur niveau de jeu
malgré les obstacles et les embûches et
la tour qui vient se placer en E1 en
face de la dame alors ça mon Fabien
s'appelle du dame G6 oui
tu te mets en face du roi
tu retouches tu retouches la case
ça c'est logique
après c'est probablement pas le seul
coup hein mais je veux dire bon je crois
pas que les Blancs menacent trop grand
chose
mais t'as pas envie de rester dans un
jeu
bon peut-être les mains même si tu les
laisses ils te feront comme des quatre
en fait j'en sais rien
à un moment alors on nous dit on nous
dit que peut-être dame D8 je peux
comprendre l'idée peut-être qu'on se dit
que la dame en G6 c'est en face du fou
il fait tourner 8
pourquoi pas enfin je veux dire ah ouais
peut-être il veut mettre la tour il veut
passer la tour peut-être il y a D6 c'est
garder ce cavalier en C6
c'est logique aussi comme quoi il se met
en face de la dame adverse non non mais
je pense qu'il y a plein de cookies
c'était bien votre dame D8 au chat bon
pourquoi pas tourner vite je vois rien
de mal hein on se met face au pire des
trois donc le fou Béa s'il part un
moment c2a4 moi ça laisse le pion des
trois pas défendu donc bon faudra
surveiller ça ça donne des idées de 4
clouages on fait nous aussi invisible
face à la dame j'en sais rien enfin ça
s'entend comme quoi c'est un coup là
encore logique
comment est-ce que Yann va réussir à
réactiver ce fou et cette tour alors
cette tour comme tu le disais elle est
un petit peu active elle touche le pion
A5 et elle peut aussi un jour revenir
via A2 et E2
un petit cheat c'est possible pour
l'avoir revivre et la tour en deux
aurait aussi le bénéfice de la défense
du pion F2 peut-être qu'un jour quand on
défend le roi ou si un jour on doit
faire un G3 prise prise une tourte et
qui viendrait courir ça pour revenir
devant le roi donc cette tour peu quand
même avoir son utilité très rapidement
dans la partie est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer aussi avec côté Yann un fouet 3
les toucher un peu spiancé 5 parce que
finalement ce serait qu'un coup d'épée
dans l'eau et qui serait défendu
simplement avec un un transfert de la
dame vers E3 et qu'on se mettrait dans
du F4
bon ça a peur d'être trop impressionnant
il faut trois mais après si on veut le
faire et qu'on se fait froid je vais me
blâme en F2 j'en sais rien moi pour
avoir des idées comme ça alors on nous
propose fougères
G6 j'ai l'impression que le fouger 5
appelle la tour
sur cette case G6
à moins qu'on est raté quelque chose
mais
300 là
du coup pour défendre
qui s'enlève de la huit verte peut-être
tu auras du F4 à ce moment-là ou des
trucs bizarres mais
c'est effectivement le premier coup de
l'ordinateur
c'est logique
c'est le coup logique par excellence on
se place sur cette deuxième rangée
ou je sais pas quel coup comme ça et
passer la tour bon oui enfin c'est pas
glorieux pour les blancs mais écoute
pour l'instant il met les barbeuls il y
a rien de faire
il faut défendre pour Yann
mais oui la position de ne pas envie les
battements de cœur doivent être assez
conséquent pour les deux hommes ça
m'étonnerait qu'on soit dans les 90 à 80
90 battements minute côté Diane et digne
s'approcher des 140 150 à mon avis
ouais et puis plus la pendule va
descendre plus ça peut taper plus
après ça dépend des joueurs je sais pas
genre je sais que saut il est connu pour
pour taper fort
avec cet enjeu pas facile la dame qui
vient en manger 6 un coup qu'on
attendait depuis un moment logique mon
enlève la toux la dame d'un vis-à-vis on
en met un autre alors on se met dans le
vis-à-vis du Fou B1 mais bon sur des
quatre façons au pire on aura le 4 au
pire c'est un vis-à-vis vite fait on va
dire mais il faut toujours les regarder
vérifier quand même toujours quand vous
avez des pièces sort de le garder en
tête c'est important
ah bah disons ouais ouais les pièces
longues portées faut les surveiller quoi
dame 2 donc il se décale lui aussi la
question qu'on peut se poser c'est ce
qu'il est venu en G6 pour l'instant j'ai
6 ou est-ce qu'il est venu pour revenir
vers D6 pour faire pour créer une
batterie et éventuellement jouer du E4
et du damage 2 échec et mat
ouais ouais ça peut ça peut devenir
indécis à tout moment
pas de mauvaise idée
c'est dur avec les Blancs on manque
d'espace on manque de perspective et on
voit arriver plein de choses chez nous
alors au moins les pauses mais pas
tromper la salle à la pendule
non ça c'est une bonne chose mais ouais
bon donne des six ça laisse des menaces
latentes une épée de Damoclès au-dessus
de la tête
c'est cool logique puis finalement cette
case G6 elle est plus pour une tour je
trouve que pour la dame ce qui ferait la
même chose une tour une dame en G6 ça
fera à peu près la même chose alors que
la dame elle peut se balader en D6 voire
même en C6 elle peut venir attaquer en
diagonale sur ce roi
mais bon tout ça est long transférer
transférer la tour jusqu'en G6 n'est pas
chose aisée
ce qui calcule peut-être même des E4
puis on prend et Dame des 6 tu vois ça
tourne à deux qui défend le fou elle est
vraiment importante
déterminante alors que pendant qu'on
analysait la position yann est parti il
a décidé de quitter
son adversaire pour quelques secondes ou
quelques minutes
on voit un pour moi Ding sur sa gestion
là de de
ces départages de ce time break il a
plus l'attitude du vainqueur
bon la E4 c'est une vraie menace
c'est un vrai truc
donc fois j'ai en conséquence et a
priori tu dois en faire G3 donc soit en
prévention soit attendre 4 pour le faire
mais bon
ça a pas l'air d'être ça
il revient plus de 14 minutes pour Yann
il faudra pas regretter ses
allers-retours intempestifs j'ai trop
joué
ça tient pour le moment
ça tient mais bon c'est fragile
maintenant on fait des trous sur les
cases blanches le fruit des loin de
Lettonie
est loin d'y arriver dessus
que toi tu aimes bien c'est faire 4 puis
on prend F4 bon là pas là mais tu te
donnes la caisse de 5 et il y a des
idées pour les Noirs c'est ça rode c'est
hyper dur pour les blancs quoi peut-être
qu'on peut commencer par un tour de 8
mais en fait j'ai l'impression que tu
peux vraiment faire ce que tu veux
et qui est blanc c'est dur de trouver
avec les Blancs juste tu résistes tu
résistes tu veux pas perdre le champ et
tu rends la tâche difficile mais tu as
pas d'idées quoi
pour le moment oui mais c'est
[Musique]
meilleur quoi peut-être qu'un jour j'ai
un des quatre qui passera qui sait
peut-être un F4 même
pas envie mais on H2 on pousse qui sait
vraiment qu'on s'affaiblit quoi qu'on
fasse mais avec les Blancs faut arriver
à pas toucher rester
formation carapace et on prie quoi tu
vois le coup
regarde là
je sais pas de quoi sérieux
je préfère Yann alors que je vois pas
dans quel monde y aller mieux mais tu
vois petite
erreur mais alors
non mais ok je vois le cookie c'est de
la F3 j'imagine qu'il veut Dame des cinq
idées
bon après dans F3 est-ce que je peux au
pire je me rends compte du truc je
reviens vite
il va te faire fouger 5 après il va
commencer à t'enchaîner
il va ramené peut-être la tour je sais
pas peut-être que tout d'un coup ça
change quelques trucs non mais en gros
c'est
clairement mieux et peut-être une série
de coups précis il se trouve qu'il y a
un truc mais c'est tellement terrible à
jouer pour les blancs ça
mais oui une peau il doit être à l'affût
de son truc
et puis on sait jamais parce qu'on a dit
la tension est tellement grande un coup
ça vaut tellement cher que il est connu
pour être assez aussi stressé
il peut ne pas jouer de manière
parfaitement non plus comme sur ta FF3
peut-être là on peut jouer le cap si on
prend cavalier E5 F4 enfin ce sera
calculé
qui est peut-être en train de retourner
la table
Yann qui est peut-être en train de
retourner la table de manière
complètement inattendue et regardez
cette tour en a deux hein l'air de rien
ce petit coup tout à l'heure qui change
tout
on défend le fou des deux cette deuxième
rangée
bravo pour donner trois quatre qui part
bon bah écoute là c'est c'est
ouais il va y avoir un chaos à l'issue
de cette séquence
est-ce que les deux hommes seront à
terre c'est comme dans les matchs de
catch quoi
et l'arbitre qui devra remettre quelques
parties où est-ce que le compte de 3
va tomber pour l'un ou l'autre en tout
cas Yann qui paraît beaucoup plus
confiant je sais pas si j'ai confiance
mais en tout cas Ding ce qui fait c'est
logique
si on en croit la jauge c'est pas ouf
mais mille fois logique il a mis toutes
ces pièces bien pour que ça marche ah ce
serait cruel si digne perdez là-dessus
mais ce qui perd peut-être sur les coups
les plus logiques qui existent non mais
le seul défaut évidemment c'est qu'il
redonne vie aux pièces blanches
maintenant qu'il y a plus le pion des
trois bah le fout bien qui faisait trop
rien bon je vois un peu plus loin et on
va voir à deux ça c'est bien elle
revient sur 4 la tour en E2 en deux deux
coups de cuillère à pot toutes les
pièces blanches peuvent être remises sur
pattes
la pression qui s'est inversé en
l'espace de 30 secondes une minute de
manière complètement inattendue ce dame
F3 très bien joué reste le temps de 8
erreur mais qui semble qui était le
premier ministre
mais il a laissé une porte en trouves
ouverte avec des F3 dame dessin qui il a
sauté dessus il a tandis de faire le 4
pour fermer les diagonale tu donnes la
case de 5 pour le cavalier mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a eu 5 finalement est-ce
que tu t'attaque la dame tu visais F3 tu
vises des trois tu vis C4 peut-être
partout ouais mais quand tu prends ces
cas tu auras peut-être un jour un fou
ton cavalier peut-être pas si bien bon
en tout cas nous on a la jauge un
visuellement tu tu as l'impression de de
faire l'écart de faire la différence
mais c'est surtout ce fou B1 qui peut
faire la différence maintenant lui qui
était complètement endormi il y a encore
7 8 coups de ça on voyait pas comment il
pouvait se réveiller et finalement c'est
c'est Ding
s'il l'a réveillé tout seul il lui a
redonné vie à se foube1 qui est
maintenant en pleine forme hybride mille
feux sur la diagonale et comme tu le
disais le pion C4 vulnérable mais ça
refera briller le le fou de l'autre côté
qui passe du plot à la meilleure pièce
de l'échiquier peut-être côté blanc et
se fout des deux qui peut jaillir sur F4
et toucher la dame et tout d'un coup
c'est les pièces noires qui se posent
des questions ce cavalier c'est 6 sous
la pression de la dame ce fouet 4 qui
met la pression à l'autre dame se fout
bien qui tape le roi cette tour à deux
qui jaillit en eux deux c'est toutes les
pièces blanches pas bien qui rayonnent
on va voir ce que ce que Ding a nous
proposer en plus ce cap qui on prend
jouer rapidement et maintenant digne qui
tank il s'est peut-être rendu compte que
c'était pas le coup optimal
cette position Fabien qui rentrera
peut-être dans tous les livres d'échec
si l'un des deux joueurs en sort
vainqueur
le combat est à son comble le plus que 9
minutes 20 pour Ding attention on va
dire que niveau je trouve qu'il a pas
mal de réussite qu'en fait ce soit pas
grave ah il est il a une réussite sa
position oh ça méritait ça méritait de
de passer au travers il a un petit peu
boisé mais ça tombe dans le cours avec
beaucoup d'effets
allez bon écoute on va voir de toute
façon tout peut se passer bon bah là
tout peut arriver
comme on dit Fab
qui a lieu 5 c'était le coup normal
j'ai rangé deux parce que je me sens
dans ton cocon
en jet de proche du roi dans le fiancé
plus vulnérables en G2 bon tu es là je
pense que je vais ranger deux il y est
parti aussi
et à t'es pas si mal placé cavalier
prend ses quatre peut-être
mais F4 qui arrive et tout d'un coup ça
se retourne ah c'est incroyable tout
d'un coup les pièces blanches
rejaillissent sur l'échiquier mais bon
c'est compliqué je sais pas où c'est si
[Musique]
qui arrive il y a le fou à deux qui
arrive si on prend ce pion C4
d'un bout je vais te prendre c'est ça
doubler les tours en E2
pour pouvoir propulser le Pione prendre
un F5 et en même temps à Fouad peut-être
tristement faire cavalier D3 mais bon
c'est tellement horrible d'avoir investi
un pion pour échanger la pire pièce des
blancs
et le roi qui peut se retrouver faible
finalement un jour avec cette dame qui
peut jaillir sur des cinq
écoute tout ça ça peut expliquer le coup
de la turbine qui aura chute
l'action totale et tu dis mais j'aurais
dû faire il y a du coup quand il se
passait rien et que j'étais tranquille
mais après tu peux t'en rendre compte
parce que c'était content qui est pas
fois deux qui te défonce qui est pas
d'âme des cinq et franchement c'est pas
le premier coup qu'elle tu penses ça me
paraît quasiment impossible à jouer Roy
Schwitz mais j'ai envie de dire
peut-être qu'il y a allez on va dire 70%
de chance là pour Yann pour le titre pas
que pour cette partie mais pour le titre
et peut-être 70-30 maintenant je donne
bien 50% de victoire au blanc maintenant
la seule chose mais oui oui c'est
bizarrement quoi l'enchaînement cool la
souris là c'est la à la réussite est à
son comble
il boit un petit peu d'eau Yann
mais bon faut dire qu'il est arrivé à
faire ce qu'il avait eu du mal souvent
c'est que là en fait il a accepté de
défendre il a pas fait des quatre allez
je retourne je sais pas quoi tu vois
enfin l'équivalent du F5 l'autre jour
c'est il s'est mis ok je défends
ce qui comptait faire dans la partie 13
d'ailleurs en fait
quand il a décidé de
la défendre je défends il a pu le faire
longtemps mais il l'a bien fait et là
une nouvelle fois il y arrive
à la digne qui est en train de se taper
la tête contre un mur en réalité un mur
solide lui ne le sait pas il n'a pas la
jauge il n'a pas l'évaluation donc il ne
sait pas qu'il n'a pas de manière de de
mettre à mal l'adversaire et donc il
cherche il cherche il cherche mais il
est en train de se taper la tête contre
un mur tout simplement perdre du temps
et rien ne marche il va falloir être
très très fort pour dingyrène pour pour
s'en sortir de cette partie parce qu'en
fait tu serais quasi à deux doigts de
pouvoir faire F4 faut prendre tout
reprendre puis on prend que les 6 mais
le 5 on va dire qu'il te fait mal
on va montrer à Fabien
parce qu'en fait s'il y a pas E5 mais
bon c'est avec des si on fait ce qu'on
veut mais tu as le temps de prendre F4
avec ce beau cavalier et tous les cases
noires tu as la tour qui revient sur la
colonne j'ai dame fou qui tape c'est
c'est cool mais tu as pas tu as pas mais
en fait il doit chercher ce genre de
scénario je sais pas tu vois ce que je
veux dire tu te dis attends mais quand
même j'ai dame poignée j'ai mes deux
tours centrale j'ai tout quoi enfin je
peux pas mettre mieux mes pièces quoi là
où il boit le calice jusqu'à la liste et
qu'il a cette tour à deux qui défend et
ce fou bien qui défend aussi ses deux
pièces sont très éloignés du roi donc on
t'a pas l'impression qu'elle touche cet
aile roi mais ces deux pièces sont des
défenseurs primordiaux des des blancs et
on les on les voit pas on a l'impression
qu'on a un énorme surnombre à la loi
mais on a ces deux pièces qui ne
servaient à rien depuis le début de la
partie qui sont là quelque part
défendent et il joue cavalier des trois
et alors là j'ai envie de mettre je sais
pas si je peux mais de mettre un point
d'exclamation à ce coup alors on peut
pas le faire sur sur le live mais
accepter de jouer cavalier des trois
intellectuellement c'est fort est-ce
qu'il accepte son erreur il qui s'est
trompé et il décide maintenant de
changer son fusil d'épaule et de jouer
pour la partie nulle c'est bien c'est de
l'humidité dans voilà de se rendre
compte
ok je me suis trompé mais je vais pas
continuer à faire fausse route et
j'essaie de moi dans le droit chemin et
de tenir donc bah là le truc c'est que à
minimal est blanc peut faire [__] des
trois dames prenez trois gardiens de
plus après EF
et voilà mais bon tu as des arguments tu
as ton pion à passer le plus
voilà bon qui est avec les pions doubler
c'est le four en E1 si on échange les
tours à la fin il sera pas génial mais
les blancs sont bien et il faudra
regarder les dames des cinq qui passent
etc en tout cas c'est c'était un coup
très difficile à jouer psychologiquement
et c'est le coup qu'il a qu'il a réussi
à à trouver donc évidemment ça va
échanger en Détroit
tu vas apprendre le pion F5 on s'y
attend aussi un truc parce que
il défend tout donc EF tour E1 prise 1
Dumbledore il y aura du dame F1 ou quoi
Dame des cinq je pense c'est peut-être
ok donc il élimine ce pion il attaque la
tour à deux
alors c'est chaud matériellement
les Noirs 5 pour les blancs un pion de
plus moi ce qui m'inquiète un tout petit
peu pour Ding c'est ce roi ouvert on
sait quand il reste que des pièces
lourdes bon là il y a encore les fous
mais quand il reste des pièces lourdes
la sécurité du roi est primordial mais
d'un autre côté il y a ce pion à 5 il
fait peur
du coup qu'après toi on peut récupérer
parce que dans ma vie ton cours c'est
pas grave
ça va enfin
en fait je vois que il se met en
position je défends il dit fou je tiens
F2 je vais faire
ton pion à d'avancer je vais faire
damaka tour à catch je sais pas quoi
mais alors attention de pas Fabien se
prendre sur dame ceci c'est un fou pran
G3 pas piqué des hannetons
c'est pas piqué
bon je peux pas le prendre enfin je peux
pas le prendre je sais pas
[Musique]
attention vous avez peut-être on peut le
prendre mais c'est pas piqué des
hannetons quoi attention hanneton Fabien
ils sont chiants ils piquent hein
mais attention quand même que ce fouet
il protège F2 oui mais il protège pas
j'ai trois
donc ça peut être une arme
en dernier recours pour Ding
ouais donc c'est 6 c'est quand même le
foot après faut regarder ranger trois si
tu te fais défoncer ou pas mais mesdames
C6 j'imagine qu'il a fait sa conception
pour ça
j'imagine mais il faut bien juger non
parce que toute façon
tu peux pas attendre comme ça il y a le
Piona qui va pouvoir mettre la marche
avant tu as H5 H4 il peut te défoncer
quand même ton rock donc tu dois faire
un coup actif à un moment tu vas devoir
ouais tu en as l'obligation
alors dit il fout des deux
oui bon enfin je sais pas trop on sait
pas là les amis c'est trop compliqué
je peux pas juger l'ordi mais bon faut
des deux je sais pas trop ce que
j'accompli
en fait c'est ça le problème mais
peut-être que tu t'en fiches
quand même ah moi non mais genre
j'imagine j'imagine moi je le ferai pas
non mais Jordan quoi normal naturel
après bon si il faut ranger trop nos
cartons ok on peut pas mais
mais oui
de l'ordi après mais
[Musique]
peut-être qu'il veut
c'est bien joué sur un coup comme dame
de quoi il va se planter en E3 et que
voilà peut-être qu'il veut dame Cécile
maintenant que tous les deux c'est une
préparation Adam C6 donc H6 jouer ça
permet d'avoir roi H7 ça c'est logique
et il tient un peu les cases noires va
être important H5 c'est aussi une option
mais le truc c'est comme il a moins de
pions devant son roi H5 H4
un peu dangereux dans les C15 donc il
préfère garder son du haut de pion et
aussi H5 H4 c'est un plan qui lui a
coûté cher dans la française donc
peut-être qu'il a il a pas envie de le
réitérer dams et si tu m'attends à tout
F7 personnellement permet d'un peu tout
tenir c'est faire un genre de
Triangle des Bermudes qui tient tout que
tout le monde se tienne pendant
barbichette
moi je tiendrai les barbichettes je
ferai je ferai tout F7 je tiens je te
tiens tu me tiens par la barbichette le
premier de nous deux qui craquera
décident de se tenir par la barbichette
ah mais je crois que c'est le quatrième
département
[Musique]
après 8 heures de jeu à barbichette qui
décide tout
4 minutes pour Ding attention il y a 10
secondes de rajout bon il y a des coups
il a donc toi peut-être comme une
mentionne sûrement Dame des cinq qui
veut solidifier changer cette dame qui
vient rôde et Dame des trois peut-être
qui attaque le fou des deux qui défend
la Tour Eiffel qui reste
voilà tu prends ces 7 je prends des deux
bon c'est bizarre mais j'ai l'impression
que ça va parce que même si vite j'ai
tortuillite et mais bon bizarre
solide mais bon tu penses ça tu prends
des deux il faut regarder ce qui se
passe là dessus
[Musique]
ça peut mal se passerai pas là-dedans
après qu'on nous propose peut-être alors
on libère tu reprends à 5 on se dit
est-ce que je suis pas par là-haut mais
ça ne rebiberait de l'autre côté ok il
faut l'avoir si on a on a jolie mais en
fait chaque fois c'est tactique je suis
inquiet pour digne et toi F7 alors c'est
quoi ouais
c'est le coup qui semble blindé et tu te
mets en place et tu as pas besoin de te
tuer tous les trucs compliqués
mais attention la tour qui peut revenir
vers eux aller vers eux 8
mais c'est de te faire acheter 5 et dame
tu vois essayer de te mets mon autre
côté ça libère le pion à c'est loin
d'être nul cette partie c'est
l'évaluation c'est 0 0 mais attention ça
peut craquer d'un côté comme de l'autre
totalement
et alors là la pendule peut avoir son
importance
et oui donc il peut essayer de presser
cette position
ça semble quelque part plus dangereux
pour Ding mais il a le pion en toile de
fond
c'est difficile de juger là qui est qui
est le plus en plus en danger entre Ding
et Yann évidemment je suis plutôt
d'accord avec toi mais
ça peut tourner en
un clignement d'oeil deux coups de
cuillère à pot puis à la pression puis
il y a tout l'extra l'extra échiquier
l'extra échec je sais pas comment
appeler ça il peut jouer mais
effectivement c'est les pièces de Yann
qui commence à se retrouver proche du
roi la tour la dame C6 le fou des deux
qui participe aussi à lattes ils sont
tous là d'un autre côté il y a le fou
projet 3 dame F1 qui peut roder cette
dame C4 qui est quand même mettre un de
l'échiquier elle défend la case F7 elle
défend la case 4 elle protège des cases
importantes du dispositif défensif noir
et touche la case F1 dans le camp
adverse et elle protège cette case à 4
pour faire à 3 2 il y a deux en plus
donc on a une dame qui qui est quasiment
parfaite qui peut être déstabilisé par
tous vos cartes mais elle viendra en
Détroit d'où elle recontrôler les cases
sur lesquelles les blancs pourraient
mettre à mal d'ingly Rennes donc on a
une dame très puissante et ici on
pourrait décider avec les blancs de s'en
débarrasser simplement par dame 4
hypothèque les chandeliers mais ça peut
être une décision ça peut être une
détour 4
[Musique]
Dame des trois fois pour tout défendre
on se réexpose à foutranger tranquille
ah oui mais le fou prends G3 est
déterminant dans la défense de 10000
dirham c'est hyper important en fait et
du coup c'est vraiment un triangle des
Bermudes
ultra important puisqu'il est défensif
et offensif là c'est même c'est à deux
doigts que ça marche bien
c'est qui défend à 5 les Noirs ont une
une harmonie ouais dans la position
étonnante
mais qui fonctionne très bien
il faudrait peut-être amener ce pion
jusqu'en H5 pour réussir à déstabiliser
la défense et ce s'octroyer la case à F6
mais les Noirs ne vont pas regarder ça
en en croupion non il pourrait faire
Dame des trois un moment où elle est en
GK justement
qui est concentré
ici mais il sait aussi que ça peut se
retourner contre lui ah bah oui bah il y
a le pion en fait c'est ça le gros
danger et tu le laisses trop avancer il
pose problème quoi ok oui ok oui pose
problème ce Piona à 4 coups de la
victoire le pion a finalement à quatre
coups d'un titre de champion du monde
c'est comme si tu as un petit sbire qui
vient faire la différence Fabien à un
moment donné il va jusqu'à dames dans le
camp et demi serait éliminé par personne
y faire attention et surtout réussissent
on nous propose j'imagine c'est toujours
le fou projet 3 attention cette case F1
est sensible
il faut être méfiant
c'est foutrant j'ai trois
et peut-être même on me dit des tours F2
qui un jour peuvent arriver on sait pas
dans certaines ventes avec une dame en
D3 faut se méfier ouais les blancs
paraissent très solides mais en réalité
il peut y avoir des sacrifices qui va
jouer il joue fou E3
alors c'est bien joué il faut 3 c'est
pas un coup qu'on avait mais c'est un
coup ultra logique en fait il veut juste
gagner un pion et sur Dom français 3
peut-être qu'il veut réussir à venir
vers le cadre finalement et regagner les
cases moi j'ai 8 et il est déstabilise
les Noirs récupère le pion c'est 5 et
bon peut-être dame 5 et ouais si je
change les dames
ouais c'est toujours pensé 5 quand même
j'espère
[Musique]
5 il veut prendre ces trois sur ful
prend h6 il veut fous prends ces trois
aussi l'avantage c'est qu'il a un rebond
il rebondit sur sur la tour
ma mamie c'est chaud qu'est-ce que c'est
compliqué quel spectacle nous offre ces
deux hommes
extraordinaire Fabien
le niveau de jeu qui nous est proposé
aujourd'hui et puis là ça craque pas
c'est à dire que la partie elle est pas
bien joué l'ouverture il a raté un truc
mais après digne bien jouer n'est pas
c'est ressaisi et c'est chaud
il nous offre un spectacle réellement
digne d'une finale de championnat du
monde dame 8 il revient fou français 3
et ce qui voudrait pas tourser un
essayez de surcharger
ils se rendent coup pour coup Yann qui
est totalement dans son élément oui sur
fouet fils il a peut-être fou français 5
attention
oh il est dur à jouer Yann dans ses
positions
faut le travailler au corps
Ding qui suit un petit peu
disons dans les petites tactiques comme
ça il est dans son élément il peut te
planter un truc de derrière les fagots
comme le B6 dans la première ou de faire
des choses
surcharge donc il faut bouger cette tour
Eiffel mais il va y avoir fout il va y
avoir foodé de derrière
[Musique]
le courage de Ding il y a peut-être du
Damien ah mais dames il y aura fou
prends deux des deux tours français 4 il
faut prendre un
il faut les avoir bien accroché là côté
Ding il se met dans des clouages mais il
a calculé Yann qui part pour le chaos
mais il faut faire attention maintenant
c'est peut-être lui qui a plus la garde
ne pas se prendre un contre les deux
hommes qui se rendent coup pour coup
dans une partie qui vaut cher une partie
en or une partie pour un titre de
champion du monde Fabien ouais
magnifique non mais c'est bien c'est
beau mais c'est Ding comme on a dit il a
pas peur en fait si calcule qui voit que
ça va
quelle passe d'armes
je suis là je suis là quoi
ici
mesdames et messieurs on le trouve
le niveau de jeu il avait dans des 7
Fabien il a tout ces deux hommes ont
tous les coups bravo oh il y a plus un
coup à côté
extraordinaire une nouvelle fois il
avait Dame des 7 et il a dame 2 pour ton
français 3 dame 1 et dame prend ces
trois il veut sûrement fou des quatre et
il veut fout des quatre j'ai changé ton
fou toi qui va t'attaquer F2 et enfin il
veut peut-être même fou hein Fabien
pourquoi pas être plus gourmand et aller
gagner cette partie en prenant F2
maintenant c'est Yann qui doit resserrer
le jeu qu'elle passe d'armes quel passe
d'armes Fabien
qui a pas sourcier hein oh le fou
français
et il est concentré et c'est Yann qui
regrette peut-être d'en avoir fait un
peu trop dans cette partie
quelle défense mesdames et messieurs
on est bien soudain de magnifiques donc
tu as fout des quatre qui est tourgé ici
ce qui peut rôder avec des tours congés
3 et dame prend les trois tu as des
petites idées par-ci par là quoi état du
fouet 5 aussi ranger trois tu as du fou
hein pour passer par derrière et regarde
ce Piona
regarde-le regarde-le qui part là tout
seul sur la dame comme un grand comme un
grand vas-y mon petit
il est encore loin de l'arrivée mais il
peut faire l'effort avec le soutenu par
le fou F6 si commence à partir lui tu le
revois plus attention
il y a une qui a plus de 4-15 le temps
le temps le temps file bien joué il
centralise défend un peu tout
attaque c'est 5 c'est un peu très très
bon coup et surtout il veut quoi il veut
dame G2 revenir ouais
si tu peux vouloir
C2 très bien joué alors de la part de
Yann ce Dame des cinq centralisation
reviens en défense viens en attaque
aussi
encore un coup difficile pour Ding là
tous les coups sont chers tous les coups
sont durs
lequel va craquer le premier on peut
avoir un peu vivre un chaos dans cette
partie
fabiennes
les deux méritent le titre
sur ce match
Yann qui a quand même l'air d'être
heureux de son Dame des cinq digne qui
se remet mal au temps en plus qu'une
trente est-ce que ça pourrait jouer
finalement autant Fabien pressé par le
temps est-ce que Ding va craquer on va
voir c'est vrai que en partie lentement
il a eu le problème il fait 4 il tient
tout pour l'instant
B4 ça tient tout est-ce qu'il y a un
petit coup droit G2 pour consolider sans
lever des faits que la première rangée
quand il enlève sa tour pour garder la
position mais tu peux la perdre parce
qu'après tu te prends à 4 attention le
pion ce que fait de bien par rapport à
ces trois bon déjà il est ancré mais il
y a plus d'un meca très échec et d'un
point 4 ou quoi enfin c'est là à 4 à 3
c'est tu peux l'envoyer donc
cette partie va pas juste se finir par
dame 4 3 G8 Dame des cinq rois 7
peut-être et en plus ce fou ce qu'il a
de bien c'est qu'on il contrôle la
colonne B1 la tour a du mal à rentrer et
si on joue autour des 1 bon je sais pas
c'est une option mais de toi
qui bouge que les coller la défense de
la tour il contrôle le 1 il bloque la
colonne B il bloque la colonne C avec le
pion il ploque la Colonna et il contrôle
en quelque sorte la colonne D est-ce que
ce serait pas l'heure de jouer fou
français 5
mais ok peut-être enfin c'est juste
normal c'est une bonne partie un moment
mais c'est comme ça
est-ce que Yann va tenter le chaos dans
celle-là ou se dire qu'il est favori
quand même en blitz tous les
observateurs disent que ce serait plus
sac à dense le truc c'est que en fait en
même temps objectivement la position si
tu as pas mieux tu as pas mieux
est-ce que digne peut tenter sur dame je
pense pas il peut pas se flouer comme ça
et sur H4 il faut avoir une idée
bizarrement et mais bon
c'est de reprendre trois et mais bon
j'aime pas me mettre dans un clouage
mais sur arcade je suis MG4 peut-être je
pense pas qu'il le fasse en tout cas il
a bien fait de jouer une répétition vite
parce que si qu'on jouait de tourner 6
en attendant il aura laissé des secondes
s'égrainer pour pour Yann et lui il aura
récupéré un peu de temps donc c'est bien
joué
à mon avis il y a là il va décider de
répéter parce que c'est ça peut ça peut
ça peut devenir dangereux pour lui et
comme on le disait il est censé être un
légèrement meilleur buteur que Ding donc
il a peut-être plutôt envie d'aller
chercher deux parties en 5 + 3
et ne pas s'embêter sur
bien aimé gagner celle là mais sur ce
coup de dés alors dame 4 est-ce que Ding
va envisager ton G6
ce serait quand même à mon avis un peu
trop
ce serait trop c'est se mettre dans des
problèmes pour rien toi aussi
ça se trouve ça va mais bon
tu te bloques quand même
je déteste en fait ce que tu n'as pas de
déclouage facile après non
il réfléchis quand même un long moment
si le fait c'est un fou furieux
alors là
Fabien
j'aurais jamais imaginé
à ce stade de la compétition joue un
coup aussi risqué
c'est deux malades qui se rencontrent là
d'un F5 donc il va s'acheter H5 avec les
Blancs et ça se finir avec un méga
zeight note
Ding il a décidé d'en découdre il
découvre
H4 en même temps les Noirs ont H5 de
leur côté pour l'instant
qui te permet de
pion il envoie le pion Fabien il y va
de coup de la corde à linge
il y a une qui a plus qu'une minute 20
regarde-le ici c'est trop dur à trouver
je crois ah ça va être très très
difficile
riding qui mérite là sur ces départages
ce qui vient de faire mesdames et
messieurs c'est un grand monsieur des
échecs d'inglyrène
le courage du joueur chinois H4
biennes à quelques encablures d'un titre
de champion du monde mesdames et
messieurs et qui sera les chercher s'il
va la gagner il se sera envoyé digne
hein il y a du Tour projet
3 Dink est peut-être en train de le
faire et il saura aller se le chercher
hein tout seul comme un grand
ça tient encore mais peut-être
le coup numéro 1 de l'ordi je l'avais
avant la jauge
tour D1 salle school tout F6 allez il
enlève cette dame pourquoi pas Madame G4
attaque C4 bien joué dame G4 Yann qui
résiste quand même qui trouve les coups
il tape le pion le pion qui va pour
devoir aller en C3 probablement il va
essayer de faire H5 et créer un réseau
de perpète
ces trois tours D1 Yann qui se replace
5 par là-bas mais attention pour le
moment le fou qui tient tout MG6 solide
sur mon domicile ou quoi probablement du
dame C4 qui va partir
qui fait mal
ce qui peut faire d'autre échanger les
dames ça paraît ça paraît compliqué
madame dos sinon triste triste résignée
mais bon mais il faut tenir un peu là il
faut mettre des barbels pour rien parce
que ça peut craquer en face il y a il y
a un titre il y a un titre au bout il y
aura plus rien à Sonia rationnel dans
cette fin de partie il faut qu'il donne
tout il y a maintenant pour essayer de
s'en sortir tout donner tout donner pour
y arriver
à apprendre ces deux parties de
départage en blitz
d'un projet 6 ça c'est impossible bah il
ramène le roi et c'est bien de plus
c'est terrible tu peux pas imaginer
mais il va vouloir essayer de jouer avec
tour D8 Fabien ces deux c'est deux tours
C1 tour des 8 mais cette C2 il veut
tourner tout court il te laisse faire C1
il donne le fou il se cache j'ai mal dit
la variante puis il s'en fout quoi enfin
il s'en fout il est foutu mais il tente
quoi et alors il va et je crois qu'il y
a une dame c'est 6 qui revient et
surtout Rachi 3 rois G6 tu auras plus
d'échec et ça menacera maintenant H1
c'est de tourner 8 C1 échec vous prend
c'est un tour prend c'est un roi
et alors là je crois faut la prendre
cette tour et c'est tenir tin qui a pas
eu le courage de rentrer dans cette
variante bah elle fait peur il semblait
gagner parce qu'il y avait peut-être des
H5 échecs encore je crois qu'il faut
prendre si tu t'en vas y assez de
tourner un qui va t'arriver en force
dessus trop dangereux et si tu prends
tes pas contente tu as plus de tout mais
bon c'est peut-être la meilleure chance
c'est pris avec du dame
psychiatre il faut défendre était là
était là et tu es encore là tu es encore
là parce que le roi est un peu faible
j'espère un fou des cadres de mc7 hein
peut-être un H5 qui passera et qui fera
un truc cool c'est pas gagné encore pour
dinguil a raté un chaos en premier chaos
il y a une qui a réussi à esquiver c'est
déjà fait compter dans cette partie
mais il résiste pour le moment ils ont
moins d'une minute ah il donne tout les
deux hommes donnent tout la jauge qui
s'affole beaucoup moins mais bon ça va
être difficile à défendre parce que la
dame bien échec
pour utiliser chaque mais bon et alors
là c'est incroyable parce que à trois
pas l'air de gagner alors que
visuellement moi j'aurais pensé que
c'était fini tu as la dame qui protège
là et tu vas faire à 3 à 2 à 1 mais
regarde là je tiens
à 4
mais ça doit être fou des quatre et dame
F7 en fait
et ça doit tenir pour un rien fout des
cas doit tenir pour un rien pour Yann
incroyable la défense qui nous a sorti
il faut l'avoir mais en même temps quoi
d'autre tu veux qu'on t'attaquer
j'essaie pas sortir
encore des coups
on revient défendre
fous des quatre et Jouets
à 3 domestique j'imagine ou quoi
H5
mais alors attends dame G6 maintenant il
veut prendre ces trois
après tu fais à deux dames B1 et Aya ah
il a raté le H5 il permettait de
d'exciser les noirs de la case G6
ça vient d'apprendre H5 sur échec
4 il tient ce qu'il peut mais il est pas
revenu avec Dan B1 ça aurait pu répéter
mais il a vu qu'il y avait qui avait H5
le fou qui tient encore mais tiens ce
qui peut c'est dur foutez bien amélioré
qui a bien poussé ses pions le roi qui
revient en jet d'eau il est pas bien
placé se ranger deux en plus et
peut-être le fou qui va arriver en E5 et
se planter en B2
alors attention fou au sein qui doit y
avoir un petit peu
très bien joué à 5 G4 Fabien il faut
peut-être faire H5 soi-même alors mais
c'est dur profil
Yann qui défend encore
quelle partie Fabien dans les émotions
et dans le niveau de jeu il y a tout
dans cette partie et il y a surtout un
titre de champion du monde au bout
digne qui va peut-être commencer à
paniquer il le voit il est là il est à
ça de l'attraper le titre de champion du
monde mais il faut encore trouver H5
quelle ressource pariane nepomashi roi
G2 et il le trouve il le trouve mesdames
et messieurs et maintenant le fou qui va
diriger vers B2 s'en est peut-être
terminé de Yann
Yann qui va peut-être voir un deuxième
match de championnat du monde lui filer
entre les doigts
le fou qui va réunir se planter en B2 et
à la ça va être quasiment impossible de
défendre après il va y avoir l'échange
en C1 A2 dam B1 et à 8 ans il y aura
peut-être encore un petit quelque chose
allez il envoie encore un pion il en
sacrifiant il va en envoyer un deuxième
il y aura d'un F5 je crois mais oui
maintenant il y a dame F5 la dame qui va
plus être dérangé
attention oui
qui est en train de devenir champion du
monde d'échec Fabien peut-être le 1er
joueur chinois à se placer sur le trône
des cinq il tente un dernier clouage
il y a pas de me prend à deux mais il y
a peut-être G3 de l'autre côté un coup à
gauche un coup à droite
[Musique]
j'ai deux rois en pousser trois fous des
deux et c'est un échec et mat
on va on va le vivre on va le vivre ce
moment ensemble 1er joueur chinois
champion du monde mesdames et messieurs
à deux jouets à deux jouets ouais ça a
l'air d'aller aussi ça menace à un dame
et sur dame prend à deux il y aura fou
point F4 je crois qu'il y a plus rien à
faire pour Yann il va s'incliner le
rictus sur sa tête regarde ça y est
c'est terminé il sait qu'il a perdu il
sait qu'il a perdu à ce moment-là il est
dégoûté il a compris que c'était terminé
15h13 dame prend à deux il va le jouer
fou prend F4 regardez Mesdames et
Messieurs le visage des joueurs Yann
c'est qu'il a perdu match champion du
monde digly Rennes champion du monde
Fabien
incroyable incroyable il sera revenu et
Yann et curé qui tourne autour de
l'échiquier il sert la main de son
adversaire il y a quand même du respect
entre les deux hommes et dingly Rennes
incroyable ce qui vient de réaliser il
est passé proche de perdre ce match à
tellement de reprise et c'est lui qui
s'impose nouveau champion du monde Ding
Li Ren Fabien
bon bah bravo bravo bravo qui le
déportage bravo Monsieur bravo Monsieur
bravo deux au dessus à la fin mais bon
écoutez on a vu qu'un super moment
d'échec
une superbe passe d'armes
et et un très beau vainqueur d'un très
beau match qui aura finalement atteint
des sommets sur sur les départages et
qui laissera un goût sucré dans la
bouche de Ding mais de nous des
spectateurs
[Musique]
bravo pour le spectacle et merci pour
les émotions un match de championnats du
monde qui nous aura tenu en haleine
jusqu'à son dénouement
et c'est ça qu'on c'est ça qu'on
retiendra on va vous envoyer sûrement
red sur la chaîne de cheescom pour les
interviews pour les interviews des
joueurs et vous pourrez si vous le
souhaitez on essaiera de faire un récap
rapide on reviendra pas sur toutes les
parties ça va te faire vivre l'émotion
dans le récap et les moments importants
du départage sinon ça va durer trop
longtemps et ce serait pas intéressant
donc pour y suivre ça si vous le
souhaitez sur sur Youtube et on se
retrouve très bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures et merci encore à dinglieren
et Yann nepomashi pour
cette magnifique journée d'échec merci à
tous passés une excellent dimanche et un
bon week-end du 1er mai ciao ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]